sunday at noon eastern on c-span 2's
book tv
pulitzer prize-winning author robert
carro delivers the 2009 leon levy
biography lecture mr cairo remarks on
the yet to be published final book of
his multi-volume biography of lyndon
johnson
the graduate center at the city
university of new york hosts this
45-minute event
it's a pleasure for me to be giving the
leon levy lecture on biography
particular pleasure because leon and i
were friends
i still remember when i didn't know him
before i'd ever met him suddenly the
telephone rang and it was someone named
leon levy i did not i have to say at
that moment knew who he was
and he said have you read henry
kissinger's
phd thesis on prince medena
i said i hadn't he said well if i send
it to you can we have lunch and discuss
it
at that lunch i realized
this guy really knows history he really
knows biography
so when i heard that shelby was
establishing a biography center in
leon's honor
i thought
oh perfect
so it's a great pleasure to be here
giving a lecture named for him this
evening
i have to share this pleasure with the
team of researchers who have helped me
on all my books
it's a rather small team
actually
in fact it consists of only one person
she writes her own books of course
but she always finds time to help me
with mine
i'd like to say thank you to the only
person i've ever been able to trust with
my research
the whole team aina kara
[Applause]
the aspect of biography i want to talk
about this evening is something that in
my opinion is too seldom talked about
when we talk about biography giving the
reader a sense of place
by a sense of place i mean letting the
reader see in his mind's eye
the physical setting in which a book's
action is occurring
letting the reader see it clearly enough
so that he feels as if he was there in
that place while the action is occurring
to see it if he as if he was there
himself
and therefore the scene becomes more
vivid
more real to him
i feel that for a book to endure
that sense
the sense of place
must be present the greatest of books
the books that we feel are great because
we never forget them because in a way
they become part of ourselves
the greatest of books
are the books with places you can see in
your mind's eye
the deck of the pequod while the
barefoot sailors are hauling the parts
of a whale aboard to melt them down for
oil
the battlefield at borodino is napoleon
looking down from the hillside on his
mighty imperial guard has to decide
whether to wave them forward into battle
miss havisham's room
the room in which she was to have been
married the room in which she received
the letter that told her that the man
she loved wasn't coming
the room with the clock stopped forever
at the minute at which she got the news
the room with the wreckage of the
wedding feast that has never been taken
away
now as you have probably noticed the
three books i have mentioned melville's
moby dick tolstoy's war and peace and
dickens great expectations are all
novels works of fiction it is commonly
accepted in the world of literature that
a sense of place is important vital in
fact if a work of fiction is to endure
it goes without saying
i think
a sense of place is just as important in
non-fiction
that is i must say part of a belief that
i have that the entire quality the
entire level of writing the sense of
place and not just the sense of place
but also the choice of words the finding
of the right word the perfect word the
the precise best word
the finding of the right rhythm to put
the words into
is just as important in non-fiction
i feel that for a work of biography to
endure the quality of its prose must be
on the same level as a novel that
endures every so often i have to say i
find myself wondering if this belief of
mine is correct so a couple of summers
ago i did the following thing
i took the long historical novel war and
peace which i think considered most like
a long uh historical work of non-fiction
and i took gibbon's decline and fall of
the roman empire and i read a few
chapters of war and peace and then i
read a chunk of the decline and fall
then a few chapters of war and peace and
then a few chapters and given and i
found out that in my opinion that was
right in both those works the quality of
the prose of the writing
is at the same
level
and therefore
in my opinion part of what makes a book
in door is a sense of place now if that
goes without saying because it is
accepted and understood about fiction if
it goes without saying that a sense of
place is vital crucial in fiction that
is not the case with biography a sense
of place is very seldom mentioned in any
reviews of biography for example
so i decided to take this opportunity to
talk about it tonight
because in my opinion it's something
that needs saying
because biography is not just
about facts
the base of biography the base of all
history of course is the facts it's
always the facts you have to do your
best to get them right to come as close
to the truth as possible
but once you have them
i believe it's important not just to get
them down on paper
it's important to make the reader see
the place in which they're happening so
they can see the scene and be involved
in the scene
if you see the scene for yourself
in your mind
then you can understand things that the
writer doesn't have to tell you
you can understand them for yourself
what's one thing well since places evoke
emotions in people when they are in them
of course they evoke the emotions in the
people i am writing about in robert
moses or lyndon johnson or for that
matter al smith or sam rayburn or
richard russell
therefore
if you can describe truly enough the
setting in which a scene takes place and
if you have previously described the
character truly enough
the reader will better understand the
emotions that the place evoked in that
character if the place is important
enough in the character's life
if on the most basic level he spent
enough time in it
was brought up in it for example
or presided over it
or exercised power in it
if the place that setting played a
crucial role in shaping the character's
feelings drives and motivations his
insecurities and securities then by
describing the place well enough the
author will have succeeded in bringing
the reader closer to an understanding of
the character
without giving him a lecture
will have made the reader therefore not
just understand
but empathize with the character will
have made the reader's understanding
more vivid deeper than a lecture would
do
in the case of lyndon johnson two
settings played a role in understanding
him in understanding his role in history
in understanding how he came to power
and how he wielded power two places
the place he came from the texas hill
country
and the place he came to when he was
still a very young man capitol hill
the first place was really hard for me
to understand i as you can probably tell
from my accent
i'm in new york
i've spent my whole life here basically
uh
in these crowded streets crowded hall
with theaters cultural events
lively conversation all the time to some
extent i understand that world
but when i started doing the johnson
book there used to be like a 9 30 plane
every morning and some mornings i'd be
in new york in that world
i'd take the plane you'd fly to austin
at the austin airport you'd rent a car
and you drive west into the texas hill
country
and on those days that i did that i felt
that i was going in the same day from
one end of the world to the other you
know the hill country the geologic name
for it is the edwards plateau it's 24
000 square miles that's enough square
miles to put all of new england and
pennsylvania into it and still have some
miles left over the early set it
stretches west it starts right at austin
and stretches west 300 miles 300 miles
of one range of hills after another the
first settlers who came there called it
the land of endless horizons because
every time you came to the top of one
rise of hills there would be more rises
stretching ahead
looking back on
my work on johnson i think i realized i
should have realized the very first trip
that i made out there that i was
stepping into a world getting into
something i really didn't understand and
wasn't prepared for
i still remember you drove west out of
austin and about 41 miles west divorced
and you come to the top
of a what they call round mountain but
it's really just a high hill
and as i came to the top of that
suddenly there was something in front of
me that made me pull over to the side of
the road and get out of the car and look
at what i was seeing because what i was
seeing was something i had never seen
before
it was a huge empty space it's i later
found out it's a valley it was 40 miles
long and only 15 miles a
course
when i stood there looking down on it
the first time for a moment for a few
minutes i didn't see a single sign of
human beings in it then something
happened the
cloud moved from in front of the sun or
whatever
and suddenly the sun was glinting off in
the middle of this empty space a little
huddle of houses
that little huddle of houses was johnson
sitting when lyndon johnson was growing
up there there were 363 people there
when i got there there were 372
but as i stood there i realized that
really i was looking at something like i
had never seen before in its emptiness
it's loneliness it's isolation
at that time einer and i were working in
the johnson library and what we had
worked out as a way to work was we i
would work from nine to five would both
work from nine to five and then i would
drive out each night into the hill
country to find one of the people to
interview one of the people who would
have grown up with lyndon johnson or
gone to college with lyndon johnson who
were part of his first political machine
he died so young in 1973
and i was starting the book in 1976 that
most of the people were still there who
knew him still living in johnson city so
i could talk to them
and i thought that that would be enough
research on his youth on his youth in
the hill country because at the time i
started there were already 17
biographies of lyndon johnson in print
and they all had
stuff on his youth so i i really thought
i had enough stuff i just needed some
more color and i'd get it by these
interviews but when i started to talking
to the people i came to realize and i
came back and said to aina one night you
know i'm not understanding these people
they're more a's their values are too
different from mine since i'm not
understanding them i can't be
understanding lyndon johnson i said
we're going to have to move there niner
of course
so
einer of course does books on france so
she said why can't you do a biography of
napoleon
but as she always did
she said sure and for three we rented a
house
actually on the edge of the hill country
up towards johnson city and for most of
three years uh for parts greater parts
of three years we lived there and as
soon as we
moved up there everything changed you
know the people of the hill country were
so sick of reporters they used to call
them portable journalists that they said
would come to the hill country for a
week
and go back and tell their readers what
it was really like with landry lyndon
johnson grew up
as soon as they realized that we were
staying there that we had come to stay
and try to understand it they talked to
you on a whole different level you
started to get a whole different
understanding of what
life was like there when lyndon johnson
was young when i look back on my
notebooks where i take my notes from the
interviews with these people for those
years i find over and over the word poor
written
there was a level of poverty there that
a city person can hardly imagine when
lyndon johnson was growing up there was
no cash around there there was no cash
you could get a dime for a dozen eggs
you sold a dozen eggs but you had to
sell them in marble falls and marble
fools was 22 miles away from johnson
city and a friend of lyndon johnson ben
crider
relates how he
rode horseback the 22 miles between
johnson city and marble falls carrying
those dozen eggs in front of them like
this so that they wouldn't break just
for a dime
lonely is a word that was over and over
again in my notes
kind of loneliness that you can't
imagine that i couldn't imagine growing
up in new york city
i sam houston johnson lyndon johnson's
brother
once told me how
i one lyndon johnson didn't even grow up
in johnson city small that it was he
grew up on the johnson ranch which was
18 miles beyond johnson city further out
into the hills one corner of that ranch
came down near the austin what they
called the austin fredericksburg road
which was really not a road but a rutted
graded
path really between austin and
fredericksburg but one corner of the
ranch came down there and sam houston
johnson would tell me how he and lyndon
used to sit on that fence for hours when
they were little boys hoping that one
rider or carriage would come by so
they'd have one new person to talk to
the houses in that area you know when
you see them and you learn them that you
call them log cabins in texas they call
them dog runs because they're two
separate little rooms they're just one
room often
and in the center is an open space
where basically the dogs sleep and they
call them door runs so i tried to get a
feeling i felt if i was going to
understand lyndon johnson had to try to
get a feeling for what such loneliness
was like because i knew his mother
rebecca was deeply affected by it and um
johnson felt it so what i decided to do
so i wanted to say of course you can't
do that but i decided the best i could
do
was to try to spend a whole day by
myself in the hills then spend the night
there wake up the next day and still
there'd be no one there
so when i took a sleeping bag by that
time the johnson family was already i
hadn't published anything but they were
already completely opposed to these
books
so i couldn't do it on the johnson ranch
but i did it on a neighboring ranch i
spent the day i slept the night in the
sleeping bag and the next day
i
went there and you know you find out
different things that you could never
realize uh unless you did it
how sounds in the night little animals
knowing on uh tree branches or something
are so frightening how important small
things become
so i i i felt that i wrote so i tried to
explain that what i wrote in that first
volume is
when rebecca walked out the front door
of that little house there was nothing
a road runner streaking behind some
rocks with something long and wet
dangling from his beak perhaps
or a rabbit disappearing around the bush
so fast that all she really saw was the
flash of a white tail
but otherwise nothing
there was no movement except for the
ripple of the leaves and the scattered
trees
no sound except for the constant whisper
of the wind
if rebecca climbed almost in desperation
the hill and back of the house
what she saw from its crest was more
hills
an endless vista of hills
hills on which there was visible not a
single house
hills on which nothing moved
empty hills with above them empty sky
a hawk circling silently overhead was an
event
but most of all there was nothing human
no one to talk to
if men loved texas
a histo texas historian wrote if men
loved texas women hated it
in diaries and letters a thousand
separate farm wives left the record of
fear
that this country would drive them mad
not only brutally hard work but
loneliness what he called nauseating
loneliness was the light of the hill
country farm wife
loneliness and dread
during the day there might be a bit now
lyndon johnson's father being a state
legislature was often away from home and
rebecca was there alone with her
children
loneliness and dread
during the day there might be a visitor
or at least an occasional passerby on
the rutted road
at night there was no one no one at all
no matter in what direction rebecca
looked not a light was visible
the gentle dreamy bookish woman would be
alone
alone in the dark
sometimes when clouds covered the moon
in pitch dark
alone in the dark when she went out on
the porch to pump water or out to the
barn to feed the horses
alone with the rustlings and the trees
and the sudden splashes in the river
which could be a fish jumping
or a small animal drinking
or someone coming
i tried to give that picture of
loneliness her hatred lyndon johnson's
mother's hatred of this life the
loneliness of the life the physical toil
without electricity of course not going
to talk about it tonight because i've
talked about it in lectures before but
the fact that the women on the hill
country had to do all the chores because
there was no electricity there were no
washing machines uh there were no pumps
to pump water every bucket of water that
you had to use for cooking or for
washing or for any other purpose the
housewives had to pull up because the
men of course were out in the fields
working all day and as soon as the kids
got big enough to work they had to be
out in the field so all this water had
to be raised by uh by the women of the
hill country and lyndon johnson's desire
to change that life
his insight that it could be changed by
bringing electricity to the hill country
his realization that no private company
would
spend the money to to extend these
thousands of miles of wires to these
isolated single homes
his genius as a young congressman and
mobilizing the powers of government
against almost impossible odds to bring
electricity and the fact that it did
change the lives of these people
you see the seeds of the whole great
society and lyndon johnson's youth if
you see
if i succeeded in making the readers see
in his mind's eye
the place in which lyndon johnson grew
up
i came to feel that everything i was
learning about the later lyndon johnson
was informed by having been in that
place where he grew up and there were
other lessons
you know i kept hearing i became great
friends with all these people and
they're all farmers and ranchers out
there they'd keep saying to me you're a
city boy
you don't under understand the land and
if you don't understand the land you can
never understand lyndon johnson well i
don't know what that sounds like to you
but to me it sounded like a line from a
very bad western
but then there came a moment when i
realized just how wrong i was about that
line you don't understand the land so
you can't understand lyndon johnson has
to do with his father
i
you can't get very deep into the lyndon
johnson story without realizing that the
central fact of his life
was his relationship with his father his
brother sam houston johnson said to me
the most important thing in lyndon
johnson's life was not to be like daddy
his father who was named sam ely johnson
looked remarkably like lyndon johnson
they were both over six feet tall they
both had big ears they both had that big
juror they both had the habit sam when
he was in the legislature that lyndon
had in the senate of putting his arm
around you grabbing his lapel and
leaning into he was very much like
lyndon johnson he was a wonderful
legislator an idealistic legislator uh
a a
very popular one
and um passed a lot of laws he was known
then as a man of great optimism they
said sam johnson is a man of great
optimism he'd always fight for his
idealistic causes but he had a romantic
streak he was a dreamer and he was a
very bad businessman
i this streak kept them from looking at
hard facts
and that really cost them
uh once the johnson family had owned the
great johnson ranch in the days of the
great cattle drives up on the criticalis
river the family had lost the ranch some
decades before then it came on the
market and sam johnson determined to buy
it back to create the johnson ranch
again now the reason however that the
ranch had gone
had been lost was that the soil had
washed away
when they started to graze cattle and
grow cotton on it and there was wasn't
very much soil left on top of the rock
you couldn't do anything with it it
looked beautiful
when you go out there the grass covers
everything the live oak trees it's
beautiful but there isn't anything you
can do with that land and sam didn't
realize that he saw how beautiful it was
and he had this romantic dream of
restoring the johnson ranch so he
thought that he was going to make it
pay
and he overpaid for the ranch he paid so
much that the ranch could never
earn back uh what he paid for it
and he went broke very quickly they lost
the ranch and in fact the whole story of
lyndon johnson's youth you know is the
story of what happened after that the
insecurity they lost the ranch they
moved to a little house in johnson city
they almost lo every month lyndon
johnson had to live with the fear that
the bank was going to take that house
away
uh he lived in a house in which there
was often no food because his father had
gotten sick after this he was broken by
this financial failure
and there was often no food and
neighbors brought covered plates
lyndon johnson earned money when he was
18 and 19 years old he worked for almost
two years driving a fresno we in new
york can't even imagine what a fresno is
a fresno is what you used to grade these
unpaved highways back then it's a big
slab of iron with when the front edge is
sharpened and handles have been soldered
onto each side
so the driver of a fresno hole puts a
hand on each handle and as the mule
pulls he pushes the sharp edge of the
thing through the ground this hard
caliche ground to try and level the road
and because both his hands are occupied
one on each handle
he loops the reins around his back and
ties him behind his back so that as i
roll lyndon johnson was really in
harness with the mules for all these
hours every day he lived with his
father's mistake his father's one great
mistake all his youth now i had this
when i thought i had this a romantic
idea about sam that he was such a great
legislator
uh
fighting for people and all then one day
his cousin ava said to me i could tell
she really didn't like when i talked
about sam that way
she said
let's drive out to the johnson ranch
so we drove out to the johnson ranch and
you got there and it's this beautiful
those of you it looks beautiful
and she said get out of the car i got
out of the car ava was an old woman but
a very forceful woman she said now
now kneel down
and i knelt down she said now stick your
fingers into the ground and i stuck my
fingers into the soil and i couldn't
even get them into the ground the length
of my fingers there wasn't any soil on
top of that rock there was enough to
grow the beautiful grass but not enough
to to
grow cotton or graze cattle you couldn't
do anything like it and aver said to me
you see
sam didn't really see
he didn't want to see
it looked so beautiful
in other words she was saying
he didn't see the reality of it
the reality the hard unblinking facts he
fooled himself
now what's the relationship of this
to lyndon johnson's political activities
of all lyndon johnson's political
abilities and he had so many remarkable
political abilities one of the most
remarkable is his ability to count votes
to no one
to know in advance
which way a congressman or a senator and
when he was majority leader he had to
know every every senator because he was
often operating then during his six
years as majority leader he often had a
one-vote majority 48 democrats
47 republicans and wayne morris was the
independent to know how every senator
was going to vote on a particular motion
or piece of legislation vote counting
accurate vote counting to be right in
your account when you have to be right
is a very rare ability a very difficult
art sometimes the senator himself is
torn between conflicting pressures or
beliefs one day he feels he's going to
vote i the next day he feels is going to
vote nay it's sometimes very difficult
to know where at the end and the roll
call himself he is going to come down
sometimes the senator doesn't know
himself
until the very last minute where he's
going to come down and there's another
reason vote counting is difficult which
relates particularly to the place of
lyndon johnson's youth
vote counting is one is a very vital
political art but it's a really hard one
to master very few people can master it
because
it is
subject to the distortions of sentiment
and romantic preconceptions
a person psychologically or
intellectually convinced of the
arguments on one side of a controversial
issue
feels that of course arguments so
convincing to him must be equally
convincing to others as well and
therefore most people tend to be much
more optimistic in their accounts than
the situation deserves true believers i
were always inclined to attribute more
votes to their side than actually
existed
but lyndon johnson never had that
trouble
he had seen firsthand
when his father failed
the cost of wishful thinking
of hearing what one wants to hear
of failing to look squarely at his
reality
when his father that man of great
optimism sentimentally attached to the
old johnson ranch purchased it for a
price higher than was justified by the
hard financial facts
lyndon johnson had felt firsthand the
consequences of romance and sentiment
every time the reigns of the fresno bit
into his back
now of all the aspects of lyndon johnson
that impressed people
vote counting in washington was the most
impressive and over and over when i was
interviewing in washington i said he's
the greatest vote counter who ever lived
he had his lessons for his staff he
would send his staff to talk to senators
and find out what way they were going to
vote
and the thing that got him
well you can't say angriest since he was
often angry is often flying into these
terrible rages but one thing that would
set off these rages was a staff member
who came back and said something like i
think he's going to vote this way
johnson would say
snarl at him really
what good is thinking to me
i need to know
bobby baker who was his chief boat
counter
said to me he never wanted to be wrong
never i learned i had better never be
wrong
people would describe this vote counting
of ability in me in terms of or
of not quite understanding where this
ability came from he knew every vote as
if it was almost supernatural but
because of that trip i made out to the
johnson ranch in fact that's that's a
word that was used to mean washington it
was almost supernatural how he knew how
the vote was going to go but because of
that trip i had made out to the johnson
ranch with ava i felt that lyndon
johnson's vote counting ability was in
some ways the very opposite of
supernatural
to some extent it was completely natural
born in nature
born in the place that lyndon johnson
was from
i always felt i understood at least part
of the explanation and that part was
placed the place from which he came that
texas hill country he had learned the
consequences of one mistake you know
when he was counting votes in the senate
he used to stand in the center of the
senate cloak room with a senate tally
sheet it's a long sheet of paper with
the with the names of the then 96
senators and a blank space for how they
were going to vote next to him you'd
stand in the center of that road in room
and aides would be coming up to him in
senators and he would be counting the
votes and when you look at these
tally sheets which is still available in
the johnson library you see smudges in
the numbers and the smudges are lyndon
johnson's thumb
because he would right take his thumb
and he would the thumb would pause at
the name of each senator
and they said you know his thumb would
never move until he knew how that
senator would vote you want to
understand him doing that think of the
land think of the place think of the
sheer ruthlessness of it it's not a city
where you have welfare you fail in the
country you lose the your place where
your family lives
i'm not going to i've talked on many
occasions about the ruthlessness of
lyndon johnson i'm not going to go into
that tonight i'll just sum it up in in
one
paragraph
a quote from some of you will remember
that senator from the state of
washington henry jackson scoop jackson
he was he served within the senate and
and was uh senator under the
presidencies of both jack kennedy and
lyndon johnson i asked him once what was
the difference
between kennedy and johnson
and
jackson said well you know kennedy was
so charming he would have if he needed a
senator's vote he would have him down to
the white house he would explain how
badly he needed to vote but if the
senator said that if he gave him this
vote it would ruin him with the state it
would ruin him with his constituency
kennedy would understand
lyndon johnson
scoop jackson said
wouldn't understand
would threaten you or cajole you
or bribe you or charm you he would do
whatever he had to but he would get the
vote i feel that's the significance of
the place lyndon johnson came from and
how about the place he came to
capitol hill
he came there as a 23 year old assistant
to a texas congressman
uh then they called him a secretary to a
congressman his whole life
he'd only had one ambition but it was
going to start on capitol hill when he
was on that road gang went driving to
fresno when they broke for lunch the he
would start talking to the other men
about how he was going to be president
of the united states one day
uh jim roh and washington insider once
said to me from the moment he got here
there was only one thing he wanted to be
president but when i started talking to
the people who knew lyndon johnson when
he started out in washington as a 23
year old it almost seemed to me
is if i was again missing like i had
missed at first in the hill country if i
was again missing something something
very vague
something that i wasn't adequately
describing in my writing
i wasn't understanding
the depth of what these people were
telling me about the power of his
determination maybe about the willpower
the will he had to get ahead about the
frenzy desperate quality he sometimes
had the desperation to get ahead and to
get ahead fast as if somehow
the passions the ambitions that he
brought to washington
strong though they were was somehow
intensified by the fact
that he was finally there
in the place where he had always wanted
to be
i wanted i guess the show in terms of
washington to show in terms of capitol
hill the contrast between what he was
coming from the poverty the insecurity
the land of log cabins and what he was
trying for i first got a clue about how
i might be able to do this really from
the young woman who worked with him as
the other assistant in that
congressman's office a woman named
estelle harbin i asked her what he had
been like and she described them was a
vivid description she called him a real
tall thin boy
he was gangling he was skinny he was
awkward those big ears sticking out his
clothes didn't fit him well he had long
arms and and the shirts were never long
enough and his wrists were always
sticking out of the
collars later lyndon johnson got a
mistress who taught him to wear
cufflinks to correct that problem but
that was some years in the future
he was very poor he'd come to washington
with a cardboard suitcase and the only
coat he had was a thin top coat and in
the uh and he came up there in the
winter and when i i said well what would
he say to you you know she said well he
couldn't stop talking about the train
that he had come to washington on he
couldn't stop talking about the train he
was saying have you ridden in the
pullman i never did until i came up have
you ever eaten in a dining car i never
did when he received his first monthly
paycheck he told miss horgan that he
wanted to deposit it in a bank but that
he didn't know how to open a bank
account he had never had one
now
she also told me how quickly lyndon
johnson learned how desperately he
learned how he became the great best
congressional assistant there ever was
one thing that got me
was that she said
when he came to work in the morning
he was always out of breath
because he had been running
now he lived as i said in this little
hotel it was called the dodge hotel it
was down by union station a little brick
hotel he lived in a basement room with
exposed steam pipes
and in the morning his office was in the
house office building so his route to
work he'd come up from that hotel
up capitol hill and then cross in front
of the entire walk in front of the
entire long eastern facade of the
capital and then continue down to the
house office building now as it happens
he'd be coming this way and as tell
harmon lived somewhere over there and
sometimes she'd be coming this way and
she would come early
and she would see lyndon johnson coming
up capitol hill and she said to me every
time he got in front of the capitol
he would start running
well i wanted the reader to feel all
this
i wanted not just to say
that he was coming from poverty a land
of little dog run cabins
and trying for something monumental
i wanted to make the reader see the
contrast
between
coming from
and what he was trying for
the majesty and the power of what he was
trying for i wanted to make the reader
see this and feel this
i kept feeling that the key to doing
that to showing that
somehow
was on the walk
up capitol hill
so i would keep taking that walk over
and over again i'm sure i don't know how
many times i took it but it was a lot of
times but i didn't
see anything there so obviously
something on that walk had excited him
and thrilled him so much that he'd break
into a run
every morning
and
i wasn't seeing anything like that then
i thought of something although i had
taken this walk
i had never done it at the time that
lyndon johnson did it which was very
early in the morning about 5 30 in the
morning in the summers about 6 30
in in winter
so i decided to try doing that
to see if there was something
and there was it was something i had
never seen before because at 5 30 and
the sun is just coming up in the
over the horizon the full force of its
rays are striking that eastern front of
the capitol it's lit up like a movie set
and then i felt i had found a way
not to lecture the reader on the poverty
that lyndon johnson was coming from
and what he was striving towards and how
much he wanted what he was striving
towards
not to lecture the reader but to show
the reader that instead
i don't know if i succeeded in doing
that or not
but anyway for whatever it's worth
here's what i wrote about when lyndon
johnson first came to
washington can someone turn that off
well here's what i wrote about when
lyndon johnson first came to washington
he lived in the basement of a shabby
little hotel
in a tiny cubicle across whose ceiling
ran bare steam
it slid of a window stared out across a
narrow alley
at the weather-stained red brick wall of
another hotel
leaving his room early in the morning
lyndon johnson would turn left down the
alley walking between the red brick
walls of other shabby hotels
but when he turned the corner at the end
of that alley
suddenly before him at the top of a long
[Music]
suddenly before him at the top of a long
gentle hill
it would be not brick
wobble a great shadowy mass of marble
marble columns and marble arches and
marble parapets
and a long marble balustrade high
sky
veering along the path to the left he
would come up capitol hill and around
the corner of the capital and the marble
of the eastern facade
caught by the early morning sun
would be a gleaming brilliant almost
dazzling light
a new line of
towering columns
marble for magnificence and corinthian
for grace stretched ahead of him
a line of columns so long that columns
seemed to be marching endlessly before
him
the long freezers above them crammed
with heroic figures
and columns loomed not only before him
but above him
there were columns atop columns
columns in the sky
for the huge dome that rose above the
capitol was circled by columns not only
in its first mighty upward thrust
where it was rimmed by 36 great pillars
for the 36 states that the union had
comprised when it was built
it was circled by columns also high
above
300 feet above the ground
where just below the statue of freedom a
circle of thirteen smaller more slender
shafts with the thirteen original states
created a structure that looked like a
little temple in the sky
adding a grace note to a building as
majestic and imposing
as the power of the sovereign state that
had been that it had been designed to
symbolize
and as lyndon johnson came up capitol
hill in the morning
he would be running
sometimes the woman who worked with him
coming to work in the morning
would see the gangling figure running
awkwardly
arms flapping past the long row of
columns on his way to the house office
building beyond the capitol
at first
because it was winter and she knew that
he owned only a thin top coat and that
his only suits were lightweight
tropicals she thought he was running
because he was cold
but in spring
the weather turned warm and still
whenever she saw lyndon johnson coming
up capitol hill
he would be running
well of course he was running
a land of dog run cabins to this
everything he had ever wanted everything
he'd ever hoped for was there
and that gigantic stage
lit up by the brilliant son
that place that front of the capital
showed him that
showed him that
and if i could write it right would show
the reader
as i said at the beginning of this talk
i felt that a sense of place could help
to explain lyndon johnson to a reader
that through a sense of place i could
make the reader understand what lyndon
johnson was striving for not by
lecturing the reader but by showing him
what lyndon johnson saw i don't know if
i succeeded in that or not but that was
what i tried to do i see i've run on
long but if i could do things short i
wouldn't always be writing thousand page
books
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Applause]
robert carro is the author of the power
broker robert moses and the fall of new
york
and a multi-volume biography of lyndon
johnson that includes titles that won
the national book award in 2002 and
pulitzer prize in 2003
the graduate center at the city
university of new york hosted this event
for more information visit
web.gc.cuny.edu
llcb
this weekend on c-span 2's book tv the
interrogation techniques used very much
author robert carroll give us an update
on your lbj
volume well i'm doing the fourth one for
the third one i got the national book
award here about five years ago
and i'm well this is a long book and i'm
sort of in the middle of it now it's you
know lyndon johnson president
civil rights vietnam
turning points in american history so
it's an interesting book to do
interesting for me to try to do it when
do you foresee it being finished i think
i have about two more years work on this
how many years of your professional life
have been devoted to lyndon johnson
well i started
i have to date it back the power broker
came out in 19 that was my first book by
robert moses came out in 1974
and i started in 76 on lyndon johnson so
do i want to add this up it's 33 years
what first sparked you
your interest in lbj
a good question i you know i never look
at my books as biographies i never want
to do a book just about a great man but
i'm interested in this political power
and how it works and using a man's life
to show it so with robert moses i tried
to show how urban power works in cities
with lyndon johnson i said well he
understood national power better than
almost anyone so if i can you take his
life i can show how national power works
and you say you won for the third uh in
your in your series you won the national
book award what's the effect of that
well the effect on it
the effect on me was terrific i was
happy to win it
did it change book sales did it anything
like that
um
i'm not sure i know i remember the
answer to that question to be honest
with you uh
it did very
you know it was
that book did well i can't remember if
this uh
had an impact or not i'm sorry author
robert carroll
author robert carroll what are you
reading i'm reading right now re-reading
the prime minister by anthony trollope
he wrote six political novels they call
in the palace and novels about 18
england in the 1870s
wonderful political understanding of how
human human beings and politics how
human nature influences politics why are
you rereading those
i just think he's got such a wonderful
well first i said sentences are great
his paragraphs are great you say boy how
did he do this so i'm always looking to
see how he did it but even more than
that
i write about
how human nature i try to write about
how human beings and presidents and
cabinet ministers are affected by being
in politics and how their human nature
affects political decision and he's
really doing the same
thing uh
in a fictional way and as i try to learn
from him
american icons three percy movement
recently presidential biographers met to
discuss and evaluate barack obama's
presidency
historians robert carro and hw brands
and journalist george packer sat down
with abc news correspondent lynn scher
at the hamptons institute
this is an hour and 25 minutes start off
by telling you in one of those great
moments i actually driving over here
this afternoon found myself behind a car
with an obama 08 bumper sticker on it
my initial reaction was thank goodness
there's somebody who keeps a car as long
as i do
and then i looked closely and i realized
that the bumper sticker was a little
worn
a little abused by the elements uh but
in fact of course it was still quite
legible and it was still very red white
and blue and not to be too silly or glib
about this but i did wonder if that was
some kind of metaphor uh for what this
president is now going through
how successful is he how bruised in fact
is he
how to paraphrase ed koch is he doing
i want to start out by saying that also
if i were president obama i am not so
sure i would want to be here this
afternoon to hear the answer
uh with all due respect the idea of
being discussed and dissected by the
biographers of lyndon baines johnson and
franklin delano roosevelt
and by a new yorker writer who has said
and i quote he mr obama is not that
messianic figure that many of his
supporters think he is i think that
would be daunting to everyone
i do not mean to suggest that any of
these gentlemen is prepared to draw or
quarter the president in fact some of
them have written and said very fine
things about him and his campaign
uh some of them may or may not have
voted for him
uh two of them bob carrow and h.w brands
actually had dinner with the president
at the white house earlier this week and
that is all i could find out from either
of them about what went on there
and that will be the end of that
conversation
um some of these gentlemen have also
indicated however differences between
our 44th president and the men and yes
of course they are all men who preceded
them some felicitously some not so
each one of the panelists has very deep
insights into what a president um should
do what makes a president a president
what makes him succeed and endure and in
fact what can bring him down
so just over two and a half years into
the obama presidency what better time to
discuss this
and 16 months yes we have 16 months to
endure all of the nonsense 16 months
before the next election
what more critical subject so let's
begin with an introduction and the
introduction oh by the way just to make
the rules clear we're going to um
play among ourselves up here and let you
listen in and talk about some very
interesting points i hope and then i'll
be opening it up to questions from you
so please get your questions ready
because we do want to hear from you in
just a bit
so i'm going to introduce everybody just
in the order in which we're seated
um george packer
george became a staff writer for the new
yorker in 2003 and has covered the iraq
war for the magazine his book the
assassins gate america in iraq was named
one of the top excuse me one of the 10
best books of 2005
by the new york times and that among
many other awards that he won for that
book
um george backer has also written about
some of the most inhospitable countries
in west africa
and not in 2003 he got two overseas
press club awards
one about the occupation and
reconstruction of iraq the other about
the civil war in sierra leone
he is the author of the village in
waiting about his experience in africa
uh he is also the author of the book
blood of the liberals a
three-generational non-fiction history
of his family and american liberalism in
the 20th century which won the robert f
kennedy book award he's written two
novels and a new a newer book
interesting times writing from a
turbulent decade he served in the peace
corps in togo in west africa
and is currently working on a book about
and this is a quote from him
institutional decline in america a small
subject welcome to george packer thank
you lynn
thank you all
[Applause]
i'm glad to have beaten the traffic in
bridgehampton
two minutes before the event was to
begin george um george drove out from
brooklyn and nobody gave him the back
road map so here he is
uh bob carrow who who many of you know
because he is one of us and lives right
out here
um as you well know has written
extraordinary truly
adjective-busting biographies for his
biographies of robert moses and lyndon
johnson he twice won the pulitzer prize
for biography twice won the national
book critic
critic circle award for best non-fiction
book of the year and has gotten
virtually every other major literary
honor including the national book award
the gold medal and biography and the
emit from the american academy of arts
and letters and on and on and on and on
and i would love to read them all but
i'd rather get to our subject in a
minute um his first book was of course
the power broker robert moses in the
fall of new york
the modern library called one of the
hundred greatest non-fiction books of
the 20th century i would say echoing uh
the words of many many before me and
still to come that it is the single best
book about a city and certainly our city
new york city that you will ever read
uh to research the years of lyndon
johnson his ongoing biography bob and
his wife aina moved from new york to the
texas hill country and then to
washington dc to literally live the life
that lyndon johnson lived as he was
growing up and getting started
his first book in the series the path to
power was called by the washington post
proof that we live in a great age of
biography they called it a book of
radiant excellence the second volume was
called by professor henry graf of
columbia brilliant no review does
justice to the drama of the story caro
was telling which is nothing less than
how present-day politics was born
and the third volume was hailed by the
london
times
as a masterpiece robert cairo has
written one of the truly great political
biographies of a modern age we are all
eagerly awaiting volume four welcome to
bob carrow
you were doing great until the last line
yeah i know bob hates it when you ask
when the next volume is coming out but
h.w brands who assures me that we may
call him bill
uh was born this is his first trip to
the east end of long island so a special
welcome to him for that
uh bill was born in oregon he went to
college in california he sold in the
family business he sold cutlery across
the american west for a while
and he earned graduate degrees in math
and history in oregon and texas he has
started vanderbilt at texas a m
and now he is at the university of texas
at austin where he is the
dixon allen anderson centennial
professor of history
bill writes on american history and
politics and his books include traitor
to his class andrew jackson the age of
gold the first american and tr
several of his books have been best
sellers two were finalists for the
pulitzer prize he lectures frequently on
history and on current events you can
see him on tv you can hear him on the
radio
and he is now working on a book about
yet another president ulysses s grant
please welcome h.w brands
thanks lynn
okay gentlemen welcome to all of you
let's start with just briefly an
assessment from each one of you on how
this president is doing is he the eat
your peas president or is he the i got
osama bin laden president or is it
something else and bob i'm going to let
you start it off
thanks
well the only thing i can say to you is
how we think he's doing is going to look
a lot different in some years than it
does now it always does if there's
anything i've learned from my books it's
that things look so different at the
time than they do a few years down
the road in fact i can just i can give
you an example from robert moses at
lyndon johnson robert moses was so
popular in new york city i went to
horace mann and what we had to write for
everybody in this in our class had to
write for their junior paper robert
moses is the perfect example of the
great night in literature right
then a great night yeah in literary
1950s and by the 1970s
he was the great villain of new york so
everything changes right so you're
saying um you're not going to answer my
question sure i i i will say that
i think
uh
things that look so important and vital
in the obama presidency right now
are going to look different for example
i mean we already you know the events of
the moment
are what captures everybody's attention
so it's seldom mentioned right now
that when he took office people were
walking around worrying about whether
they had more than a hundred thousand
dollars in the bank because the bank
might fail
or that he came to office with a war in
iraq
or that he came that was really
a problem
and that
he came most important he came to office
and no one really mentions this at the
very crest of the tide of conservatism
that you could say began
near the end of the lyndon johnson
presidency by over 40 years ago and has
just come to a crest and is crashing in
this uh
irrationality of the tea party movement
and these are all things he's had to
face that he stepped into so i think
that
however we feel about it now
history will look at these
more in the context of those things and
a lot of other things okay
bill let's go to you for another
history point of view or not history up
to you
i think president obama is doing about
as well as any president could under the
circumstances he became president and
was handed an extremely difficult hand
to deal with
it was difficult precisely because it
wasn't absolutely terrible
you probably remember the cover of is
was either time or newsweek right after
obama was elected where he was in that
franklin roosevelt pose and they had
photoshopped something so he had a cap
on his head and he had a cigarette
holder and the caption on the cover was
franklin delano obama
and there was some thought that obama
was going to usher in a new new deal
well in fact
a lot of obama's supporters hoped that
was exactly what was going to happen but
it wasn't going to happen
because things were bad but not bad
enough
if you recall when obama was elected the
unemployment rate was six percent
and
wall street was teetering and nobody
knew whether it was going to go over the
edge or not now what this meant was that
he had a huge challenge he had to deal
with
bad economic times but unlike franklin
roosevelt they weren't so bad that he
was free to do whatever he wanted
franklin roosevelt was elected after the
country had been in a full-blown
depression
for two and a half years
and in part because of this
americans generally gave him carte
blanche to do whatever he wanted to do
he could do no wrong because things were
so bad they couldn't get worse obama had
in mind that there were some major
changes to the american financial system
to the american system of governance but
he couldn't
undertake the steps to get there because
everything that he did had to be weighed
would it spook wall street would it make
this financial crisis a full-blown
depression now in fact the full-blown
depression did not occur
and one can argue that
well with these sort of things you never
know whether it would ever it wouldn't
have but
it did not occur and he ought to get
some credit for the fact that it did not
occur but he's not going to get credit
because in american politics you don't
get credit for things that didn't happen
you get credit or responsibility for
things that did happen and so
you know he
has managed the american economy about
as well as i think it could have been
managed given the opposition in congress
and the fact that he's got
republicans in control of the house of
representatives so i would say
that he has done about as well as could
be done under the circumstances but i
know there were plenty of people who
voted for him who were thinking this is
going to be a transformational president
it's not going to happen and it's not
going to happen because
the context is not right things are bad
but not bad enough enough
first time i've heard someone say
gee if they were worse off maybe he'd be
doing better but okay we'll get we'll
get back to that uh george packer how's
he doing
i think
he's he's been very surprising he he is
so different from the the candidate that
i think it's taken a long time for the
public to sort of catch up with the real
president that he is as opposed to the
figure
who sees the world's imagination
in 2008 when when he just streaked to
the to the nomination and then his his
meteor continued to rise to the election
he's actually
he is not a he is not a roosevelt he's
not a
figure
who would fit um
sort of a depression you're a new deal
era time he reminds me of an earlier
time maybe a progressive era figure
in his
high-mindedness
his cerebral qualities he's so
reasonable his his
speech is so lofty
and moralizing he's very comfortable
moralizing
he reminds me a little of wilson in that
sense he's a bit remote and aloof like
wilson and i think he would probably
have done better if he'd been governing
at a time closer to the progressive era
when there were
it was not one crisis after another
there was uh there was no fox news there
was no michele bachmann
it was
although there were rational tendencies
as they've always been in american
politics it was a time when an appeal to
sort of civic mindedness and political
reform
um and you know those higher qualities
actually had a real audience especially
among sort of the professional middle
classes across the country who were the
real backbone of the progressive
movement instead obama is a reasonable
man speaking into a hurricane all the
time
and that is why if his presidency has
fallen short i think
why it has he his policy you're you're
presenting a picture of a man who is at
odds with the times around him i think
so he may be behind and ahead at the
same time i think he's always three
steps ahead of the rest of the the sort
of ordinary politicians and perhaps of
the public i mean you mentioned i'm
writing a book about
about decline i think obama may well see
his job as to manage
as well as he can a period of american
decline i don't think that this is a
president who really believes uh that we
will describe the world like a colossus
again and i don't think he wants us he
said yesterday in that was at the second
or third press conference in a row on
the debt ceiling
he said and i can't do it verbatim some
version of
this is a time we have a chance to do
something big
we can make a big change he not not
bestriding the world but
what you're talking about
four trillion dollars from from the debt
yeah i mean of course he says that all
american presidents have to talk that
way but
there's a kind of a gap between
what we expect of the president and what
what i think obama is really thinking
which i can't be sure about but there's
a lot of indicators based on action um
the thing he's failed at is a strange
thing it's connecting to the public
this is what he did so well in 2008 but
since then he's had a terribly difficult
time
uh moving people persuading people being
heard above the noise of the hurricane
that's out there which is a political
hurricane an economic hurricane a
cultural hurricane a news hurricane
there's just so much
noise and obama is so thoughtful and so
unwilling to descend to the sound bites
and the cheap phrases that you
that a president actually needs in order
to
to reach the public in it in a deep way
i think he has failed to lead in that
sense and that's that is the
disappointment in his presidency this is
all the people who are saying i wish he
would just do something i wish he would
be the man that i voted for ask yourself
how many phrases can you remember from
his presidency
i mean
i can remember i could quote
based on the great books of these two
gentlemen
a dozen two dozen phrases from the first
couple of years of johnson's presidency
and of roosevelt there was something
called the new deal there was something
called the great society what phrases
stick from obama there are none audacity
of hope well that was before he became
president
and a great and
and my point is that since he's become
president he has been so consumed with
the
tremendous problems he inherited and in
coming up with
in his you know in his way reasonable
policy solutions it's almost as if he
can't do that
and reach out to the broad public with
those
memorable phrases that i think are part
of the java book which you have to have
bob carroll let me go back to you now
and talk a little bit about it the lbj
comparison which is
in so many ways a terrible comparison
but but maybe there are ways that aren't
start with the difference between the
way president johnson
got things done and the way this
president is or isn't getting things
done
how how did lyndon johnson get things
done i'll answer you with a quote from a
senator named scoop jackson from the
state of washington who served in both
the house of representatives and the
senate with johnson he said president
kennedy was a wonderful communicator he
said but when he needed a vote from a
senator he'd have the senator down to
the white house and he'd give them all
the reasoned arguments why he had to
have this vote but if the senator said
if i give you this vote it'll kill me
with my constituency kennedy would
always say i understand he said lyndon
johnson wouldn't understand
he said he would charm you or threaten
you or cajole you or bribe you he would
do whatever he had to but he would get
your vote and you see this with johnson
over and over again
you see him getting votes in the center
that you don't believe are possible to
pass his legislation and is this the
model
is is that what americans want for a
president do they want a lyndon johnson
who who cajoles and does
pick your verb of choice many many worse
things than that or do they want a more
reasoned diplomat who which is what our
current president appears to be well it
depends what lyndon johnson you're
talking about are you talking about the
lyndon johnson of 1964 and 1965 where he
passed medicare medicaid two great civil
rights bills which seemed impossible to
pass we don't even remember that and 70
separate education bills or are you
talking about the lyndon johnson of 66
67 and 68 where he's this figure who
deceived the american public who tried
to get us into a war who got us into a
war in asia
tried to do it basically as james reston
wrote he said the president this was
after johnson's first escalation of 125
000 troops which he did it on a saturday
because he thought it wouldn't get much
coverage on sunday and james reston said
the president of the united states got
us into a land war in asia last night in
secret
so it's it's you know
there's something to be said for a
president who establishes a persona i
think the persona that obama has
established is thoughtful
smart honest
calm
and is trying to negotiate his way
through which i think george's word a
hurricane
as best he can i think there's a lot to
be said for that
uh bill you you've written about another
wartime president to what extent
to what extent are these wars is there
any parallel with with with world war ii
with fdr or are these wars so utterly
different
uh that is that again back to the
hurricane word that he that he can't
make his way through it
the wars that the united states is
fighting in iraq and afghanistan and
maybe a little bit in libya are so
different from world war ii that there's
really no meaningful comparison
because
if
with this group if we weren't told that
there was a war going on in afghanistan
you'd hardly know it very few people
that i know have relatives who are
fighting in iraq or afghanistan it's a
war that's fought by an all-volunteer
which means professional army and so
i've have been on college campuses
teaching since the 1980s and there are
no protests against the war in iraq and
afghanistan
there is public public opinion poll
after public opinion poll shows that
americans think the united states needs
to get out of afghanistan but it gains
no traction because that opposition
there's nothing to mobilize the
opposition now with franklin roosevelt
one of the reasons a principal reason
that he was able to get so much done
during his the first hundred days which
by the way he had no idea that there was
going to be a hundred days he called
congress into emergency session to deal
with the fact the banking system was
collapsing so he was gonna send them
he's gonna send congress an emergency
banking bill and send them home but they
were so willing to go along with what he
sent that he's okay let's try something
else and one thing led to another and
led to another
and by the time he ran out of things to
send to congress a hundred days had
passed and so that became the yardstick
for all future presidents to be measured
by but roosevelt had huge majorities in
both houses of congress
and so he could get whatever he wanted
barack obama in essence had to deal with
a divided congress from his inauguration
now it's true that the democrats had
majorities in both houses but due to
changes in the
definition of a filibuster that still
somewhat confused me
nowadays to get anything through the
senate you have to have 60 votes and he
didn't have that and so he had to deal
with an opposition that decided to go
into opposition against his presidency
and mitch mcconnell said right at the
beginning that the first order of
business was to make sure that barack
obama was going to be a one-term
president well roosevelt didn't have to
deal with that and so obama's situation
was entirely different now there's
something else i think obama was the
victim of his own brilliance as a
campaigner i've been observing american
politics since the 1960s the first
campaign i vaguely remember was the 1960
campaign and i studied a lot of them and
i've never seen a politician other than
a victorious general they play by
different rules but an ordinary
politician who came out of nowhere
before the summer of 2004 almost nobody
had heard of barack obama and four years
later he is president of the next
elected president of the united states
and he was this individual who allowed
people to project onto him their hopes
for what america could be in a difficult
time and his campaign slogan yes we can
was absolutely brilliant yes we can what
whatever you want
well
that's fine for a candidate but once you
get elected the operative phrase is no
longer yes we can it's no you can't
because you have to tell you have to
choose when you're a candidate you don't
have to choose you let everybody believe
what they want to believe now it's also
worth remembering and you'll have your
own opinions on this but absent the
financial crisis of 2008
john mccain would be president of the
united states because as long as this
most salient issue was the war in iraq
and afghanistan
obama's background obama's biography
didn't measure up to mccain's but then
more or less out of the blue
the
the ground changed and wall street
shuttered
and mccain's
biography now as the military veteran
the war hero prisoner of war and all
this it no longer meant anything and so
people were willing to look at give
obama a close second look and they
decided okay it's time for a change
we'll give him a try well okay so now
he's president and all sorts of people
think that he's going to bring in this
grand new revolution this reform and all
this other stuff well it wasn't going to
happen because the crisis wasn't quite
deep enough he had to tread very
gingerly i happen to think i'm guessing
this but
i happen to think that obama is probably
waiting to get this debt ceiling issue
resolved one way or the other so he can
move back into campaign mode he's a
brilliant campaigner and i think he will
be able to connect with americans the
way he did in the campaign of 2008
because one of the things but based on
what what is what does he use as his
campaign well so good this year well
first i would say the only adult in
washington the only one who's dealing
with these is reasonable
but the thing is
polls show there was a recent poll to
show that 80 percent of americans think
that to deal with the debt ceiling in
the deficit there ought to be some
combination
of spending cuts and tax increases but
the trouble is that that particular
public is not the one that republicans
in the house of representatives are
responding to they're looking over their
right shoulders of a much smaller public
the one that will throw them out in the
primaries next season
if they vote for anything in the way of
a tax increase but once this issue is
off the table it will be off the table
in one way or another then he can reach
out to the broader american public i
think he does very well with the broad
public but if as long as the public is
split up between the democrats on one
side
republicans on the other then he can't
reach those republican zealots but he
can i think he can reach the broader
public so you're saying once we get by
august 2nd
he becomes he comes out of his um
pops out of the egg as a whole different
person or he goes back to who he was i
think he goes back to who he was in the
summer of 2008 when he can campaign
instead of having to govern oh and he's
because governing is always harder than
campaigning he's a better campaigner
than the government george
champing at the bit here well it's going
to be hard for him to do that because i
mean
during the two and a half years of his
presidency
forget about the official unemployment
rate the real unemployment rate
basically one in six americans is out of
work right now which is a staggering
number
it isn't quite 1930s levels but it's the
closest we've been since the 30s i think
what obama is i mean so that will be
what he has to account for throughout
the campaign and i honestly don't know
what the theme of his campaign is going
to be this is part of the deficiency i
see in his leadership he has not
articulated a vision that americans can
quickly
understand and either subscribe to or
not the only adult in washington is
basically who he is i'm not sure that's
a wildly successful uh campaign theme
what one thing that obama lacks that lbj
and fdr both had is a movement
fdr had eventually labor behind him he
also had all the discontents of the 30s
that
in some ways opposed him but eventually
uh once huey long was out of the picture
etc became you know this overwhelming
majority that brought him to reelection
in 36 lbj had the civil rights movement
pushing from below for what lbj
behind the scenes was
cajoling uh twisting arms flattering etc
to get done in congress there is no
movement behind obama the only movement
we've had since the biggest financial
crisis since the depression is the tea
party movement which is implacably
hostile to him they have filled a vacuum
obama couldn't create a movement but
i think once he became president that 10
million
named uh you know
the list of 10 million names that was
his email list
which was sort of the movement that
brought him to the presidency just
disappeared it went home they were no
longer being asked to do anything
and
without a movement in a critical time
like this it's very hard
for the president to
summon the troops in the in the in the
thick of a campaign in which he is going
to be on the hot spot because the
republicans are going to say one in six
americans is out of work so what do you
say to this
the driver of this car that i saw and
and innumerable people i've spoken to
who were obama supporters who are still
obama supporters who are nonetheless
disappointed they say
he's he's not speaking i voted for him i
will vote for him again but i'm not
getting what i want from him
that's politics i mean get over it
you know you you wanted a miracle worker
yes we can was the slogan of a miracle
worker you didn't get it you got a human
being who has amazingly you know amazing
qualities you you take them off very
very well bob well you know but what's
left out
is what is governing you know you talk
about the civil that they had movements
but turning a movement into laws i mean
what is governing in the democracy
governing in a democracy is passing laws
lyndon johnson called it writing it into
the books of lore he said we've talked
about civil rights for a hundred years
now it's time to write it into the books
of lords they had a civil rights
movement but the southerners controlled
congress no civil rights bill i'll go
back to the when he actually passed his
majority had passed
at senate in 87 years since
reconstruction
johnson
has to get this bill through it doesn't
matter that there's a civil rights
movement in the streets the southerners
are not going to let it through to watch
him do that is to see genius in the art
of government the southerners he works
out this deal where the southerner said
they'll let a weak bill pass and johnson
says that's enough the important thing
is to get something passed to show we
can pass something if we get a bill
passed we can always it can be a bad
bill but we can always go back and pass
it later i've got to get it passed it
gets the southerners to agree that
they'll allow a weak bill to pass as
long as they can be assured that if the
liberals try to amend it into a stronger
bill they will have a block of votes on
their side
to
sustain the filibuster and let them stop
it johnson knows he needs a block of
votes he's not within one or two votes
he's 10 or 12 votes short you can see
him in the in the memos in the johnson
library trying to figure out where can i
get 10 or 12 votes
and he figures it out
there's a dam on the river the snake
river between idaho and oregon it's
called the it's called the hell's canyon
dam and the westerners the rocky
mountain states westerners and there are
12 democrats there 12 democratic votes
they've been trying to get this damn for
20 years and the south has always
blocked it he goes to the westerners and
says i'll give you the dam if you agree
to vote with the south and they agree so
that he has in this one stroke linked a
dam in the northwest to the civil rights
movement and got it within
just within three or four votes of
passing and then lyndon johnson comes
into play he's he's still three now he's
got to get him one by one and to watch
him
know what these senators want and give
them what they want or withhold what
they want is to see this brutal
force but the end the result of it is
governance he has gotten the bill paid
okay and let me just add here um bob
told me the other day that when um
when he bob won the national humanities
medal in 2010 um
president obama said to him and i quote
i think about robert carro and reading
the power broker back when i was 22
years old and just being mesmerized and
it helped to shape how i think about
politics so the question is
what has president obama learned about
politics
sorry you asked me that
but i think that so far i think that the
things that george and bill said the
difficulties of doing this are really
very real but you know part of the
problem is senator obama was only a
senator for three years and for part of
that three years a large part of the
three years he was out campaigning
it's very hard to learn congress to
learn to learn the senate it's really
another world
uh so when you come in i like to think
that he's been on a learning curve you
know he strikes me as an extreme but on
the job learning is not what we want for
our presidents is it you know can i add
something about just throwing in uh
your story your your great story about
how obj got the 57 civil rights bill
passed
so the equivalent would be the health
care bill obama really needed every last
vote and i i studied that pretty
carefully i was in the senate a lot
during the the last votes
and you know he did it he got it done
against great odds i remember what it
was like when scott brown was elected in
massachusetts many democrats said forget
it we're never going to get this thing
done and obama basically was the one who
said we are along with nancy pelosi um
but
after the midterms i went down to
virginia the next day and to this
southwestern virginia which is my coal
mining country
the 30-year congressman there rick
boucher tremendously popular he had just
been defeated by someone who didn't even
live in the district it was like anyone
but the democrat and i asked a bunch of
people you know why would you throw out
this popular congressman who brought
home a ton of bacon to a poor area they
said you know
obama disappointed us we thought he was
a new kind of politician instead we saw
him wheeling and dealing
and trading you know uh medicaid
payments and the louisiana compromise
and and
dealing with the insurance companies in
the hospitals and giving everything away
in order to get this health care bill he
wasn't supposed to be that type in other
words obama's living in an age where
two hours after
the deal that lbj would cut with
whoever uh
was done the whole world knew and
and it's it's stomach turning and so
obama had to sort of
he he mastered legislation in that case
and it killed him
he didn't have to do that because what
lyndon johnson would have said is i
think i said the important thing is you
know he actually being lyndon johnson is
he was always trying to say the
important thing was to get a bill passed
he said we can always go back and fix it
he said once
once they lose the virginity it'll be
easier next time that's the guy i'm
writing about actually he's kind of got
a lot of phrases like that but he would
say we got her pissed and my feeling
actually is that obama could say the
same thing we have a health care bill it
will be easier to fix it than to pay us
a bill let's say i think it's a bad bill
i do think it's a bad bill but it'll be
easier to fix it than to start all over
again and pass another one and he did it
is it all about politics is it all about
whether he can govern and not living up
to campaign promises or how much of what
we're seeing now has to do with
personality bill is
is there historically a president who
has withstood so much comment about is
he too aloof is he not a loofah is he
not
down and dirty enough is he too down and
dirty is he is he not part of the group
the
the personality thing is astounding and
start with george washington
maybe the reason i say this is that
there is this notion that somehow
a semi-monolithic media has broken apart
into all these different
fractions
and that people now can watch fox news
if they don't want to hear what cnn has
to say you can choose your media outlet
and so you're not confronted with
with opinions that disagree with yours
well that was really the model of
american journalism in the 18th and 19th
century and there were newspapers that
were attuned to particular i mean
parties had their own newspapers
presidential administrations had their
own newspapers and so we're reverting to
that time now
this may or may not be coincidental but
it was also a time of relatively
generally weak and comparatively
insignificant presidents the presidency
achieved anything like its modern form
only with the beginning of the 20th
century but through the 19th century
congress was the dominant force in
american politics and everybody thought
that's the way it should be there were
brief exceptions to this they were all
crises like the civil war and
occasionally you'd get a force of nature
like andrew jackson
but until the 20th century the president
was not the center of american politics
and in terms of
um
the role of personality personality
matters tremendously but the personality
that worked for andrew jackson would not
didn't work for abraham lincoln and
abraham lincoln's personality would not
have worked in the days of theodore
roosevelt and franklin roosevelt's
personality would not work today and
lyndon johnson's wouldn't work either
the personality has to match the time
and with lyndon johnson if you've been
to if you've been to the johnson library
various other places where you can see
mock-ups of lbj's oval office and the
thing that gets the attention of the
school kids to go through is the
television set with the three screens
and johnson was considered such a
voracious gracious consumer of the media
he would watch all three of the evening
news shows at the same time
well imagine a president today trying to
keep track of all the media outlets it
would be quite impossible they have a
lot of eyes well yeah and so
a president today faces a different kind
of challenge franklin rose one of
franklin roosevelt's secrets of success
was his mastery of the principal medium
of the day radio and roosevelt's
fireside chats became legendary as
roosevelt's way of getting around the
largely republican newspaper press of
the day and speaking directly to
individuals
and
ronald reagan jfk a little bit ronald
reagan even more webby was the master of
the medium of his day television now i
don't know if the media and it's a very
very plural today
can have a master it definitely is the
case that it's a lot harder for a
president to get the message out but i
will just add one thing at this point on
obama
george is absolutely right that the
american economy is in the worst shape
that it has been in since the great
depression
having said that barack obama just might
get re-elected
and the fact that he just might get
re-elected is an astonishing statement
given the context of the economy when
the economy is doing as badly as it is
today presidents don't get reelected
historically there should be an uprising
within the democratic party he should be
having to fight off challengers simply
for the nomination he's not and if i
were making book today i'd say obama's
going to win next year in part because
the republicans can't figure out who
they are
and they've gotten themselves in a
situation where
the only type of
candidate they are able to nominate and
here i will share
this isn't simply because i live in
texas and i'm hoping that my governor is
going to go on to different things
but i think rick perry is going to i
think rick perry is going to get the
republican nomination and we could talk
about why but
he also can't beat obama and he's
this is typical of where the republicans
are they are so split and they're so
hostage to their right wing that the
only person who can get the nomination
is somebody who can't win the general
election and i think that's where we
will see obama's strength in reaching
out to that broader public and not just
the the fractionalized publics
he's going to win by default
well that was going to be my next
question is what is
what right now
both in terms of governance and in terms
of reelection what's the biggest
challenge that president obama faces is
it the economy is it the tea party is it
the republican party is it a divided
congress
what's
what do you think is the biggest thing
he has to get over
any of you
well you know
you never know
what they're really because you don't
know what the internal polls are showing
you know
we and it's that's what's some one of
the things that so strikes me i started
about learning about lyndon johnson is
you read the newspapers on what's
happening in a certain month and then
you go to the minutes of the meetings in
the white house and the internal
communications and it's like what's in
the me in the newspapers and magazines i
say it's like the shadow to the
substance this is what they're really
thinking and i don't think but one i
i'll just say one thing that occur it
seems to me there are only four or five
states that are really in play in this
election and they're all they seem to me
ohio michigan pennsylvania they all seem
to me to be states where unemployment
statements is the great the yes the rust
belts and florida where unemployment is
also very bad and i was that's the one i
left
and
so i think that
if you're trying to get reelected
and if in fact this is what the polls
are showing him his internal polls are
showing him he has a tremendous problem
in being reelected even
uh by default in those because of those
five states of those right uh bill what
do you think the biggest thing he faces
right now
well
i'm actually an optimist uh if i were in
obama's camp i would be an optimist and
i'll start with the current debt ceiling
negotiations i think things have shifted
in a way that he wins almost no matter
how it turns out
if they get a deal whether it's the the
big deal the medium deal or a smaller
deal he can say we got this deal they
did it yeah
if they don't
he has shifted the onus so it's really
he's the one who's sounding very
reasonable and the republicans are
sounding increasingly shrill
and he can you know run against eric
cantor and the ones who are going to
vote against anything
any kind of debt ceiling raising and
he'll come across looking like the
reasonable person now one of the real
wild cards in this is foreign policy
and
a lot of really bad things could have
happened so far during obama's first
term that didn't
and foreign policy has gone reasonably
well
now there's still lots of really bad
things that could happen between now and
next a year from november and if any of
that happens then he's stuck dealing
with that too many wild cards at the
moment how about you george what do you
think he's facing
i think it's just the profound sense of
discontent in the country uh which has
been with us you know since 2008 and
he he didn't break through it in 2009 he
arrived with all the wind at his back
uh with an not an overwhelming majority
a la roosevelt and johnson but really
big majorities in congress
with a big majority in the popular vote
unlike anything we've seen you know
since ronald reagan actually or george
h.w bush in 88
um
and
we could do a counter factual as to the
things that he might have done in a
different order in a different way that
might have produced different results in
terms of popular support but he has been
fighting a headwind from the very
beginning
starting with the fact that the
republicans
shamelessly having
largely created
this mess refused to do a thing to help
him to clean it up and in fact basically
made the calculation
that if if they don't help him out the
country will decide that it's his own
his burden and when things don't get
better as they may have gambled they
wouldn't it will be his fault i think
that was the very cynical decision made
by the republican party from even before
the inauguration
um he
he has
he lost the ground he came in with the
ground where the the country really had
invested their hopes in he lost it
because he lost it or because
circumstances lost it for him i remember
those early weeks of like february march
april 2009 a whole lot of things
happened
that
looking back
seemed like critical things that at the
time i wasn't even paying much attention
to because i it seemed like we were on a
much longer time horizon no in american
politics today things
one
can make a gigantic difference for
example uh the aig bonuses came out in i
think march of 09
and there was a tremendous national
uproar it was the first time the anger
over the financial crisis really found a
target
and instead of
harnessing it finding a way to say i'm
just as angry as you and we're going to
do something about it because the people
who brought the country to its knees
should not be profiting off taxpayer
bailout money instead basically geithner
went into obama and said there's nothing
we can do about it these are contracts
summer said you know
larry summers said yeah these are
contracts
the house was all up in arms and there
were some demagogic bills about 99
taxation of the bonus money which
probably would have been
unconstitutional
in his high-minded way obama decided i'd
rather do the unpopular but right thing
and not touch those bonuses and not say
anything and not be a demagogue about it
and he lost some of the public's
confidence at that moment and there are
other things that happened around the
same time the stimulus bill they never
explained to the country what it would
do
and how uh you know how it was going to
work so it was their own so i think from
the very start they made it
consumed with all the things coming at
him just more things than any human
being could possibly deal with that he
began to lose his hold on the public
from the from the first days could i
just get a clarification here when you
say i i don't mean this as a joke when
you say high-minded do you mean that as
a criticism no no it's great to i mean
to have a man who can think and
articulate and is honest and and and for
whom the english language is a friend
and not an enemy and and and who can
write a speech uh accepting the nobel
peace prize that you know invokes
without naming him reinhold niebuhr and
and and and and who can you know
who who can write a speech about race
that in invokes without naming him james
baldwin i mean this is a miracle that we
have a president like this it's a great
thing
but it's not the only thing he needs
there's i i was just rereading this
essay by max weber on politics as a
vocation and there's two kinds of
politician in it one who practices the
ethic of responsibility and one who
practices the ethic of ultimate ends
obama practices the ethic of
responsibility that word is the key word
of his presidency
and it becomes a kind of
um an end in itself to be responsible
the republicans practice the ethic of
ultimate ends we don't care what the
consequences are we're going to go with
our convictions obama has one but not
the other the republicans have one but
not the other neither can present the
full
personality of a leader we're going to
turn now to some audience questions so
why don't you folks get your questions
ready more to come
uh and while
while we start circulating with the mic
i just want to do um some version of a
lightning round here which is very
quickly
what's the single best
accomplishment of this administration so
far very quick one thing
to focus the debate of the country on
long-term issues like the deficit
passing a health care bill 40 million
people who didn't have insurance before
have it now that's quite an
accomplishment george yeah i'd say the
same the health care bill okay let's go
to some of your questions and we will of
course come back here
where's the mic i'm sorry okay why don't
we start in the back where you were and
please stand up if you would
thank you i think bill was wrong when he
said that the
severity of the economic crisis wasn't
severe enough to make a difference when
obama came in there were actually three
economic crisis at the same time
the first was the middle class was
disappearing
indicative of your
national debt to gdp ratio which was
half of gdp in 1980 now is five times of
gdp it's 75 trillion dollars it's an
impossible number to look at the other
thing is that from 2001
the private sector stopped creating jobs
so you have no you have no way to create
jobs you have no demand
and
in using summers and geithner he paid no
attention to these two things and i
wonder why he ignored these two issues
maybe he just didn't know what to do
about it
thank you for your question george you
want to uh
no i couldn't agree more
i think obama does care about those
issues he talked about them constantly
during the campaign
he may not know what to do about them i
think that with the stimulus
they got what they thought they could
get
maybe they didn't push hard enough to
try for more and a different
you know
pa a different kind of a proportion of
spending to tax cuts
it just was it was too weak given the
both the short-term
gail force wind of the financial crisis
and the long-term erosion that you're
talking about i don't know that
politicians know how to solve these
problems any longer biden runs this
thing called the middle class task force
which is all about restoring the middle
class we never hear about it no one
really knows what they're what they're
doing it's as if they kind of have given
up the idea that they're actually going
to persuade the public
that they can solve these these big
problems and you're right the people he
picked not only as we all know you know
were some of the purveyors of policies
that led to the financial crisis but
also were the type who
when it came to things like aig bonuses
advise the president to ignore the
public to to do the high-minded thing
and in that case i think the wrong thing
so his his advisers uh don't have a feel
for the pulse of the country and i think
inevitably a president becomes isolated
in the white house we we don't hear from
obama for long periods of time
this is not on the economy but on
afghanistan throughout 2009 he gave one
speech on the war while he was in very
serious meetings planning an escalation
he's great at those meetings for some
reason he fades out in in the public's
imagination it's a weird thing given
what a gigantic figure he was in our
imagination throughout 2008 that he's
come to this could i just answer go
ahead bill then we'll go to another
something george said earlier and your
question about the role of personality
one of the striking things to me about
president obama is his inability to get
effectively mad in public
and he is the great conciliator he's the
one who wants to bring people together
but if you look at american history the
biggest steps forward or you could call
it backward the biggest steps occur when
a president
typically the president
separates the sheep from the goats when
he singles out those bad people and is
able to isolate them and reduce their
numbers so that they can't resist both
roosevelts were brilliant at this the
first roosevelt theodore roosevelt
talked about the male factors of great
wealth and franklin roosevelt railed
against the economic royalists
because you know politics is an
emotional game and unless you can engage
people's emotions you can't
get you can't lead a movement you can't
get people to do what they wouldn't do
on their own obama is very he's a very
cool personality
and i don't know
at least i don't think on the basis of
ender's i've seen that he's the kind of
guy who can get mad i think he does the
opposite of what the roosevelts did
rather than drawing a line saying here
are people here are those male factors
he says let's all be adults right that
means there are no lines there's just
adults and children and he wants
everyone to be
and people get angry at him for not
getting angry you hear
more and more from constituents saying
why doesn't he shake them why doesn't he
yell why doesn't he but here it may be
that it's an aspect of his personality
right he absolutely is that's right if
you this is something you probably can't
fake
it
go ahead bob and then we're going to go
to another question one thing was that
was not mentioned here is that neither
of the two roosevelts was black
you know in this entire
whatever hour and 10 minutes the fact
that obama is our first black president
was never mentioned and you have to
wonder i certainly don't know the answer
to this
how much of what
you all are talking about
is because he's afraid of looking in the
cliche like an angry black man i don't
know the answer to that but i think
that's a critical point
thanks bob another question where's our
microphone uh let's go on this side
right here
well let's get a mike please
everybody wants to know what eric cantor
got so mad about this week and what all
that nonsense was what did eric campbell
get
well the president the president said
actually it was nothing to worry about
but um i don't know if we're supposed to
believe schumer had one take on it and
he had another take
what do you guys know about that
anything i don't i have no insider hey
you guys were just in the white house
didn't you find out they were in the
white house on monday and they and if i
were invited to the white house i would
have been asking that question that's
why you weren't invited george
it's a good question uh the president
certainly down tried to downplay it
yesterday in his press conference um i
assume we have to wait for both of their
memoirs to uh find out what really
happened in that meeting another
question please do we have something
down how about down here can you stand
up and wait for the mic please thank you
i wanted to continue with the
personality issue because it seems to me
much greater than not getting mad
in public or being afraid to appear as
an angry black man if i look at great
leaders throughout history
alexander the great julius caesar throw
in cleopatra
certainly
robert moses lyndon johnson these are
all people who are very comfortable with
their aggression
and it seems to me that barack obama is
very
tied up in his own identity as a nice
guy he was a nice muslim boy a nice
christian boy
health care it's really nice thing to
give all these programs health care and
stuff to people
but
unless one is really comfortable
fighting maybe even dying for what one
believes in
there seems to be a limit to what one
can accomplish and to do that one has to
be comfortable saying i have a nasty
side
and i'm not afraid when
i have values
that i want to uphold to be nasty to
those who disagree
thank you for your comment nice guy
that's what i'm nice guy she's pushing
nice guy anybody want to respond to that
well
there's no question that the most
forceful presidents the one we the ones
we consider to be the great presidents
had
in very many cases but not all cases had
this kind of
ability to channel what you've labeled
their aggression but i'll give you the
example of the person who is considered
by historians to be the greatest
president of all
and abraham lincoln abraham lincoln did
not have an aggressive bone in his body
he was ambitious
but he was exceedingly thoughtful very
reflective
and he put the greatest priority on
trying to bring the country back
together so
there's no single model for presidential
success
yeah
you know it's odd nice is the word um
because people who really know obama who
worked with him people i know who had a
lot of dealings with him describe him as
the most
unsentimental and even ruthless man
they've ever met that that this is a man
who
will it once you
are no longer going to be
able to help him
we could point to jeremiah wright among
others
you're gone uh greg craig his counsel
who was an early supporter of obama's uh
risk of becoming
an obama guy and became white house
counsel was cut loose
with apparently not a second thought to
the horror of a lot of people in the
white house this is not a softy this is
actually a man who i think has a lot of
steel in his uh in his skeleton and
partly
uh
how else could a black man get to the
point where he's at without having a
skeleton made out of steel and perhaps
nowhere better seen than in the
campaign against osama bin laden which
from everything i am hearing inside yeah
how could you how could you truly be
funny the night before at the white
house correspondents dinner really
his time was amazing he was just nailing
joke after joke all the while knowing
that the next day
maybe the most fateful moment of his
presidency was about very a very steely
moment uh indeed go ahead bob then we
have another question
all right let's go down to the question
here thank you
hi um my name is hilary doe i'm the
national director of roosevelt's campus
network and i graduated in 2008 so
thousands of those young people in our
network like myself worked really hard
to elect barack obama and i think a lot
of us did believe that we were working
for a movement you guys referenced
movements earlier and in a lot of ways i
think the movement was led by obama a
new kind of governance and i think ofa
organizing for america was a great
example of that i can tell you that tons
of young people believed that organizing
for america represented a new way of
doing governance and that locally across
the country people could you could get a
sense of the public's interest that
could allow barack obama to be
courageous throughout his presidency so
now since that didn't work out the way
that we thought it would despite being
thrilled that healthcare passed and
thrilled that pell grants were extended
you know a lot of the things that he's
accomplished in the last two years
i think a lot of young people are
weighing that against their
disappointment about ofa so while i
think that young people will come out
for barack in 2012 i wonder what you
think he can do to ensure the youth vote
in the same numbers that he got it in
2008 let me ask you a question before we
turn it over to them if the people the
young people who organized for obama and
08
are disappointed who will they vote for
um you know i'm seeing a lot of people
make the decision whether or not to come
back and join the campaign and a lot of
people are
i think they still believe in barack
obama but certainly there's some
disillusionment and i'm not sure if the
same numbers of them so they just might
not turn out in the same numbers which
were critical at the time thoughts about
the youth vote bill well i will say that
often especially under these economic
circumstances it's a lot harder to run
as an incumbent than it is as someone
with a blank slate upon whom people like
you can project their own ideas and
their own ideals but
to govern is to disillusion people
that's just the way it goes now the case
he will have to make is better me than
somebody else i did better than who
somebody else who might have been
elected in 2008 and i will continue to
fight the good fight you have to stick
with me it may well be that the kind of
campaign he runs is the campaign of
a president in the middle of a war where
you have to stay the course you know we
victory has not yet been achieved maybe
this is abraham lincoln in 1864 or
something like that george bush in 2004
okay yeah you know so at least you know
me i'm we're moving the country in the
right direction if you throw me out now
think we're gonna lose all the progress
we've made and things are gonna be worse
than they would have been in the first
place another question uh let's can we
go over here can we get a microphone
over the gentleman in the white shirt
yes you
please stand up when you get the mic
mike is coming mike use the mic please
thank you thank you one of the major
responsibilities of a president is the
stewardship of foreign policy two
specific questions how would you assess
his handling of the palestinian-israeli
negotiations and the comments that he
has failed to visit israel and secondly
the arab spring
thank you for the question who wants to
take that george you can start with that
i actually think foreign policy has been
his strongest point
he's handled
uh
two wars a third that was sort of laid
on at on his table and
the most vexing relationship that the
united states has ever had with any
quote ally in its history pakistan
about as well as i can imagine any
president doing i mean
the arab-israeli conflict the
palestinian-israeli conflict is is just
going to make every president look bad
it made bill clinton look bad and he
devoted you know every day of the last
year and a half of his presidency to it
so i i think yeah obama made a few
mistakes rookie mistakes maybe in 2009
but it
it's i i'm not going to lay that one on
him that that is the situ that is a
situation that no american president can
possibly simply work his his will on the
arab spring he was always a step behind
i don't think he quite
uh grasped what a world historical
moment this was and that there was an
audience in the arab world paying very
close attention to what he was saying
but i think
um
his his
country by country choices some of them
very tough choices do you push
salah out in yemen do you push mubarak
out in egypt i think basically he's
handled them very well i think he's a
really shrewd
tactician in foreign policy um which
again is not
what
we thought he was
going to be when he ran we thought he
was a visionary transformer i don't
think his foreign policy is particularly
transformational i think it's just been
very shorthanded well to add to that
i go back to what uh i said at the very
beginning if you look at things in a
historical context you could really say
how big is the arab spring going to
appear 100 years from now
but if you take it in the historical
context perhaps the thing that's going
to be dominant about his par or most
significant about his foreign policy is
that when he came to office the united
states was the subject of anger and
contempt really throughout the world and
somehow he has brought the united states
back into a position of whether
everyone is cooperating and still we're
in a
leadership role and i think that in a
broad sense may be the most significant
thing
okay another question down here please
well as i look around i may be the only
african-american male here
and let me just say this
barack obama is a type
he's been trained by his parents and his
grandparents
as i was trained by my parents and
grandparents not to get too angry with
white folks
right
because that
that is just the opposite effect of what
we want to do we want to be participants
in american life
if i were angry and bitter and walked
around frowning all day i wouldn't have
many friends in life or business
partners
so we are trained
in a in a largely
uh professional white world
to behave a certain way i learned that
from my mother
he learned it from his mother and his
grandparents so
we can get angry
oh yeah my wife can attest to that
but
but in our public persona
we are trained our behavior is to be
upright but not uptight
uh to be real
not phony
but to also listen and try to
to convey
that we're not going to
jump you
and i say
let's hug them not mug them
so
i am a thousand percent supporter of the
president
uh i was four years ago and i am now
he can learn
they all learn on the job andrew johnson
couldn't even read he had to be taught
how to read by his wife
so let's get real folks
not every president walks in
uh and and has a bed of roses
lincoln did not have a better roses
george washington they want to make him
a king
he said no no no no he could have been
king george the fourth
so let's
you know in america
there's a dead ceiling for presidents
and there's a doubt ceiling when are we
going to get to the doubt ceiling about
this man
can can i ask you do you think that
that upbringing has handicapped them in
any way
because
has that upbringing it's upbringing
everyone's upbringing is both enables
things and limits
was different first of all no the
question was do you think it has
handicapped him in any way well
handicapped in the sense that
his grandparents who from kansas
schooled him and had to behave
unlike my own grandparents because my
own grandparents were african-american
his were kansas his mother
had him in indonesia his grandparents
also had men hawaii so i think it has
handicapped him
not in a not in a pejorative sense but
in a behavioral way
he has to
respond
he became the uh law uh
guy at harvard law school the law editor
law review by doing the same thing he's
doing as president if he had angered
those guys at harvard law school do you
think they would have made him the head
of the law review come on let's get real
he had to be diplomatic he had to be
smart about it and he had to be
influential and he was all of that so i
think it is a handicap it was handing
out for me in business i could not show
often my true feelings to a client
or to a colleague or to a competitor
because i always had that thing angry
you know
fox news come on
now lincoln how would lincoln have
handled fox news how would roosevelt
handle fox news how would
ronald reagan handle fox news
it's a whole new cacophony
in this country
we're not about sensible solutions or
sensitive solutions we're about who's
got the noise of the day
it's it's daily noise not daily news so
we all have to in this in this society
sit back and begin to to deliberate and
be more honest and honorable he's an
honorable man
he's an honest man
and i think america would do itself an
injustice not to reelect him but that's
my own view ah thank you so much for
your comments i like the i like the
image of how would lincoln have handled
fox news how by the way how would obj
have handled fox news
well he would
he would have had a fourth screen in the
office
definitely a fourth screen in the office
more questions from the audience in the
back sure go um the gentleman that has
not had a chance yet
oh i thought you had before we'll get to
you go ahead um
mr brand noted it touched on it briefly
but you guys have mostly been talking
about how barack obama has been defining
himself
and i feel that historically barack
obama is unique in that he has been
almost as defined by
the opposition as he has been defined by
himself as he has defined
himself um he's been trying to present
himself as this very diplomatic figure
but at the same time there have been
these guys who are like he's a secret
muslim he's a secret communist who hangs
out with anarchists
and i feel that at the same that while
that really angers conservatives
there have been a lot of people
especially over afghanistan
obama was always throughout his campaign
saying that we need to get out of iraq
and go to afghanistan but i feel that
people bought into the opposition
uh
the opposition rhetoric as much thinking
that he is a total dove he's going to
get us out of all all of our wars
and they're disappointed when obama
actually does what he says that he was
going to do
how do you feel that
the opposition
the opposition narrative has affected
barack obama's problem so to what thank
you for the question so to what extent
uh we've talked about that a bit here to
what extent
has the mitch mcconnell position that
i'll do anything to get him not elected
again and and all of that
has that been either um
good or bad for him
i'd like to draw a parallel to what
happened to harry truman after the 1948
election
because truman inherited the presidency
upon franklin roosevelt's death in 1945
his first run on his own was in 1948. he
won by a very narrow margin and the
republicans were so embittered in large
part because they had taken the high
road on foreign policy they were so sure
they were going to win that they didn't
want to spoil the ground of foreign
policy that they thought they were going
to have to tread themselves but truman
squeaked past and the morning after the
election the republicans made a
collective decision we're going to
destroy this presidency and they went
into opposition right across the board
and they use the soft on communism
charge against him and when china went
communist in 1949 then when the korean
war began and they essentially destroyed
truman's presidency so that there was no
constitutional ban on truman running for
election again in 1952 but he was so
unpopular that he could not have gotten
the nomination even within his own party
so he packed up and went back to
independence missouri so this
unrelenting opposition i would say
unfortunately
it sometimes works and it has worked
pretty well against obama and and i say
this despite the fact that i said
earlier and i still think that he has
done about as well as anybody could have
and so given what george called the
headwind he's been dealing with it's
this hurricane he's been
facing into he's still done remarkably
well but that's not going to go away
another question
uh over let's go down here
please
please stand up thank you
uh
i i listened
to uh mr brand discussion of having
large majorities in both houses and
immediately went to
bob carroll saying uh
lyndon johnson could get 12 votes
but you only could get you only needed
one to break the filibuster at the time
when he had 59 in the senate
and then i heard george talk about how
shrewd and ruthless obama is and though
he may have been inexperienced
i think that calculus was available to
him
what i want to raise is the prospect
that obama needs to raise a billion
dollars
obama needs to make the aig bonuses look
like they're high-minded when they
really are quite
how would i say perhaps legal but
unethical
that citizens united
is a change in the playing field that
with 59 votes you don't even
feel you have all the democrats because
they can go get money and lyndon johnson
didn't have to argue quite as hard
against money when people needed 40
million dollars to run for senate
isn't it the context that's trapping
this presidency rather than the failings
of the personality of the president
lyndon johnson didn't have to worry
about
running against money quite so hard
partly because he always had the texas
oil money uh behind him but he had
something just as uh tough which was the
southern uh conservative midwestern
republican domination of congress you
know when
johnson came into office
this conservative coalition was formed
in 1937 in response to the supreme court
packing bill and it stayed in power for
26 years a quarter of a century
roosevelt never got a single major
domestic bill through congress after
1937.
no major really major legislation passed
until johnson came into office every
president
has huge problems uh
facing them
i
just to go back to what this was i just
have to say one thing one was talking
about being comfortable in your
personality and not being afraid to be
ruthless i won't talk about robert mose
but i'll tell you what being ruthless
did for lyndon johnson so i was just
listening to a tape for something that
i'm i'm writing now
he
everyone knew
that if you denied him a vote he would
never stop trying to pay you back
he's now president there's a really
crucial moment in the finance committee
it happens to be nine to eight against
him and he has to change this vote and
he gets a call and and they're going to
call for a vote within the finance
committee in five minutes he's got five
minutes to go on he calls frank lauschi
a democrat of ohio
and lao she says no i can't i i can't do
that i my company needs this uh tax
break he says i'll lose face lyndon
johnson says and you have to hear his
voice on the tape
you save my face today i'll save your
face tomorrow
laoshi
you know you
you're you're absolutely right the
context is just wildly different so it's
even hard to compare money makes it
different uh interest groups make it
different media makes it different but
some things are permanent i think you're
talking about how to use power and one
aspect of using power is instilling fear
obama it has this ruthlessness i think
he just uses it with the wrong people
it's it's it's more the people who work
for him or who who who are his allies at
one time or another who can tell you
yeah you better
he he will cut you off if if if you stop
being useful to him do you think
john boehner is afraid of obama do you
think mitch mcconnell's afraid of obama
do you think joe lieberman is afraid of
obama do you think
you know um
should they be yes absolutely i asked
david axelrod about this when i was
writing a piece about obama's first year
because one thing i thought was missing
was fear his his ability to actually
let
potential friends and enemies know that
there would be a
a reward for
for being a friend and there would be a
penalty for being an enemy if you can't
do that then there's no price to be paid
for opposing you and so
democrats opposed him on the health care
bill in ways that were terribly damaging
to him and republicans have done nothing
but oppose him and i think obama does
not want
perhaps for reasons we talked about
earlier perhaps for other reasons maybe
it's just deep in him
does not want to be seen to be
to be punishing people and you have to
be willing to punish people and i think
it's been
a kind of missing weapon
in his arsenal and it sounds a little
crude to talk about politics in this way
but this is part of what what it's about
and i asked a number of senators does
obama feared
on capitol hill and they all said
absolutely not no one's afraid of him
as opposed to the former speaker of the
house for example
uh natan pelosi
she was feared
and that's how she got she got more done
than than obama did actually and lyndon
johnson was i'd like to have something
we're going to we're going to be
wrapping it up so if you want to include
a final thought in here go right ahead
or not
we don't need okay yeah this will be my
final thought and that is that obama
faces a challenge that lyndon johnson
did not face that franklin roosevelt
didn't really have to deal with and that
is we have gone beyond the days when
bipartisanship was at all possible
in the 1960s until the 1960s both
political parties included both
liberals and conservatives so it was
possible for example for civil rights
legislation for other legislation in the
1960s to find a coalition that included
people from both parties because the
democratic party had all those
democratic southern conservatives but it
also had liberal democrats big city
democrats the republican party had
newton northeastern liberals and it had
midwestern conservatives
but
with the passage of civil rights more
precisely when lyndon johnson nailed the
the flag of the democratic party to
civil rights reform he gave those
southern conservatives permission to
leave the democratic party and they did
with the result that they all became
republicans and the south became the
center of gravity the republican party
we've achieved a point now where if you
are a conservative in this country you
are a republican if you are a liberal in
this country you are a democrat and
there's effectively no overlap with the
result that the parties sift themselves
out add to this the perfection if you
want to use that term of gerrymandering
with computers so that nearly every seat
in the house of representatives is safe
for incumbents so republicans in
congress do not have to worry about a
challenge from the left they're all
looking over their right shoulder and
democrats are looking over their left
shoulder so the days when you could
reach across the aisle to form some kind
of consensus they're gone at least for
the time being some of the states are
appointing independent commissions to
draw congressional districts and that
will dilute the power of party to some
extent but for now we're stuck in this
age where you know you can't expect the
other party to go along with you and
that's and that's a subject for a whole
other panel to talk about the parties
and what's going on uh gentlemen this
has been wonderful i
i know for a fact that bob carrow will
not be writing a biography of obama i
don't know about bill because you're
pretty quick and you're you're moving
through a lot of different presidents
but george it could fall on you as well
so i i think that underneath my boss
already did it i can't i can't show him
up
under any circumstances i think that the
um
the biographication of our presidents is
in extremely good hands as you've seen
right here and
stay tuned for what happens next thanks
all thanks for coming
thank you folks for coming thank you for
coming there is a coffee break out in
the garden if you'd like to join us at 4
30 we have a panel on new media so
please come back 4 30. thank you
on c-span the co-founders of twitter
thank you very much
robert carro is the author of the years
of lyndon johnson the fourth book in his
series is titled the passage of power
and it captures lbj in the years from
1958 to 1964 his transition from the u.s
senate to the presidency
up next mr carro's keynote address
during a symposium aimed at revisiting
the great society policies and politics
of franklin d roosevelt and lyndon b
johnson this is about 50 minutes
[Applause]
thank you president rob
it is all together appropriate
that this conference be held at hunter
college and at roosevelt house where we
will convene tomorrow
lyndon johnson as president rad
mentioned was a protege of franklin
roosevelt who served as president when
lbj was first elected to congress in
1936.
lbj a new dealer by background and at
heart
believed in fdr and his vision for
america
in many ways the seeds of lbj's great
society were planted in the fields of
fdr's new deal as johnson often said to
his aides during his administration
i really intend to finish franklin
roosevelt's revolution
but lbj's passion for social justice
came well before fdr landed in the white
house
in a 1965
before a joint session of congress lbj
talked about an experience as a young
man that may have been among the most
formative of his life
my first job after college
was as a teacher
in catoola texas
in a
small mexican american school
few of them could speak english and i
couldn't speak much spanish
my students were poor and they often
came to class without breakfast hungry
and they knew even in their youth the
pain of prejudice
they never seemed to
know why people disliked them
but they knew it was so
because i saw it in their eyes
i often walked home late in the
afternoon after the classes were
finished
wishing there was more that i could do
but all i knew
was to teach them
the little that i knew
hoping that it might help them
against the hardships that lay ahead
and somehow you never forget what
poverty and hatred can do
when you see its scars
on the hopeful face
of a young child
i never thought
then in 1928 that i would be standing
here
in 1965.
it never even occurred to me in my
fondest dreams that i might have the
chance
to help the sons and daughters of those
students
and to help people like them all over
this country
but now i do have that chance
and i'll let you in on a secret i mean
to use it
[Applause]
with memories of those mexican-american
school children seared in his conscience
and racial strife alive and well in
america in the mid-1960s
lbj took his own revolution where fdr
had not
enlisting in the cause of civil rights
and determined to put a legal end to
racial apartheid in america
on november 25 1963 on what was the
second full day of his presidency
johnson called martin luther king jr and
initiated what would become among the
most productive and important
partnerships of the 20th century
a good many people told me that they
heard about your statement i guess on tv
wasn't it yeah that's right i i
i've been locked up in this office and i
haven't seen it but i won't tell you how
grateful i am and how
how worthy i'm going to try to be of all
your hopes
well thank you very much i'm so happy to
hear that and i knew
that you had just that great spirit and
you know you have our support and
backing well we know what a difficult
period is
just an impossible period we got a
budget coming up it's
they got nothing to do with it's
practically already made and we got
civil rights bill it hadn't even passed
the house and it's november and hubert
opera told me yesterday everybody want
to go home we got a tax bill if they
haven't touched
we just
got to let up not let up on any of them
and keep going and i guess they'll say
that i'm reputed but i'm going to ask
the congress
wednesday to just stay there they pass
them all they won't do it but we'll just
keep them right next year will it do and
we just won't give up an answer
well this is this is mighty fine i think
it's uh
it's so imperative i think one of the
great uh
tributes that we can pay in memory of
president kennedy is to
try to enact some of the
great uh progressive policies that he
sought to initiate well i'm going to
support them all and you can count on
that and i'm going to do my best to get
other men to do likewise and i'll have
to have y'all's help i never needed more
than i do now well you know you're happy
that just feel free to call on us for
anything thank you so much mark all
right call me i want you to call the
file i sure will call me when you're
down here next time i certainly will
let's get together and any suggestions
you got bring a man fine i certainly
will do that thank you so much
[Music]
all men are created equal
is an inherent part of the american
creed by working with martin luther king
and others towards the civil rights act
of 1964
and 1968
the voting rights act of 1965 and other
civil rights measures lbj more than any
other president
helped to fulfill the promise of equal
rights for all americans
that legislation came at a cost
when johnson's friend and mentor
democratic senator richard russell of
georgia
warned him that passage of the civil
rights act of 1964
would result in the
democratic party's loss in the southern
states and his loss of the presidency in
the fall election
johnson replied
if that is the price for this bill
i will gladly pay it
in fact the democrats did lose the south
but johnson won the election of 1964 in
a landslide
he used that mandate to fulfill other
promises enacting medicare
head start
federal aid to education
immigration reform
environmental conservation and taking
measures to weaken poverty's hold in
america as the poverty rate plunged from
20 percent to 12 percent during the
course of his administration
the great society might have swept even
further into american life if not for
the meyer of vietnam
a conflict johnson inherited from
presidents eisenhower and kennedy
as lbj escalated the war with no
resolution in sight divisions spread
throughout the country
on any given day in the latter part of
his presidency protesters could be heard
outside of the white house gates
chanting hey hey
lbj
how many kids did you kill today
lbj agonized over the war which resulted
in the loss of 36 000 u.s troops by the
time he ended his white house reign in
1969
but as this conference will reflect
lbj's formidable legacy of liberty
continues to resonate
uniting us today far beyond the
divisions of yesteryear
come let us reason together with
johnson's favorite biblical passage
by reaching across the aisle
appealing to reason and fostering
togetherness he not only continued fdr's
revolution but left his own indelible
mark on america
while he may have been the consummate
politician his ultimate aim was to use
his power to do the greatest good for
the greatest number
hey hey
lbj
my oh my we could use you today
one of johnson's chief architects in
building his great society was a young
new yorker
named joe califano who served as a
special assistant to the president from
1965
to 1969. he then went on to become
secretary of health education and
welfare for jimmy carter
he is currently an advisory board member
for the roosevelt house public policy
institute and as president rad mentioned
a catalyst for this conference ladies
and gentlemen please join me in
welcoming to the stage joe califano
thank you
thank you
i'm standing between you and robert
carro so i'll be short
uh bob carro is fascinated with the
exercise of power
and those who exercise it
that fascination led him to write the
power broker his brilliant biography of
robert moses had set a whole new
standard
for political biography
today i view that pulitzer prize-winning
book as his warm-up for tackling lyndon
johnson
the most intelligent complicated
committed inspiring and infuriating
person i've ever worked for
bob carrow is lyndon johnson's most
demanding and meticulous biographer
bob is fond of saying that and i quote
to understand power you not only have to
show how it is used
but also its effect on those on whom it
is used
you have to show the effect of power
on the powerless
no wonder he has become obsessed with
lyndon johnson
bob carroll has worked for 40 years
to give the world lbj with the bark off
his highs and lows
how this president gave new meaning to
the word machiavellian as he gave new
hope to the most vulnerable among us
robert carroll gives no quarter
to the subjects he writes about
so we should all take notice of what he
wrote about the president
and master of the senate
his third johnson volume
in the 20th century cairo wrote
with its 18 american presidents lyndon
baines johnson was the greatest champion
that black americans and mexican
americans and indeed all americans of
color had in the white house
the greatest champion they had in all
the halls of government
he was the lawmaker for the poor and
downtrodden and the oppressed
the president who wrote mercy and
justice into the statute books
by which america was governed end quote
bob carroll's three volumes on lbj have
already won him a second pulitzer prize
and a second national book award and too
many other prizes and accolades for me
to mention in any introduction
of one thing i'm certain
lbj has given bob carroll plenty of
material to win even more prizes with
his next volume
passage of power
about the years from 1958 to 1964
when johnson was vice president part of
those years which will be out in may
and with his final volume on the white
house she is and beyond
due out in a couple of years
indeed publishes weekly in the issue
coming out on april first
has already called his
new his forthcoming volume compelling
insightful
and
a a one that will thrill all those who
care about american politics
bob
he's back there
bob has spent some 40 years with lyndon
johnson and he looks great
bill moyers and i spent about three
years each with him
in the white house and we're still
exhausted every time we think about it
ladies and gentlemen the great bob
carroll
[Music]
thank you
joe that was such a nice introduction
that i'm reminded of what lyndon johnson
used to say when he used to get an
especially nice introduction he used to
say he wished his parents were alive to
hear it
because his father would have loved it
and his mother would have believed it
you know what winston churchill said
when he was asked where he was in his
great biography of lord marlborough he
said i'm working on the fifth of a
projected four volumes
well
not to equate myself with winston
churchill but i'm in the same boat and
in a way this talk tonight is an
explanation of how i got there
the role of government the
responsibilities of government that's
the theme of this symposium with the
focus on lyndon baines johnson 36th
president of the united states on lyndon
johnson's concept of what the role of
government should be
and that theme will be explored in
detail in the panels tonight and
tomorrow
but to begin this conference i am going
to talk about the origins of this
concept
about its beginnings
about where lyndon johnson's belief in
the role of government came from
about the most fundamental basic
beginnings
for lyndon johnson not the beginnings in
washington but the beginnings long
before washington
and i'll try to talk also about the
origins not only of lyndon johnson's
general beliefs
about the role and responsibility of
government
but also about the origins of the
program in which in a way he announced
his beliefs to the american people about
the program
in which just seven weeks after
president kennedy's assassination
in his first state of the union address
johnson enunciated quite clearly his
concept of what the role of government
should be
it's the program with which he
began his great society
the war on poverty
for lyndon johnson
the beginnings are all in the place he
came from
the place in which she was born and
raised the texas hill country
i've talked about the hill country
before
but i don't think you can talk about it
too much particularly in new york city
i saw
what that meant growing up there myself
and it was quite a shock
i grew up in new york city which is
this place of fast-paced conversations
and busy streets theaters and everything
else
there was then a nine o'clock plane from
the guardian to austin i take that plane
and sometimes when i got off that plane
i felt you'd rent the car you drive west
out of austin into the hill country and
on those days i felt like i was going
from one ends of the earth to the other
i'll never forget the first time i drove
out there about 40 miles out of johnson
out of austin as you're heading towards
johnson city there's a rise they call it
a round mountain but it's really just a
tall hill but as i came to the top of it
something made me pull my car over to
the side of the road and get out on the
shoulder and look down in front of me
because i was looking at something that
i had never seen before in my life
it was just
emptiness i was looking at a valley i
later found out it was 42 miles long and
about 15 miles across
and when i stood there first and looked
at it
i felt that there wasn't a single human
thing in it to be seen
just a tremendous expanse of emptiness
and then something happened the cloud
moved
in front of the sun or away from the sun
or something and all of a sudden there
was a light glimping off a little huddle
of houses in the middle of that empty
space that was johnson city texas lyndon
johnson was growing up there the
population was 367 at one point when i
came along it was 362.
and i think i had stopped the car then
and got out of it because i realized i
was confronting something that i'd never
seen before and that i really wasn't
equipped to deal with
i'd be as i started to interview lyndon
johnson's you know i came london johnson
died so young at the age of 64. and i
came along so uh
quickly after he had died that all the
people who knew him who grew up with him
in johnson city they were just about all
still there if his best friend in high
school was truman fawcett truman force
that had moved to a bigger house but it
was still in johnson city just a couple
of blocks away if his first girlfriend
was kitty clyde raw she was kitty clyde
leonard now but she actually still lived
in her parents house
and i started to learn about this land
you know the land it starts just it's
now of course austin has pushed out into
it but then the hill country began just
at the western edge of austin and rolled
west
it encompasses 23 000 square miles which
is an area big enough to put all of new
england into it and still have room for
pennsylvania
and the population at that time was
about three people per square mile
this first settler is called the land of
endless horizons because every time you
got to the top of one
line of hills you found that there was
another one beyond it
it was a land of incredible loneliness
as i started to talk to people there
i'll never forget lyndon johnson now the
johnsons for a large part of lyndon's
boyhood didn't even live in johnson city
they lived 18 miles beyond it on the
johnson ranch
and lyndon's brother sam houston johnson
once told me they were so lonely out
there that one corner of the ranch came
down to what they called the austin
fredericksburg highway which is really
an unpaved just path between austin and
fredericksburg and he told me how lyndon
and he would go down and sit on this
corner of the fence hour after hour
hoping for one new face to come along so
they'd have someone new to talk to
the land of almost incredible poverty
there was almost no cash there
you could get a dime from selling a
dozen eggs but you had to go to marble
falls to sell it marble falls was 22
miles away across the hills and a friend
of lyndon johnson's ben kreider told me
how he used to on saturdays ride those
22 miles carrying a dozen eggs in a
basket in front of me carrying like this
so that they wouldn't break 22 miles
like that to get a a dime
and i came to realize that being from
new york i simply wasn't understanding i
came back and i told einer one night you
know i'm not understanding these people
and i'm not understanding this country
therefore i'm not understanding lyndon
johnson would you mind if we moved here
einer of course said okay and for three
years we rented a house up in the hill
country and i would spend day after day
driving around interviewing these people
every interview seemed to be 180 miles
from the one before
interviewing these people who grew up
with lyndon johnson went to college with
lyndon johnson or members of his first
political machine
when you moved to a world that opens up
to you in ways
that you can't even imagine
i mean one thing i had heard you know we
all heard
if you read about lyndon johnson you
cite a wonderful journalist for time
magazine has a poignant scene
in his book on johnson's presidency
we're following a cabinet meeting
johnson says
he says following tablet meetings
johnson would often say you know i had
two rhodes scholars at the table all
these guys from harvard and one graduate
of southwest texas state teachers
college and site he said
johnson would always laugh loudly at
that
too loudly
and i didn't really understand what
lyndon johnson's education the effect
that it had on him until i went down to
the college found the textbooks that
they used and i said gee do you like
textbooks that you would use in high
school in new york that was his college
education i found a friend of his guy
named joe berry who later became a a
professor at bryn moore he said you know
when i got to bryn mawr i realized i
couldn't talk to anybody about anything
i felt i had been cheated out of an
education
so that's part of lyndon johnson's
upbringing
but it also showed me
living there
just how remarkable were his unique
abilities to use the powers of
government to improve the lives of
people
while i was interviewing in the hill
country i came to realize that i was
hearing the same thing over and over
uh
they would tell me these stories about
johnson's ruthlessness and his cruelty
often just cruelty for the sake of being
cruel but then i would hear over and
over they would say no matter what
lyndon was like
we loved him because he brought the
lights we brought the lights well i knew
what brought the lights meant i mean
when john i knew from reading when that
when johnson became congressman in 1937
at the age of 28 there was no
electricity in the hill country and
during his term as congressman he
brought electricity to the hill country
but because i came from new york city
where electricity is always just there
you turn a light switch and it's on
i understood intellectually what
bringing electricity meant but i didn't
really understand what it meant or what
the lives of the people of the hill
country were like without it because
they didn't have any electricity of
course they didn't have movies they
didn't have radio problems one of the
poignant things that they told me was so
many of these farmers and ranchers would
say you know we loved linda we loved fdr
he saved my rant she saved my phone we
heard all about these wonderful fireside
chats but we couldn't hear the fireside
chats the only radios they had in the
hill country were these crystal sets and
they would describe sitting there while
roosevelt was talking moving the needle
back and forth on the dial and trying to
find uh trying to make his voice come in
clearly
but movies and radio are just
entertainment
not having electricity means something
uh a lot deeper than that
you can say it all you don't have
washing machines etc but you can say it
most point most basically perhaps
in water
you know for us we just turn a force and
because of electric pumps the water
comes out but in the hill country
water came from streams and wells now
the streams in the hill country are
generally small and dried up for a large
part of the year
so they had to get
water out of the wells and the water
table in the hill country in general is
about 75 feet deep so they had to dig
well 75 feet and bring up water from it
the department of agriculture tells us
that at that time the average farm
family used 200 gallons of water each
day or 73 000 gallons or 300 tons per
year
and that water had to be brought up from
the wells by the women by the wives of
the house because the husband was out in
the fields working all day and there was
so little cash in the hill country that
as soon as the children got old enough
to work boys and girls both they had to
work what they called off the farm on
more prosperous farms in other areas of
texas nearby areas of texas for a dollar
a day to earn some cash money so the
woman of the house would be left there
alone
i couldn't get had a hard time getting
these women to talk to me uh at the
beginning because incredibly enough they
were very shy
very shy about talking to someone
from the city
so einer as a matter of fact learned to
make fig preserves and she would go
and become friends with the women and
then i could go back and they would talk
to me more freely
and they would say to me you're a city
boy she says you don't know what bring
in the water mountain
they would say
and they would go to their attic or
their garage and they'd bring out a
bucket of water
often with the ropes still attached
frayed old rope attached
and they would take me over to the wells
which were always covered by these boys
and you'd push the boards aside and
they'd say they dropped the bucket in
and they'd say you don't you're a city
boy you don't know how heavy a bucket of
water is now pull it up and of course a
bucket of water you find out is heavy to
be pulled up in fact it was so too heavy
for these women
often so what they would do is they had
this metal thing over the well and they
put the rope over it and they do what
they call walking away that they haul up
on the rope like this to pull the bucket
of water out of the well
and that's the way they had to bring up
all this water that they needed for
household
duties then they would say to me
you know it's easier to get it to the
house if you do it
two buckets at a time
do you know how we did that
and i'll never forget the first time a
woman went over to the garage
and opened it and showed me her yoke
because that's how these women carried
the water
with the oaks over their shoulders like
cattle
you know i realized that i was hearing
another thing i had been hearing another
thing in a lot of these interviews with
the women they would say things like you
do you see how round shouldered i am
you see how stooped i am bent they would
say you see how bent i am the word the
word in the hill country is really bent
do you see how bent i am
and in fact i had sort of noticed that
these women seemed a great deal more
stooped than city women
but i thought it was just because they
were old
but they would say i got bent like this
before my time
my bent my back got bent like this when
i was young
these women were
stooped at 40 stooped at 35. one woman
said to me
i swore that i wasn't going to look like
my mother looked but then the babies
started to come and i had to bring the
water
and i knew i was going to look exactly
like my mother looked
they would show me what wash days were
like because they didn't have
electricity they would take out you take
out four number three zinc wash tubs and
you'd line them up on your lawn and
you'd build the fire on under each one
and you transferred the first one was
the low eye soap and they didn't have
enough money to buy store-bought soap so
they had to make their own soap out of
lie and there was another expression in
the hill country
lie so peels the skin off your hands
like gloves
but you put the first
load of wash in and i use the scrubbed
the law scrub it out with a lie soap and
then say you're a city boy you don't
know how heavy a load of wet washes on
the end of a broomstick do you
and they they would give me and i have
then it's very heavy and they're and
then they have to so they'd be the lie
uh wash tub the rinsing wash tub
the blueing or starch wash tub and then
the other rinsing washed up so they had
to transfer these between the wash tubs
and they on an average day as near as i
could tell
there were eight to ten loads of wash in
the hill country family and they said
i'll never forget how my back hurt on
wash days tuesday was ironing i'm not
going to bore you all by going through a
day of the week i named that they called
it i named the chapter after what they
called tuesday the seattlines because
they because you didn't have electricity
an iron was a hunk of metal with a
wooden handle which you would transfer
from iron to iron and you'd have to get
them hot on the stove and that meant you
had to sit next to stand next to the
stove all day doing your ironing and
it's nothing in the hill country for it
to get up to 105 or 106 degrees sort of
day by day there
so these people were living lives out of
the middle ages they were living like
peasants
lyndon johnson runs for congress at the
age of 28.
and he says if you he basically says if
you elect me i will bring electricity
well they elected him
he let me just go back and lyndon
johnson was a political genius and he
gears his campaign to the women
and what he said the line that he uses
is if you elect me you won't look like
your mother does
they elect them but no one really
believes
that he can bring electricity i mean
there is no dam no source of dam in the
hill country a dam has been started at
the edge of the hill country but uh it's
the depression it's 1937 the company
that was doing it has run out of money
to do it and so the dam has stopped and
even if you build a dam how are you
going to get electricity out to these
scattered
farms isolated farms miles one by one
laying lines across the hill
well to watch lyndon johnson do that to
watch him
do what he had to do to get the dam
built then persuade the rural
electrification administration to
violate all their rules uh and lay these
lines when i think they had a minimum of
like 10 people per mile they wouldn't
lay lines but they didn't have that
there but he gets them to do it
he keeps asking roosevelt for money to
build the dam every time he sees him he
asks him for money he has has
intermediaries rose both aides they're
always asking him and finally roosevelt
said oh give the kid the dam
and electricity comes to the hill
country
and
these people the people of his 10th
congressional district are brought in a
stroke by one man
using governmental to his genius for
government
brings them into the hill to the 20th
century
and the fact that he did that means that
we see in the hill country the
beginnings of what i'm talking about
beginnings of something else in lyndon
johnson not just an understanding of
what should be done to help people who
were fighting forces too big for them to
fight themselves they were never going
to get electricity on their own no
private company was going to uh bring it
in there wasn't profitable enough
not just an understanding of what should
be done to help people
but the ability to help them
a gift that he had
quite a rare gift really a talent that
was beyond talent
to use the powers of government to help
people trying to fight forces
too big for them to fight themselves you
know his father was a populist
legislator
served six terms in the texas house of
representatives and he used to say
that the proper function of government
was to help people court in the
tentacles of circumstance the tentacles
of circumstance fighting things too big
for you to help to fight yourself
joe said that i try to write about the
effect of power on the powerless and how
power is used on the powerless
also you try to write about how power is
used for the powerless now we go forward
to 1963.
president kennedy was assassinated of
course on november 22nd and lyndon
johnson has become president
under president kennedy there had been
some
vague hardly defined early discussions
about a poverty program an anti-poverty
program because over one-fifth of the
united states or 33 million people
actually
in uh that year in 1963 were still
living below the poverty line
on the day after the assassination on
the saturday on november 23rd
at the end of the day lyndon johnson
meets in his office in the executive
office building he still hasn't moved
into the white house with four of
president kennedy's economic advisers
walter heller who's chairman of the
council of economic advisers kermit
gordon the director of the budget bureau
douglas dillon the secretary of the
treasury
and gardner-ackley whose title escapes
me at the moment
he was a deputy to hella
the meeting is about budget
johnson is coming in in the middle of
the budget
process
knowing very little about it has to get
brought up to speed it's a long meeting
but at the end of the meeting
as heller is leaving
he's walking out the open door and
lyndon johnson is beside him
we know what
uh heller said and we know what
johnson's response was
because both heller and ackley left
notes on the meeting and their notes
coincide exactly
heller mentions the proud anti-poverty
program
johnson shuts the door
he says that's my kind of program
i'll find money for it one way or the
other
heller had up to that point johnson had
said a lot of things about budget and
his various priorities
and heller had formed an impression
i'll read from his notes
his other remarks johnson's other
remarks he said was quote a little
calculated
a play for support
there he was
lyndon johnson the politician close
quote not about this however
standing at that door heller suddenly
feels that there was no calculation at
all in lyndon johnson's response to
poverty
that was
so spontaneous so immediate
and instinctive and intuitive and
uncalculated response
all
his life people who worked for johnson
for years knew about those moments of
instinctive
uncalculated responses
always in response to injustice social
injustice or social need those of you
who've read my books know there was a
moment like that in 1949 when he learns
that a mexican-american soldier has been
denied killed in the philippines during
world war ii has been denied burial in
his south texas uh cemetery cemetery of
south texas town because he's not white
on the instant john connolly and walter
jenkins are standing there when johnson
they hand them the telegram johnson
reads it and without a moment's
hesitation he says by god will bury him
in arlington
all through his life there are these
moments and here is another one that
christmas i that december johnson
goes down for a two-week vacation on his
ranch and heller finds out that his cat
analysis is feeling that this was unspot
unspontaneous that this was spontaneous
uncalculated
he finds out that that analysis was
correct
johnson is down on the ranch the johnson
ranch the ranch that his father lost and
that he has now bought back and when
heller and kermit gordon get there they
find that those words weren't
meaningless johnson has found new money
half a billion dollars for an
anti-poverty program and they find he is
determined to push the through congress
he gives them a lesson in polit in
political tactics
they have they had thought of a program
as a targeted demonstration program with
uh with demonstration programs in a
limited number of cities johnson johnson
says
tries to make them understand that a
limited number of districts
means that a limited number of
congressmen are going to get benefits
from that program and he says in his
memoirs i was certain that we could not
start small and propel a program through
congress
he tells them they have to his quotas
something like
i knew we had to do it big or we
wouldn't get it through congress at all
and they'd see he's very determined he
keeps asking them how are you going to
spend all this money i've earmarked half
a billion dollars to get this program
started but i'll withdraw it unless you
fellows come through with something
that's workable
very determined and when you ask where
this determination came from as always
with lyndon johnson part of the
explanation
is political he was weak with he had an
election coming up in 10 months he was
weak with liberals weak in the big
cities of the northeast in the liberal
urban areas
a campaign against poverty would
strengthen johnson in these areas
so part of it is political as always
with johnson but as always with lyndon
johnson part of the explanation is
something more
something that had to do with the fact
that when he was doing this when he was
thinking of this anti-poverty program he
was doing it back in the hill country
where his father had gone broke and he
had grown up in poverty back in the
ranch
back at his beginnings
how do we know
that those beginnings were very much in
his mind
as he's dealing with the anti-poverty
program that christmas
well
he saw he talks very often during those
weeks
about his boyhood and about a particular
thing in his boyhood having to get up
early
most of the books on johnson quote a
very cute remark that he made to
reporters as he's flying down to the
ranch
he says i've always been an early riser
my daddy used to come to my bedroom at 4
30 in the morning when i was working on
the highway gang right out of high
school and he twist my big toe real hard
so he hurt and he'd say get up lyndon
every other boy in town's got a half
hour's head start on you that's
that's sort of cute
but there's nothing really cute about
other things he said
about being poor
called it old i was interviewing an old
hill county ally a hill country ally of
his guy named e babe smith who went back
a long way with lyndon johnson he
recalls him saying
he calls him early one morning and he
says he hopes he hasn't woken them up
then he says i'm sure i haven't because
you were a poor boy too
and therefore you must have been getting
up all your life just like me
this is the quote that's the only way we
can keep up he said
otherwise they're too far ahead of us
calls an attorney in fredericksburg
who's known since his boyhood man named
arthur stalin and says
we always get up early don't we when
staley answers the phone on the first
string we can't make it unless we do
at the age of 9 and 10 lyndon johnson
had worked in the cotton fields beside
his cousin ava
hauling cotton on their knees all day
under the broiling hill country sun
i asked uh that christmas we know from
the diary the backup diary that the
aides kept that the presidential aides
keep that johnson
and lady bird
visit ava in johnson city to bring her a
point setter for christmas and i asked
ava if she remembered what they had
talked about and she said she didn't
except that she was sure that they had
talked about the cotton picking
she said whenever she and lyndon got
together the subject
of cotton came up
we always talked about the cotton she
said we just hated that so much
hate is a word that occurs very
frequently
when people talk about lyndon johnson's
feelings about poverty
in in a memoir that was written by his
longtime
cardiologist dr willis hearst
dr hearst writes that he hated poverty
and illiteracy he hated it it's in
italics
he hated it when a person who wanted to
work could not get a job then he
recounts an incident that occurred when
he was accompanying johnson during his
vice presidency on a trip to iran
and they pass a group of iranian
children and somebody
remarks that they're there have rags for
clothing and johnson flies into a rage
and says as hers recalls it don't say
that i know rags when i see them they
had patched clothes that's a lot
different from rags
and i suddenly remembered
when i read this
uh reminiscence of dr hurst something
that linden's brother sam houston
johnson had told me about them growing
up
and i couldn't quite recall which is why
i didn't quote it exactly in in the book
but only in general
i hadn't thought to take a note of it at
the time but i remember sam houston
saying something like when he was
describing their poverty that he and his
sister rebecca had to wear
patched clothes and i remember he said
something to me like but they weren't
ranks
so these are the beginnings
of lyndon johnson on the anti-poverty
program the war on property and you know
how much the war on poverty meant to
lyndon johnson if you just listen to the
words with which he introduced the war
on poverty in that first state of the
union speech when he flew back to
washington from the ranch to deliver it
on january 8 1964 the writing of the
speech is interesting in that regard
johnson had persuaded ted sorenson the
great speech writer for john f kennedy
to stay on at least for a while and help
him with his speeches a short while
and
i he had sorensen he had flown sorensen
and his three little boys down to the uh
to texas and they were staying at the
lewis ranch which is some miles away
from the johnson ranch his his little
boy sources little voice his dad was
supposed to spend time with us that
christmas but all we remember is him
scribbling in this little room at the
end of the hall
several evenings he went down to the
ranch house talking to johnson about the
speech but when you analyze those drafts
and you can see them in the johnson
library draft by draft swords and draft
one source and draft do you see how much
of it came from johnson
some of it when he delivers the speech a
real lyndon johnson words
sorensen had written this administration
declares unconditional war on poverty in
america
the speech is delivered by lyndon
johnson is
this administration today
here and now
declares unconditional war on poverty in
america he had added four words today
here and now lyndon johnson words and
the speech said unfortunately many
americans live on the outskirts of hope
some because of their poverty and some
because of their color
and all too many because of both
our task is to help that one-fifth of
all american families with incomes too
small to even meet their basic needs
our chief weapons will be better schools
and better health and better homes and
better training and better job
opportunities to help more americans
especially young americans escape from
squalor and misery and unemployment
roles you know it's interesting to watch
that speech
on tape today
as lyndon johnson says those three words
squalor
misery
unemployment
his eyes behind the thick glasses he had
to wear for speeches
narrow
and i wrote his lips
set already in that grim tough line
tightened and twisted into an expression
close to a snarl
and he continued with words that while
none of them applied specifically to the
circumstances of his own life
might nevertheless have had a special
resonance for someone who had grown up
in poverty
and who knew it was only because he
hadn't been given a fair chance
of course lyndon johnson passed the war
in poverty past so many of the other
bills that will be discussed during the
rest of this symposium
he showed in his presidency he
demonstrated in his presidency what he
had demonstrated as a young congressman
a rare gift
a talent beyond talent
a talent that was genius
for transmuting
compassion into government action
into transm in trans to transmute
compassion into government action that
would make the compassion meaningful
the life of lyndon johnson is a very
complicated life
but two aspects of it showing through
all the complications
showing brightly through all the dark
episodes
one is the compassion the sympathy for
the empathy for people poor people
people of color
people caught in the tentacles of
circumstance
and the other is the great gift the
talent beyond talent to make compassion
meaningful
meaningful how
to help people fight p forces too big
for them to fight alone
the proper role of government
and as i said at the beginning of my
talk it all went back to the beginning
now i may have talked too long but if i
could write short i wouldn't always be
writing thousand page books thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
you're watching american history tv all
weekend evolution on youth activism and
the environment
[Music]
this week on q a
two-time pulitzer prize-winning author
robert carro discusses the passage of
power his latest book in the
multi-volume biography series entitled
the years of lyndon johnson
[Music]
robert carrow in your fourth book about
london johnson the passage of power
you talk about the tension between
lyndon baines johnson and robert kennedy
yes
give us some background on when they met
and why there was so much hatred between
the two well the first time they met
is fascinating lyndon johnson is the
great powerful majority leader of the
senate robert kennedy is this 27 year
old new staffer for senator joseph
mccarthy on his committee the first how
do we know what happened the first time
they met because two of johnson's staff
people were with him and told me the
same story
uh he had breakfast every morning
johnson in the senate cafeteria and joe
mccarthy had this big round table near
the cashiers
register where he would sit with his
staffers and johnson walks in one
morning and mccarthy is there with four
or five of his staffers including bobby
kennedy
and mccarthy jumps up in deference to
johnson as they all do and all the other
staffers get up
except robert kennedy he just sits there
and johnson walks over to the table and
shakes hands and he sees that bobby
kennedy isn't getting up so johnson you
know knows how to handle any situation
like that so he sort of stands there as
it's described to me like this sort of
forcing robert kennedy to get up and he
does
and george reedy who was johnson's press
secretary who was there says there was
no reason for it do you ever see two
dogs come into a room and they've never
met and the hair rises on the back of
their neck and there's a low growl there
was just something chemical between
those two guys
when was the next time they had some
kind of a confrontation
well uh
the next time they actually had a
confrontation would probably be at the
democratic convention in 1960 where jack
kennedy joined president kennedy well
still the nominee has orphaned lyndon
johnson the vice presidency
just a second on that
age factor how old would bobby kennedy
roughly been there and how old would
lyndon johnson have been uh in 1960 yeah
well lyndon johnson was 52. i can answer
that
very quickly
uh bobby kennedy was born in 29 so i
guess he was 34-35
yeah
but so there was a great deal difference
in age and what had lyndon johnson
done up until the time he was selected
and what had robert kennedy done well up
to the time at the time that johnson
starts running against jack kennedy for
the nomination
for the 1960 democratic nomination he
has been the senate majority leader for
six years he has been the greatest
majority leader in history he made the
senate work
it introduced its own bills it passed
bills
it was the center of governmental
ingenuity and
energy in washington and he was
considered the most powerful democrat in
the country the second they called him
the second most powerful man in the
country second only to president
eisenhower robert kennedy uh had been a
congressional staffer but for the last
two years he had been running his
brother's
presidential campaign
you say he worked for joseph mccarthy
why
well
[Music]
uh he left mccarthy's committee
eventually you know uh but there was a
time and he's frank to admit it in his
memoirs where he believed that something
had to be done
about the communist conspiracy in this
country and that mccarthy was the only
person doing it and you know
considering you know a large part of
this book
is about how bobby kennedy changed it's
a fascinating thing i mean it's an
evolution you know he says to somebody
all that happened was i got older but i
don't think that's all that happened he
changed as a human being into something
by the end of the book
you see something quite different but
when he was a young
prosecutor for our first mccarthy's
committee and gen john mcclellan's
rackets committee liberals called him a
torcomata and if you see newsreels of
him questioning witnesses in this way
you know not giving them a chance to
answer you know he was a very
hard-nosed uh militant prosecutor
so you go back to this 60 convention yes
why did
john f kennedy offer lyndon johnson the
vice presidency
can i say first nobody knows you know
what's in somebody's mind um
he had
in retrospect we see and do i think that
john f kennedy saw it from the beginning
not in retrospect because he was quite a
brilliant politician he had to have
lyndon johnson in 1956 eisenhower had
the solid south was not solid for the
democrats anymore eisenhower had taken
five of the 11 confederate states in
1956. one of them was texas no democrat
including john f kennedy was going to
win the presidential election against
nixon without carrying texas so we had
in a way you say he had to have johnson
on the ticket
so lyndon johnson
ran against him for the nomination why
did he lose
well that's one of the fascinating
stories in the book you know to me i
don't say i did it fascinating but it's
fascinating all is life
the one quality about lyndon johnson
about
is his decisiveness his a will his
ability to his willingness to act to
make decisions and to white and to try
as hard as he could for everything here
he's wanted to be president all his life
you know lyndon johnson has only had one
goal in his life to be president
in 1958 he seems
perfectly determined
uh perfectly positioned to become
president
uh he's been the majority leader he has
all the senators in his camp he has
passed the first civil rights act in
history to blunt some of the northern
antagonism to him
he calls i i have in the book in in 1958
he calls seven or eight of his top
lieutenants to his ranch he says i'm
destined to be president i mean one of
them says i was meant to be president
you all know that and i'm going to be
president
and then suddenly and they're waiting
for the campaign to begin
and suddenly
he doesn't run he doesn't give any
orders he doesn't want to go and speak
anywhere he's terribly indecisive and
really he throws away
his chance at this nomination
why
well it
people who knew him best
say
like john connolly was his
who later became secretary of the
treasury secretary of the navy his great
politician
once had me down to his ranch for three
days
and those interviews were fascinating to
me because he was closer to lyndon
johnson during his early years than
anywhere anyone else
he'd come to
to my guest house he had this grand
great ranch down at floresville he'd
come about 5 30 in the morning or six
o'clock in the morning he'd knock on my
door
he'd be in jeans and an open you know
ranch's shirt he then had a great stable
of quarter horses we'd go over to the
railing where the mexican vaqueros were
running them and we'd sit on the fence
and he talked to me and i asked him that
question he said you know the one thing
about lyndon johnson he was afraid to
fail
why was he afraid to fail his brother
sam houston johnson said to me the one
thing that was most important to lyndon
was not to be like daddy his father had
been a politician for a while a
successful politician and had failed
lost the ranch and the family was
plunged into not only bankruptcy but
being the laughing stock of their town
so johnson
when he was senate majority leader you
know bobby baker is his uh the man who
counted votes for him and baker says i
learned
never to let him fail on a vote never
by the way in your acknowledgements you
say there are two people that have not
talked to you one of them bobby baker
and the other bill moyers correct why
not and how hard have you worked to get
them to talk to you
well bobby baker
years ago i made repeated efforts to get
him to talk to me
um
he doesn't think much of my books
as for mr moyers
he does say complementary things about
my books you know he said repeatedly i
think complementary things about my
books but he simply said that he doesn't
want to talk to me
for a long time it was said that he was
going to do his own book on lyndon
johnson
which was perfectly you know
understandable
i don't think he said that for many
years
he simply you'd have to ask him why he
hasn't talked to him
have you missed because these two men i
know you there's a lot of these people
have told you but what have you missed
from either bobby baker or bill moyers
well uh
you miss a lot from both of them um
you can remedy like of course bobby
baker went to jail he had a trial
a long trial he's written a very um
revealing
memoir and there's so much testimony
about him
at the time of the scandal
in the book
that you were able to put together most
of a picture of what you want but of
course it would be better it's always
better you know i've talked i don't
think there's another
off the top of my head i can't i can't
think of another johnson person
important to me
who didn't talk to me i'm sure there's
somebody but i've talked to you know
scores and scores of them and people
like george reedy or harris buzz we have
talked to probably 20 or 30 times
whenever you can't talk to someone you
miss something
how much of the bill moyer's
lack of talking about this has anything
to do with some of the charges made back
when he was an aide that he was involved
in things like wiretapping of barry
goldwater
you'd have brian i have to say you'd
have to ask him that
um
you know with moyers there are
he's written so many memos you know i i
think i spent three
probably three months going through all
the moyer's memos when he was johnson's
aiden in in the white house so you see a
lot of what he was doing but of course
you know he's a very keen observer of
people and you'd like to have been able
to talk to him
go back to the relationship between
lyndon johnson and bobby kennedy you
okay can i just go i'd uh
so his brother said that lyndon johnson
was afraid to fail all the people who
knew him best say he was afraid to fail
to be like his father and he was afraid
that if he ran for the presidency he
would fail that's really basically i
think why he didn't run hard why didn't
you run harder i want to go back to
bobby kennedy how badly did
jfk beat lbj
well the final the final tally on the
first ballot was 806 to 409 but that's
not a realistic talent uh
tally when they get up to wyoming
kennedy still doesn't have the necessary
votes and you see johnson's strategy and
it's a strategy that the more you look
at 1960 you say gee it would have worked
if only he can keep kennedy from getting
a majority on the first ballot
the bosses the the dave lawrence's the
uh dick dalys the carmine disappears
in the back rooms
they will want lyndon johnson and
kennedy comes close when it gets down to
wyoming he still doesn't have the
necessary votes
the chairman of the wyoming delegation
has promised teddy kennedy
that if it comes down to his delegation
he will give the last five votes of that
delegation he they have 10 of the 15. he
will give anyway he will give the last
five votes to kennedy and you see
it's coming down to wyoming
and walter cronkite says on television
there is teddy kennedy hurrying across
the floor you know and he's hurrying
over to the wyoming delegation and you
see him say something to the delegation
chairman who says wyoming chaos has 15
votes for john f kennedy so after
kennedy has the majority of course a
number of states switched to him but
actually it was it was close that he was
going to make it on the first bout i
started to ask you earlier
you
say of lbj and robert kennedy that they
were both
ruthless
yes explain what that means and give us
some examples if you can
well of course it's always
easier to do it for me with lyndon
johnson johnson's ruthlessness
throughout his life
uh was
was striking you know in the last volume
uh
he ruined he destroyed the senate career
of a senator named earl clements by
forcing him to vote for what later an
early version of medicare
he clements knew
that if he voted
for it
he would be destroyed because the ama
had been very active in his in his state
and they called this socialized medicine
so johnson says unless it's a unless i
need your vote
i won't call on you but he really knows
that he needs the vote
and when it's a i think it's a toy vote
and he sends bobby baker to clements and
baker says the sweat was pouring down
clements's face but he had to give that
vote johnson uh
had to
win he had to win
robert kennedy had to win
also
and it's quite fascinating in this 1960
campaign johnson realizes the key to the
campaign are the western states johnson
thinks he has them
the kennedys
think at the beginning that he has them
so they send their younger brother ted
out there because he's the youngest and
it doesn't they've lost anyway ted is
such a great politician at whatever age
he is like 27
that he starts to win the western states
bobby goes out to reinforce this
and johnson then realizes what's
happening and starts but he says someone
had i forget the guy who put who went
out there for johnson first
says robert kennedy had put the bridal
and the halter on the delegates and once
bobby kennedy put that bridle on these
people knew they could not take it off
go though to the
selection of lbj as vice president
running mate for
john f kennedy there's a huge amount of
your book a back and forth not a huge
amount but a lot the back and forth of
bobby kennedy's involvement did he
really try to stop
his brother from putting lbj on the
ticket
well
let's say he he tried to get
what there's no question about is that
he tried desperately to get lyndon
johnson to withdraw or not to accept
the offer of the vice presidency that
kennedy has won in the scene the night
before with 806 votes on the on the
ballot
the next morning at 8 o'clock
um kennedy goes now this is in the
biltmore hotel in los angeles
the two suites of the two candidates are
in the back corner of the hotel
johnson's in 70 on the seventh floor in
73-34 kennedy's two floors up
in 93-34 but there were suites of rooms
i have to stop you for a minute you go
to those suites
yes
how long well it's it's been renovated
it's not
it it wasn't productive
you couldn't tell what they had been
like
before okay go ahead i'm sorry
but um
so there's a back stairs this chapter of
my book is called the back stairs
uh
so at night in the morning jack kennedy
comes down
uh the back stairs because they don't
want the reporters to
see him or either him or robert
and authors lyndon john he has a
conversation with lyndon johnson you
know whenever there are only two people
in a room brian
you really can't say as a historian you
know what happened because
one gives one version and one gives the
other but we know what happened after
the meeting
johnson calls in his three closest
advisors that's john connolly
bobby baker and james h rowe jr who had
been roosevelt's advisor and truman
advisor and he says
jack kennedy was just down here and he
offered me the vice presidency that's
what johnson says
kennedy goes back upstairs
where there's a group of northern
borders who who know they can count
votes that kennedy has to have texas and
some southern states there's dave
lawrence for one is up there and kennedy
walks into the room and he says
he hasn't said he'll accept it
but it looks like he's going to and
lawrence is a picture in this book of
this very moment and lawrence a tough
old irish politician reaches out his
hands to jack kennedy this young great
you know charismatic handsome irish
politician and they shake hands because
lawrence knows this is the key to the
election what happens the rest of that
day
i say no one can know every everybody
has different versions but we do know
that bobby kennedy came down those back
stairs at least three times and each
time tried to get lyndon johnson to
withdraw from the ticket
so which version do you trust the most
of whether they met three times and what
happened in those meetings
well
what happened in the meetings in in um
two of the meetings
we we do know because uh there are other
people involved like the first time that
bobby kennedy comes down
he meets with john connelly and sam
rayburn
sam rayburn gave a description of what
happened a couple of weeks later so we
have that and john connolly talked to me
i took him back over when basically what
happened is robert kennedy comes down
he's very upset
rayburn says in his
statement his hair was hanging all down
excuse me his hair was hanging down all
over his face
and he basically says we're going to
have a floor fight the labor and the
liberals won't stand for lyndon johnson
they're going to put up their own
candidate and
we'd like him to consider instead being
the chairman of the democratic national
committee
rayburn replies with a single word
epithet
and robert kennedy leaves and so we know
what happened in that because connolly
and rayburn both say the same thing
the second time robert kennedy comes
down
he apparently uh
am i going on too long here
okay the second time he comes down
uh
what's happened what happens is that um
john
at each of these meetings he wants to
meet with lyndon johnson and lady bird
is saying i don't think they ought to
meet together i don't think they were to
meet together and rayburn also knows
they shouldn't meet together there's
simply too much antagonism there and the
second time that bobby kennedy comes
down
uh connolly says i got to get rayburn
you know johnson said of connelly he
made him his campaign manager because he
was the only man tough enough to handle
bobby kennedy but connolly knows that
and tough as he is and he knows he's
tough there's someone a lot tougher and
it's sam rayburn sam rayburn is old
we know now he has cancer at the time
he's blind
but he's sam rayburn this massive
unsmiling grim figure who has ruled the
house of representatives for a quarter
of a second and he's from texas so tell
us why he and lyndon johnson are so
personally close
it was almost a father-son thing rayburn
loved lyndon johnson like a son
and um
he would spend
perhaps most sundays in washington at
the johnson's home and uh he loved the
two johnson girls
and uh all during johnson's senate
career rayburn is his rock rayburn is
his support rayburn is the guy nobody
can go around and he's for lyndon
johnson
and uh connolly
says to horace busby the speechwriter go
in there and talk to bobby kennedy keep
him occupied i've got to find sam raber
busby walks in the room he's he's a very
smart
brilliant
little man but a little timid and he
walks right back out he says bobby
kennedy was glaring at me i couldn't
that that was a glare he said i walked
outside i said i'll deal with him from
out here i won't stay in there
connolly comes back
with sam rayburn
and bobby kennedy says basically that he
wants lyndon johnson to withdraw from
the ticket
and rayburn says to bobby kennedy are
you authorized this old blind man so
tough he says are you authorized to
speak for your brother
and bobby kennedy says no and rayburn
says
then come back and speak to the speaker
of the house of representatives when you
are
that's the sec robbie kennedy leaves
goes back upstairs and there is yet a
third time he tries to come down
to get johnson to withdraw from the
ticket and this time he meets with
johnson alone
so what do you think after all the
research you've done did jack kennedy
send his brother down to get him off the
ticket
or not i do not know okay i don't know
um
i don't no one can really know that
and robert kennedy in his orals history
says basically an answer to your
question if he was sitting there of
course not i was so close to my brother
what do you think i did go down and
secretly try to get as a vice president
off the ticket
however
all the other thing we know is that all
that day
jack kennedy did everything he could
to get johnson to accept the nomination
at one point he goes down jack kennedy
goes down the same back stairs to see
sam rayburn alone
and rayburn i don't remember this this
quote of him but ray burns said in his
description of this says basically to
jack kennedy i ask you two things
will you keep lyndon johnson occupied
and happy as vice president
and something else and kennedy says i
will you make him a real part of your
administration kennedy says i tell you
that and rayburn says
then he says basically then johnson will
go on i agree that johnson can go on the
ticket because johnson will not go on
the ticket if rayburn doesn't approve
that
what did the kennedy people call lyndon
johnson behind his back
uh among other things
rufus cornpone uncle cohen uncle rufus
what
well they are of course mocking the fact
that he has the southern accent they're
marking the fact that he's
a big clumsy southerner you know that
he's corny in there but beyond that
um you say why did they treat him
with a meanness in fact a cruelty an
outro cruelty when you get down to it
for three years
i try to explain you know
that in the book
among other things
they were afraid of him
they had watched lyndon johnson you know
when he was majority to run washington
they had seen his incredible energy his
incredible drive and one night robert
kennedy when he's still in the senate he
is leaving you know he's been working
till midnight or one o'clock whatever
the time is he's walking out and there's
one light building one light burning in
the capitol and it's in lyndon johnson's
office and he turns to his head and he
says nobody out works lyndon they're
afraid that if they let lyndon johnson
off a very tight leash
he will start to build up his own power
in washington
if i count right including the index and
the notes in your four books
3 267 pages
is that right 30 267 pages now the last
time we chatted a couple of years ago
you were going to have four books and
that was it on lyndon johnson yes what
happened
you got five you got a fifth one coming
yes i have a fifth one i've divided the
what i thought was well you know what
happened
well that's such a good question
you know the last half of this book
is the assassination and what happens in
the 47 days after that
and i'm writing it and i'm watching
lyndon johnson take all the reigns of
power up
so dramatic to see what he does
i'm saying you know all my books i know
i've told you this on previous programs
i don't regret this as just the
biography of lyndon johnson i want each
book to examine a kind of political
power in america and i'm saying this is
a kind of political power
seeing what a president can do in a
moment of great cr in a time of great
crisis great crisis how he gathers all
around what does he do to get
legislation moving to take command in
washington
that's a way of examining power in a
time of crisis i said i want to do this
in full i suppose it takes 300 pages in
there
so i couldn't
that's why i just said let's examine
this
in your book
lyndon johnson
i think safe to say does
lies to the public
about about a number of things
uh including his relationship i mean you
go on his relationship with his
blind trust and things like that but how
often from what you've seen in this book
did lyndon johnson lie to the public
about anything when he became president
oh
this you know these 7 47 days seven
weeks
is a period unlike any other in lyndon
johnson's life
i mean he has all these forces within
him lying is a big part
of his entire career
up to here
um
but it's like he rises to something else
and i don't think it's really part
although there are hints of it you know
i in his stopping the texas jury what he
does to stop the texas journalists from
looking into his uh
fortune
uh
but it's a minor part of what he does
because
he knows he has to be a president
he has to the country needs continuity
their young
president has just been struck down in
an incident and although you know most
of these conspiracy theories are
disproved in a couple of days that's not
the headlines as air force one is flying
back to washington here are the
headlines you know
suspect arrested
suspect
charge suspect visited soviet embassy in
mexico city soviet has a suspect has
ties to
castro anti-castro groups we had just
come through a year before the cuban
missile crisis nuclear crisis of nuclear
war
the country
it would be very easy for the the
country to become
very it's worried there's an anger let
me strike that
the country was worried there was a
great anxiety in the country
johnson knows he has to step off that
plane and be a president and he is he
rises to it and for the next seven weeks
he
he is a president there are no rages you
know you've interviewed me before a big
part of lyndon johnson's life is not
just his lying but his raging his
bullying of subordinates
there's none of that
someone says it's like an alarm clock
had always told him to yell at somebody
every 20 minutes he says for seven weeks
this alarm clock didn't go off
i actually want to take a moment out
here in just a couple minutes and run a
audio tape
of one of your sources before i do
though i want to ask you to tell us how
important george reedy was
to this book george really was really
important to the speaker and who was he
george reedy was lyndon johnson's press
secretary
for basically with in a couple of
intervals from 1950
to
1960
65.
and in the senate he was the closest
they to him and he and johnson relied on
him
uh for strategy really was quite a
brilliant man and uh johnson relied on
him
to help him work out the strategy in the
um
this is about a couple minutes and it's
lyndon johnson on the phone with george
reedy so we can get a sense of what
their relationship was okay
yes sir why don't you answer me in there
because i was outside just stepping in
as it rains sir all right uh now tell me
i'm going to announce to the cabinet but
what time we have the ceremony and where
and so forth it's in the east room
the network say 6 45 is the absolute
best time sir
we put way to them cold
and they say 6 45 both nbc and cbs will
carry live
and the summer abc stations will carry
live and others will take
well i thought seven is what we asked
them to do because it was it was and
they'll do it but uh we'll get better
play at 6 45 this thing
[Music]
well i don't believe that at the cheaper
time and seven o'clock is that they see
6 45 is 4 45 in a good part of our
country george that's right sir but that
of course will be replayed and tape
oh well i i mean that's not an answer to
it
like it'd be better to me in texas to
have some at five o'clock when people
getting off that
i don't see why it would be better 6 45
and 7. because one of their stations
will carry it live that's why
down i don't need it
now
i just don't believe it
i don't either but i'm impressed just
passing on what the pool said
i guess they don't want to
interrupt uh that's the seven o'clock
news nbc then and that they get it on 6
45
and then i guess the cbs uh didn't mind
that cheap time but
it seemed like that's what they're after
there's no doubt sir
they'll carry it i think i can't imagine
they're turning it down
well what time we're going to announce
it that's what i'm about to do what
let's think about it we got i don't do
this in a hurry and i don't know enough
about it and i don't think anybody in
our outfit knows enough about the radio
television i believe they're selfish
bastards they're like jessie kellem he
wants anything carried the afternoon he
can because he don't want to give up
that night primary time that's right and
you see uh if it's seven o'clock here
it's uh five in texas but if it's 6 45
here just 4 45 there and hell it's about
3 45 in california
and i just don't believe you're going to
get much audience i think later in the
evening you do it to very bro that's my
opinion thought let's go decided let's
talk about bill moyers in here
and uh let's just try to reason it out
there's a lot in there i want to ask you
about including his reference to jesse
kellum just so we could put that into
perspective yes
it was jessie kellum was the manager of
the johnson radio and television uh
stations in austin
and how many stations did they they have
in austin one austin had only one
television station w uh lbj and that
later changed uh different call letters
but it had all three networks that it
was yes it did yes it did why only one
television star
well uh
the fcc only allowed one
uh channel there you know airplane
pilots used to say you could always if
you get louis over the united states you
could always tell when you were over
austin it was the only city that only
had one television antenna
you do talk in the book about jesse
kellum and
the money managers of london johnson and
i'll come back to that but
uh what did you hear in that well i've
heard first of all
a
a press secretary and reidy was always
like this
who wasn't going to agree with lyndon
johnson he says no they'll carry it this
is what i arranged i i i'm explaining it
to you
that's why if you really i'm going to go
into this next volume it's among the
reasons that johnson gets rid of george
reedy as the vietnam war escalates
reedy is telling him not to escalate it
and johnson doesn't want to hear it and
reedy always
tried to tell johnson the truth second
thing you hear
is john this is a master politician he's
a micromanager he's thinking what time
does it go on in california and he's
probably right about that it seems to me
he's right about this
he wants it at seven o'clock instead of
6 45 but he manages every detail of
everything the third thing i hear
um
is the tone of his voice to tell you the
truth um
his tone with reedy that's a
there are other conversations where the
tone is a lot harsher a lot more
demanding
the jesse kelm part of this what do you
hear what do you hear in that
conversation
i listen to hundreds of hours
i mean you hear him even harsher when
some conference yes
but go back to the jessie kellum thing
and i asked you about how often he lied
to the public
you have a whole section where you talk
about
uh his relationship to the media and his
threats yes i mean we heard a lot of
that during the nixon administration but
this is going on i don't think we've
known this about johnson and it's the
reason
that i do go into the the three threats
that he makes
down in december 1963 he's been in
office
for a month from november 22nd obviously
and he's defeated congress he's got
kennedy's civil rights bill started
through congress he's got kennedy's tax
bill cut bill which was stolen started
he defeats congress on another thing he
just murdered he says i want them
murdered on this and he murders them he
flies off to texas and but down for a
two-week vacation during which he
starts to create the war on poverty
wonderful thing but he also has a number
of conversations
about he's worried that the press is
getting too close
to the fact that he's accumulated a
fortune during his life
what do you want me to tell about the
kellum sure
one of them involves this man jesse
kellum
kellum comes out to the ranch and says
there's a reporter margaret meyer
m-a-y-e-r but pronounced meyer
from the dallas times herald who sent me
this list of questions
what do i do about it
johnson
telephones the managing editor of myers
newspaper the dallas times herald and
says basically the exact quotes are in
the book
says you know you don't want to be
investigated
me
because you know someone
might investigate you
and
i don't know if he actually uses the
word tax returns but it's pretty
he says we may investigate you know a
lot of things we can investigate he says
we can investigate licenses you know he
says you know there's a
sentence in there i can't remember it
but it's approximately you know
the last time they were up for an
application um
they didn't go into thanks to me the
public service percentage meaning the
fcc likes to look at how much
of of television talk how much time a
radio or television station devotes to
none paying public service so he's
basically saying i helped you before i
might not help you again and someone
might start looking into these things
the managing editor i mean and albert
jackson has heard on the phone he's
saying don't worry we'll stop her we'll
stop margaret meyer i johnson said i'll
talk to her next week johnson says
something like next week's not good
enough it's a saturday call me back
tomorrow morning tomorrow morning
jackson calls back and says
uh she will be stopped
and washing yes i talked to her about it
yeah uh
they made clear to her they didn't want
the story they didn't want her
investigating how long did she stay with
the paper
oh she stayed margaret meyer you know
was a quite a wonderful
in an era before women became bureau
chiefs in washington
i think she i say i think she was the
first woman to head the washington
bureau of a national
newspaper all right she became a great
close
friend of mine i'd like to say it was
very helpful she covered lyndon johnson
you know for years and years but she
knew she was stopped on this
we hear politicians tell us all the time
that the money's in a blind trust
yeah whatever they own whatever they are
worth it's being invested in a blind
trust you suggested in the book that it
wasn't very blind well i don't think i
yeah yes the
people involved
say it wasn't very blind and in fact he
had i talked to the there was a law firm
called more son than ferguson moore son
was one of the trustees of the blind
trust
and his partner thomas ferguson who was
a judge in the hill country uh
would tell me that uh it seemed like
again the correct quotes in the book
seemed like almost every night johnson
was talking to morrison and telling him
what to do but do you say that there was
special telephone lines absolutely there
was yes there was a special telephone
line in morrison's house you just picked
it up and got the white house
there was a special telephone line on
the desk of someone named earl deith who
was the general manager of
ktpc and several others
and
this book and i
we're going to go in in the next book
into what was actually happening with
the blind trust but in this book what is
happening is that life magazine has
found out about this and at the very
moment that they have been investigating
uh they started investigating bobby
baker and campaign contributions but
they soon found that it was leading to
lyndon johnson
the very morning that
jack kennedy is assassinated as the
motorcade is go at that at the same time
that the motorcade is going through
dallas there is a meeting in the offices
of life magazine to divide up the areas
for a major series on what one of them
calls lyndon johnson's money and they're
going to they're about to investigate
this they've started and they're about
to just make it a big series of articles
so this book covers from what time
period and ends exactly what time period
well i well it ends exactly with the
state of the union address on january uh
eighth unless it's the seventh i forget
1964. no january 8th 1964 because
in that period of time why i do that
in this period of time he takes
kennedy's programs he gets them started
he makes the country stable have a
feeling of continuity but he does
something more he says to a friend to
friends
i've got to continue kennedy's programs
but if i want to run for reelection and
i want to do what i want to do with the
presidency i have to make a program of
my own and that christmas down at the
ranch he basically has his advice
his advisors create the war on poverty
and in the state of the union address he
says too many americans live on the
outskirts of hope
and he lays out the basic outline of the
great society and the war in poverty
that's the ending point
so
back to the bobby kennedy lbj
relationship
what impact did that relationship have
on history
oh an immense it had an immense impact
although that's going to play out in
1967 and 68
largely over vietnam and
in a way over civil rights too but the
seeds of it all the absolute antagonism
you know there are scenes in this book
where bobby kennedy makes as kennedy is
attorney general and has a lot of the
power in the administration johnson is
the vice president and
bobby kennedy just humiliates him time
after time how
well in a lot of ways every time johnson
wanted to use a plane
excuse me he had to get written
permission
uh from the pentagon but that was robert
kennedy every time he wanted to give a
speech
every word had to be cleared
and kennedy does more there are meetings
of they are both on the president's
commission on
on civil rights on equal opportunity
employment
and in two consecutive meetings johnson
is chairing this
the scene i mean i when i wrote this you
know you really say you can hardly
believe that you're writing this
johnson who is once the most powerful
man second most powerful is chairing
this meeting all the advisors are around
as you say bobby kennedy walks in and
wyatt
pixar at the a johnson's chief aide and
starts demanding answers to questions
humiliating him in effect humiliating
johnson and then when johnson tries to
reply
bobby kennedy walks over to someone else
and starts chatting with him johnson is
trying to talk but bobby kennedy is
having a chat and then he simply walks
out of the room on another the second of
these meetings he says to a
civil rights leader black civil rights
leader named lewis martin who was also
an official in as you know in kennedy's
administration listen i have to catch i
have to make a trip i figure what he
says i have to catch a plane tell the
vice president to cut it short johnson
is giving his thing so that lewis says i
knew both these men he says i did not
want to tell the vice president that i
knew he i knew how
how he would be if he was angry
robert kennedy comes over to him and
says i told you to go over and tell him
to cut it short so morton does johnson
just looks at him and continues
talking
there are scenes you can between robert
kennedy and lyndon johnson in this book
that when you're writing them brian you
can hardly believe you're writing them
you keep looking down at your notes to
see are you exaggerating or not because
it seems you must be exaggerated
you talk about robert kennedy cutting
off his ability to fly wherever he
wanted to fly but why then did lbj do
the same thing to hubert humphrey
well when he became his vice president
and he wouldn't even let him use a jet
plane across the united states
you're certainly i mean you really know
this stuff
he certainly did the same thing to you
but humphrey perhaps in spades
um i have to say that
i haven't finished my research on why on
that can i take a pass on that it's the
next volume and i just don't
think i've examined enough well as long
as we're there let me ask you about the
next volume sure i know you hate this
question but what's your time what is
your timetable does it really matter
what i say to you would you believe me
of course uh this book took ten years
yeah yes but although that's not really
right because i thought this was going
to be one book so a large part of the 10
years was done was
doing the research on the rest of it i
have
done most of the research uh on the next
volume as well are you writing the next
volume now have you started writing
i've written part of it just a small
puppet i've written part of it i've
outlined it you know now do you think
this will be the final book
well i thought originally was going to
be three volumes and you know i remember
you saying is this going to be the final
book and i said yes and you said that i
said it was going to be four volumes and
i seem to remember a similar question
from you and i said flatly yes so i'm
saying is the next one going to be the
next the final volume and i say flatly
yes what is the update on your memoir
that you say you're writing well that's
getting very long um i can do that sort
of when i with my i don't know how to
say i don't have to do any research on
that
you know it's my own life
um
it's not sort of a memoir about how i
grew up in new york it's more of a
memoir about what it was like to try and
find out the truth about robert moses
and lyndon johnson and how they wielded
political power
i think there's a lot of
stuff that's interesting to me about how
they both tried to stop at his family
and they
would say just say how about how
i was trying to it was made difficult
for me to do the research on these two
books that's a more accurate way of
putting it and how i got around that or
tried to get around that
what ways have you changed in the way
you approached this whole subject
since you began this back in what
1977 77 yeah what ways have i changed
yeah the whole you know we've talked
about your routine of going to the
office
having the
outline on the wall all those things and
doing your research
seven days a week writing and then
taking time off and then not paying
attention to the book while you were on
vacation all that but what is anything
changed in this in the way of gathering
information
no i always try to talk to everybody
who's involved in something
excuse me
now a lot of the people are dead
um
but i got them you know before uh they
died i'd like to be able to still talk
to them excuse me
you know i used to be able to call
george reading
now you know i had gone out to milwaukee
we had had many kind a lot of luring
conversations in person but we got so
friendly it got to the point where you
know you don't want to if you're riding
away and there's some
detail that you don't have you don't
want to stop and have to schmooze
somebody before you ask them the
question i got so i could just call
reedy i said george
when johnson was meeting with with
george wallace where was johnson on the
rocking chair of the sofa he said the
rocking chair i say thanks and i go back
so not sometimes my hand actually
reaches out to the phone to call reedy
or horace busby or somebody
and they're not there anymore but i
don't think much has changed in the way
i try to do the work ted sorensen's gone
how important was he to you you write
about him in the uh and you i guess
didn't you deliver a eulogy at his yes
general yes i did
inadequate uh for the help that he gave
me
you know
ted uh
lives between me and my office we both
live on central park west i live on 69th
he lives on 62nd i had again formal
interviews with him but over and over
again um i would call and ask him about
something that happened in the kennedy
administration
and he would say generally because he
was a very thoughtful he was a very
thoughtful man every word i thought was
considered
he'd say i'll think of why don't you
come by after work today so i come by
and i just meant going into his lobby
instead of walking by it
and we'd sit there he lived in this
wonderful apartment that lived looked
out on central park west
and he was blind or effectively he
doesn't like to say he's blind but he
was effectively blind so he would sit on
one couch and i'd sit on the other and
outside the window it would get dark
it'd be late in the afternoon and he
would be talking about things and i
remember
feeling
boy i hope nothing happens to him
nothing further happens to him because
he's the once those lipstick i can't he
knows stuff that nobody else knew i
thought i think his relation to jack
kennedy
was so special and he himself ted
sorensen
was so brilliant
not just at words but at analyzing
things that it was like each of these
things was like a lesson to me i hasten
to say that he wouldn't agree with
everything that i have in the book but
he told me a lot of things that no one
else could have told me and explained a
lot of things to me that no one else
could have explained to me
what part of this book was the hardest
to research and write
um
probably john's the hardest to write the
hardest to research too was johnson's
vice presidency because it was so
uh poignant the period to see this
powerful man
humbled humiliated day after day that it
was actually painful
for me
to learn about it i mean i i sort of
sort of i mean horace busby once said he
couldn't go over to the white house when
on the rare occasions when johnson was
was over there
and watch how the kennedy lower level
people treated him
because it was so horrible
and sometimes when they were describing
this to me
however with johnson's very complicated
character
you felt this is a terrible thing to
happen to any human being but to happen
to a lyndon johnson you know somebody
said it was like a great bull
put out to pasture late in life you know
he doesn't know what to do and that's
that's what happened to johnson
was there a time before
he left the presidency at the end of 68
where he
got revenge
oh yes
uh
although we're going to see that you
know i mean
you know it's funny i mean um bobby
kennedy says to uh
bobby baker at the democratic convention
uh when johnson has insulted bobby
kennedy's father called him a
chamberlain umbrella man you know robert
kennedy loved his father was devoted to
his father this fascinating character
joseph kennedy
and bobby baker thinks he can just this
is all just normal politics so he
invites bobby baker to come over and
have breakfast with him and his wife and
it just takes a minute before bobby
kennedy throws chain bills on the table
and gets up
and says don't worry you'll get yours
when the time comes and the three years
of johnson's vice presidency bobby
kennedy seems to think that's his time
when johnson becomes president
he starts to act the same way toward
robert kennedy
of all the subject matter besides the
vice presidency in here
again the civil rights the tax cut all
that which of those
was the most difficult to get your hands
around
um the tax cut
uh probably the civil rights bills and
the tax cut
uh just to understand how johnson got
the moving again you know it's like a
lesson in politics i mean it's like why
had the saw had to stop the book here i
mean i i said you know you want to just
see what he does in this time of crisis
and what he does with these two bills
which are effectively
stalled how he almost immediately comes
in and gets them moving
you say wow you know if you're
interested in political power this is i
i mean he has a gift
a legislative gift
that i write is beyond the it's a gift
beyond the gift the talent beyond the
talent that is genius johnson to see
johnson come in in an instant grasp the
situation and know what to do about it
it's hard to figure out what he does but
when you figure it out it's thrilling
how did he turn a hairy bird of virginia
around
i mean it's the figure the number in the
budget which would blow people's mind
today this was 1960
60 60 63 63
the number is a hundred billion dollars
kennedy's last budget was i think 98.9
billion dollars if i'm wrong i'm bad on
numbers
and harry byrd has said something like
you know be nice if it came in under 100
billion dollars the kennedy people seem
to feel
that he doesn't really mean
100 billion dollars that if they come in
at 101.5
or 102
that'll be okay
but harry byrd is not releasing his the
kennedy tax cut bill he's not releasing
the budget from
i have to go back and say who harry byrd
is harry byrd
is the chairman of the senate finance
committee and he rules to say he's one
of the lords of the senate and he rules
the finance committee absolutely
he's kennedy introduced the budget and
the tax cut bill back in january 63.
it's now november 22nd
these bills are not going out they are
not being released
from the finance committee
harry and harry bird has sort of linked
them together the budget and the tax cut
bill kennedy's people seem to feel
that if they only um
allow
if they only get it close to 100 billion
dollars that'll be okay they keep
talking about going around harry bird
we'll go around harry byrd
the night of jack kennedy's funeral
johnson summons to the o to his office
it's still in the executive office
building he's not in the oval office
kennedy's three top
economic advisors walter heller who's
the chairman of the council of economic
advisers douglas dillon the secretary
the treasury and kermit gordon
uh the budget bureau of director they
they're kennedy's three top advisors
they start to talk about
going around
harry bird lyndon johnson basically says
you can't go around harry byrd they say
why not lyndon johnson basically says
there are 17 people on the finance
committee harry byrd has nine votes they
say how do you know he has nine votes
lyndon johnson says because harry byrd
always has nine votes and all of a
sudden two of these people
write memos on what happened and again
the memos have johnson saying
the same thing they're just small
differences in wording all of a sudden
they say the problem disappeared we had
to give harry byrd what he wanted on the
budget and we could have the tax cut
bill and they they realize a hundred
billion dollars is a magic figure to
harry bird he wants the budget under 100
billion dollars johnson gives him that
and the tax cut bill starts moving
robert a carroll is our guest
this is the years of lyndon johnson and
his fourth book called the passage of
power we thank you thank you
[Music]
for a dvd copy of this program call
[Music]
or to 1-877-662-7726 us your comments
about this program visit us at q a dot
org
q a programs are also available as
c-span podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
this week on q a part two of our
discussion with two-time pulitzer
prize-winning author robert carrow as he
talks about the passage of power his
latest book in the multi-volume
biography series entitled the years of
lyndon johnson
[Music]
robert carroll author of the passage of
power your fourth book on lyndon johnson
why was he so concerned about the health
of his family meaning his
father and your brothers
you know a key element in lyndon
johnson's whole life which his absolute
belief that he was going to die young
there was a saying you know when i was
interviewing people in the hill country
the johnson men all die young in fact
his father died at 60 of heart failure
after he had been sick for many years
with with heartfelt with his bad heart
before that his favorite uncle died at
the age of 57 of a massive heart attack
suddenly
the third uncle lived i
i think till 70. i forget but he was
also had hard trouble
johnson has an absolute you know he
knows he resembles his father amazingly
physically you know same
both tall both had big ears both even
had the same way of putting his arm
around you
and he used to say john i'll be dead at
60. it's a dead
one dead pipe cinch i'll be dead at 60.
so throughout his life he had this
terrible rush
to accomplish what he wanted when was
his first heart attack 47 in oh in 1955
and what impact did that have on him
well you know it was a massive heart
attack uh they only gave him a 50
percent chance
of living
and
i think that must have reinforced
this feeling that he was going to die
young that he didn't have that much time
how often were you in the same room with
him oh
um i had like once in the same i mean i
the only time i was actually in his
presence was in 1964 i was a substitute
reporter for the regular political
reporter on newsday so i covered his
three days of his campaign
i went to new england
but i was no and now he once actually
shook my hand but i never was in the
pool i was never you know close with him
i just followed him around can you
remember the first instance the first
moment where the the flesh came to you
that you wanted to study the power of
london johnson yeah uh well
not the moment but i was writing the
power as i i
can just take a second to say
i don't believe my books either on
robert moses or lyndon johnson i never
think of them as biographies i guess i
don't think of them as i never had the
slightest interest brian in writing a
book to write the life of a great man
what i'm interested in is exploring how
political power worked in america in the
20th and the second half of the 20th
century
so i with robert moses i tried to do
with the power broker i tried to do
urban political power how power works in
not just new york but all cities in
america then i wanted to do national
power and i knew i wanted to do johnson
because he understood national power
better than anyone else in my opinion in
the second half of the 20th century
moses book was 74.
first johnson book was 82 correct and
what was the title
uh the path to power did you
name all these books did you did you uh
name the titles of the books
sure path to power then after 82 there
was 90. right means of ascent
and that title came from what
i didn't come from it i just sometimes
the titles of my books like to come
right out of the books you know like i i
as i'm writing them like i my first
publisher not my current publisher
uh
didn't want the power broker you know as
the title but i said that's the title
you know luckily it didn't come to a
showdown because my next publisher who
published the power broker loved the
title but each title i've had the title
so that's
the path to power the whole thing is
called the years of lyndon johnson
first volume is the path to power then
means of ascent then master of the
senate and now
the passage of power
0 through 02 2002 was the
master of the senate and this book 2012
what do you mean by the passage of power
well it's about i think glad you asked
that
the title to this book came at the very
end when i decided not to go on to make
this a book i said
this is a book
what am i what form of political power
what am i examining here the passage of
power the passage from one president to
another and because it's a passage of a
at a time of great crisis we learn a lot
about
uh the use of power
in the passage of power i've read that
you already have written the last
sentence of the last book which is in a
couple years well i have yes all right
i'm going to read you the last sentence
of each of your four books up until now
and tell us what you were thinking all
right
in 82 in 82 the path to power before the
paint had faded on the billboards
proclaiming his loyalty to franklin d
comma lyndon b had turned against him
i thought that sentence summed up
the lyndon johnson of that period of his
life
he had to get ahead
uh he's been roosevelt's protege he was
roosevelt's boy
he ran on every time his campaign slogan
for one race was roosevelt roosevelt
roosevelt 100 for roosevelt as soon as
he roosevelt dies and he realizes that
it's not if he wants to move on to the
senate he better not be a new dealer he
starts not to be so much of a new deal
sums up the book means of ascent 1990
last sentence by 1955 with the barons
power broken and the democrats back in
the majority lyndon johnson was the most
powerful majority leader in history
is that the second value second means of
ascent
well that's sort of summing up what's to
come
i mean the last uh chapter of means of
ascent
um
he's in this whole means of ascent he's
just trying
uh
for power trying to get to the senate
and then at the last i want to say and
just seven years later he's going to be
the most powerful majority leader in
history
in uh 2002 master of the senate
those years this last this is the last
dozen those years had been happy
12 years in the senate and now they were
over the senate had been lyndon
johnson's home
now he had left it yeah
to me that's a very poignant sentence
because you know lady bird johnson said
those 12 years in the senate the
happiest years of our lives you know you
watch lyndon johnson in the senate you
say this is a place the man was born to
be you know roaming around the aisles
button-holding people exerting power you
know
getting things done standing at that
majority leader's desk you know towering
over the senate you know directing
people at you side he wrote he gestured
and two more men came running out of the
cloak room he made another gesture and a
man came running across the aisles
running the world power enveloped him
but he doesn't want to be senate
majority leader he wants only one thing
to be president so he's going to leave
the senate
and become vice president and be
humiliated
for three more the next three years
it was his home
and now he had left it
and this volume right now the 2012 i am
the end of the the book is
um
if he had held and checked these forces
within him had conquered himself for a
while
he wasn't going to be able to do it for
long but he had done it long enough yes
that's the last sentence but he had done
it long enough
because you say in this book
why i no not you i say in this book
you know you had a lyndon johnson who
before
these 47 days the 47 days after the
assassination he was a certain type of
man
bullying ruthless
conniving
he has to rise above that
to make the country know it has a
president
he has to curb his temper he had a
secretary named marie faimer her name is
now marie kiroto
who told me the mo gave me a brilliant
insight where she said his very physical
movements changed
on the plane
going back from washington
it's like she said he had you know he
always shambled
suddenly he's walking
disciplined like a president
and that doesn't change that's the way
he acts
he has to be humble with the pres
kennedy people to ask them to stay on
people he knows despised him
so he says to them he humbles himself he
says i need you more than jack kennedy
ever needed you he says to one of them
you know
jack kennedy understood things he meant
about history that i don't but you
understand them you have to stay with me
you have to help me
so he changes in that way there are no
more rages in that way uh he walks with
dignity and when you watch him just walk
up the aisle to give us the we can shall
continue speak to you see a man who's
walking in a different way so marie
famous said it's like his very physical
movements he put a discipline on
he's not going to be able to do that
very long as we're going to see as soon
as the next book opens
but
as this book says
he had done it long enough
give us some background on marie famer
and where you interviewed her and how
long you interviewed how valuable it was
to
welsh
it was very very valuable um
i can't um
i think i i think i had three interviews
with her
she came to work for linda johnson in
1962 and i believe
i'm bad on number that she was 19 years
old
i found
she was a secretary who was very
[Music]
close to johnson
by that i mean
they trusted her a lot they trusted her
discretion
uh she was immensely helpful to me
because she was a good observer you know
to me i don't care
how handsome you are or how all i care
is can you tell me what he looked like
you know i'm constantly asking the
johnson people what would i see you know
if i so she was in the
right after this she was in dallas
she's on the plane
um
she actually types the um the oath which
has given her you know i mean
sometimes she said things that are
enough to really
make you cry
uh she describes uh if i if i misquote a
little here i don't have the book
she has to take the johnson has
telephoned robert kennedy
to ask him should he be sworn in in
dallas and to get the oath
and kennedy is apparently on a patch
telephone line with nicholas katzenbach
who has the oath the deck the deputy
attorney
describe where robert kennedy was when
he first learned about his brother being
shot well that's that's robert kennedy
is sitting by the swimming pool um
at hickory hill his estate
and a number of things he's talking to
robert morgenthaur the great district
attorney of new york later
who is then united states attorney and
one of morgantoy's deputies
and suddenly they see a number of things
happen simultaneously they see a workman
hickory hills a big old white house and
it's being re-painted and they see one
of the workmen suddenly stop he's
holding a transistor radio to his ear
and he comes running down this long lawn
toward the swimming pool where kennedy
and morgan thor are sitting
at that very moment before the
man with the radio arrives the telephone
rings and it's j edgar hoover to tell
robert kennedy that his brother has been
shot
perhaps fatally
hoover didn't like kennedy robert
kennedy and robert kennedy didn't like
him robert kennedy was later to say he
didn't show any emotion you know at all
he just delivered the news
so
um
they see sitting on the other side of
the pool morgan thought see robert
kennedy clap his hand to his face in
shock and horror
i figured
well the the question was about the oath
and when london what happened when
lyndon johnson talked to robert kennedy
right after he was shot well he calls
him from the plane
he goes into he calls him from the plane
to ask him basically two things
should i take the oath of office in
texas or wait till i get back to
washington to take it
but he's not really asking
he knows he wants to take it in texas he
wants robert kennedy to agree that
that's the best course
and he wants the wording of the oath
attorney general deputy attorney general
katzenberg really said to me i was
really appalled
that he would call robert kennedy
whatever number of minutes i have in the
book 26 minutes after he learns his
brother's dead the man he hates is on
who is now his brother's successors on
the phone asking him for the formal
details of how he'll take office so
marie famer is on the plane and she
takes the oath and she says i mean
she says
katzenback got on the phone so i said to
marie famer how was his voice
she said like steel
controlled
bobby wasn't when it began
he shouldn't have been doing that
she said so then she says something i
was sorry to be doing it
but it had to be done
she was a great admirer of lyndon
johnson and she said he always taught
you
if there's a job to be done you can do
it
so you know in that great picture of
lyndon john the iconic picture of lyndon
johnson taking the oath of office jackie
kennedy's beside him and lady bird if
you look in the left background you can
see the top of a woman's head
with glasses that's marie famer and what
she's doing
is amazing to me
she is reading the words of the oath to
make sure lyndon johnson is taking it
correctly
she said lyndon taught you when there
was a job to be done
you did it so she was a great help to me
you know a lot of these johnson people
were amazing helps to me
you know in that same picture right off
to lyndon johnson's left is jack brooks
former congressman from texas head of
the judiciary committee still alive yes
did you talk to him yes and how helpful
was he in explaining that situation
i can't really uh
it's been years since i talked to him i
know he was helpful i can't
remember exactly what about homer
thornberry i never spoke to home
everyone
i want to run a audio tape and before we
do it's audio tape of one of these oval
office conversations
why did lady bird
let those tapes go way way ahead of the
plan supposed to be 50 years after
lyndon johnson's death don't know
and how useful have they been to you to
me they're they're quite amazing i mean
when we see
john when we see when we want to find
out how johnson is bending congress to
his will just to take one thing that's
in this book
and you see
you learn so much because what he's
saying to people you know one thing just
everyone says johnson was talking all
the time
when johnson needed information he's not
talking practically his first call is to
george smathers he wants this is the
night he gets back you get her from
florida i'm sorry the senator for
florida but more important a guy lyndon
johnson could really count he was a
pragmatic senator so he calls smatters i
believe it's the very same night
to ask him what the situation is with
the tax cut bill and the civil rights
bill and you just hear smathers is
talking all you hear from lyndon johnson
for quite some time is uh huh
but then he starts to talk to bring
senators around the representatives
around and you say
wow this is a genius at bending people
to his will here's that audio tape bobby
kennedy's on this tape
can we have fbi people there and
have them uh
keeping their eyes and ears open and
preceding them and following him
probably well it's difficult just the
preceding and following uh then
i suppose we can again my
i have
no dealings with the fbi anymore but
but i think maybe they asked them
perhaps did he didn't he get you that
report the other day that he said yeah
but i understand that you know he sends
all kinds of reports over to you
about me and about the department of
justice not any that i've seen
what are you talking about well i just
understand that
but uh he's about to
leave planning and plotting things
no no he hadn't he hadn't sent me a
report that i
that i remember
uh
i just called him the other day and told
him i'd like to have that full report
he uh
and be sure to send me a copy of it and
then i called him back a little while
later and said send an extra copy for me
here
i assume you sent one of the attorney
general he said yes
and
that's the only conversation he had but
he hadn't
he hadn't sent me any report on you or
on the department
anytime
and i get to
i guess
letter every three or four days
uh
let's summarize video stuff and walter
jenkins gets eight to ten of my day on
yugoslavia
there's routine things where people are
talking
but as far as i know them involved you
well i had understood that
any
indication of it
well in any case it's going back to this
uh
uh
that's the uh
they're gonna have this state patrol
there it's just uh
and maybe the fbi i thought about having
marshals go
go along that road but i think that
causes all kinds of problems
maybe the
the fbi could
talk to uh
governor's office down there with whom
they have a laser on see whether they
think it makes any sense if they had a
car that would follow martin luther king
out of greenwood
back to uh
mississippi why don't you have somebody
bert marshall or you or if you don't do
i'll do it well i think that to tell you
to be dealing with somebody you're
working over here
i hate to ask you to be dealing with
somebody that's working over in the
department
that's not a very satisfactory situation
but i would
why don't i call him and see but anyway
i never had the slightest indication
that he didn't want to cooperate with
you or with burke marshall
or any of him he's never indicated
anything like it to me
and i don't know where well i think it's
i mean their
numbers
you know it's very difficult situation i
think for everybody here now
or whether it's nick or burke or me
or anybody that has to deal with them
but i mean as i say we'll all get
through
i don't want to sound incredulous but
how could that happen how could the
attorney general not be able to tell the
fbi director what to do
well you know
um j edgar hoover hated robert kennedy
you know it's very it's interesting
writing about you know people
don't give enough
force shakespeare did
to the key role that character
personality plays
in politics and power
this this
this telephone call to my mind you know
and your question
hoover hated robert kennedy robert
kennedy insisted that there'd be a
telephone on hoover's desk that he
robert kennedy could call him at any
time as soon as the president president
kennedy dies that telephone is removed
from his desk
um
hoover was very close to lyndon johnson
i found uh my my reaction to johnson
said i've never seen a report on you you
know it reminds me of robert kennedy's
with something robert kennedy said in in
this book he says you know thing about
lyndon is he lies all the time he lies
even when he doesn't have to lie
um of course he was getting reports on
robert kennedy from the fbi director and
hoover was very close to johnson and
so here we have two men it's a
conversation about civil rights
it's outwardly quite civil
i'm sure robert kennedy wasn't believing
what lyndon johnson told him and robert
kennedy
and yet and yet the two of them are on
this occasion are working together
because they won't they both want the
civil rights murders
solved they both the two men who wanted
the cause of civil rights advanced in
the united states
you have a phrase that you quote quite
often uh in the book
and i want to ask you where it came from
it's power is where power goes
power is where power goes where'd that
come from johnson lyndon johnson says it
when when people are saying to him
don't take the vice presidency right now
you are the most
you are a powerful majority leader don't
take the vice presidency you won't have
any power johnson says power is where
power goes meaning
i can make power in any situation and
his whole life i said nothing in in his
life previously makes that seem like
he's boasting because that's exactly
what he had done all his life he was a
junior congressman he got himself a
position of real power uh he took the
job as assistant where as the whip
in the senate he made a nothing job i
said no i unless but i had nothing job
no one wanted he made it real power took
the majority leader joe the majority
didn't have much power he made that but
he thought he could do the same thing
with the vice presidency and did he no
[Laughter]
but he tries
right at the beginning
in
two fascinating
moves
uh
he tries to remain
as the chairman of the democratic
the de facto let me say chairman of the
democratic caucus although he's in the
executive branch
in the senate yes
yes
the democratic caucus in the senate uh
he thinks
that they will do it because all the
senators know what he's done for them
you know it's one of his worst misjudges
because
when as soon as he accepts as soon as
the election is over it's like the
realization comes to him
that
god i have no power now
so he's got to try to make some so he
does it i write on two fronts one was on
capitol hill where he tries to remain as
the power in the senate you know if he
had done that kenny o'donnell
one of kennedy's aides his appointment
as secretary
says you know he wanted to be vice
president and majority leader
if he had succeeded he would have been
and all of a sudden think what you would
have had you would have had a president
who had a vice president who had his own
independent source of power the senate
would could be independent of kennedy
then at the same time virtually simon
but that fails
well
at the same time
he submits this letter to kennedy which
generally asks for general supervision
of various government agencies something
no vice president has ever had before he
asked for an office right next to the
president's in the white house he asked
for his own staff within the executive
wing and he thinks he's going to get
these things he's absolutely confident
he's going to win on both fronts
the senate is just an example of his
overreaching where uh
he's so desperate here that he's not
doing the smart thing like his aides
reedy and bobby baker say uh
god he you know the old lyndon johnson
would have realized that the senate
would never give power to someone in the
executive branch but he was so frantic
manic
when he realizes he doesn't have power
that he makes that misjudgment and with
kennedy you know i write this line he
said
this great reader of man lyndon johnson
this great reader of men this man who
thought he could read any man had read
one man wrong and the one man was john
kennedy he doesn't realize how tough he
is that he's going to take the
presidential nomination away from and he
gives this memo to kennedy and kennedy
just handles it by utterly ignoring it
and being very cool about it and johnson
loses fails in but he that was his boast
power is where power goes
let me ask you something that's not in
the book um
assume your book was done by the way was
the last time you what was the last day
you wrote something for this book
not that long ago i'm known for not
giving up my galleys i just say i mean
overall though before you you uh uh
edited the galleys when did you finish
this book oh that was some time ago
because a couple years ago no um
i'd have to think i think the notes took
me like four months uh at least so it's
at some months but while we're on that
for a moment how do you do the notes and
when do you do them well that's always
an agony for me because you know each
sort every statement in my book that's
you know that needs a source has a
source
so there are a lot of notes to do and as
i'm writing each time my publisher says
be sure you do the notes we don't want
to go through this agony at the end you
know
so each time i have a notebook there and
i think i'm writing the sources as i'm
doing the notes
but in fact when i come to do them
they're all these
blank spaces because when i get involved
in writing
i completely forget about everything
else and among the things i forget about
are the notes
so i told them i would be done with the
notes in two months you know for this
book and i think they took four months
or something but what i'm starting to
ask you is and i want your your
perspective on this in your earlier
books you write about lyndon johnson's
mistress alice glass goes way back when
he was in the house representatives you
write about helen gagan douglas and his
relationship you write about
other mistresses that he had over the
years
and then recently we've had this book
about jack kennedy's
one of his mistresses
mimi beardsley alfred did you look into
that at all no
the reason i'm asking is
what aspect does power play in this
relationship that these married men with
families they present themselves as
being
you know
families that are together and behind
the scenes we're reading in your books
and others that there's all kinds of
stuff going on
well i can only really speak about it
with regard to lyndon johnson you know
um
johnson was always sleeping with people
you know is a constant in his life
however
it wasn't necessary for me to write
about
99
of this because they're just
uh meaningless uh has no greater
significance in his life than sex
about alice glass the one that you
mentioned and to some extent helen
gahegan douglas but alice glass i had to
write at length about
i don't think the johnson people those
around you know have ever really
forgiven me but you couldn't write an
honest book about lyndon johnson
without making her a rather major figure
because
he was close to her
for more than 20 years i think the sex
part isn't near as i can tell which i
cannot is you know was over in like
perhaps three or four years
but he always uh was driving down you
know to virginia to her greatest state
and she was you know she played quite a
role in his life she was this great she
was a small town girl from texas who
had become the mistress of a very
powerful man named charles marsh
publisher and oil man
and
he brought her
apparently
they toured england she saw this mansion
there's a great mansion there and celery
caught lonely she liked it so he built
her a replica in the virginia hunt
country and this small town girl from
virginia became this great hostess
center of a liberal circle
very brilliant man but also someone who
was really and when phil you know in
when johnson comes to washington
um he's this taught at the age of 29
he's this tall gangly fellow and his
arms are too low and they're always
sleeping so alice glass
taught him to wear french cuffs so his
wrists would not stick out she toured
him for some reason which i always to
wear countess maritime to the end of his
life this was important to him
uh and she was his she there are times
where she he takes her advice above all
other advice like
when he's in this pacific during
1942 you're only allowed one telephone
call back to see the senior senator from
texas has died he can run for the senate
cedar key and run again for his housing
franklin roosevelt has told him if you
need any advice on anything because
roosevelt really liked him you can call
uh he he says you can call the white
house meaning basically you can call me
johnson has one call to make
to decide whether to run for the senate
or the house of representatives he
doesn't call the white house he calls
alice class how do i know that because i
found in the johnson library her
telegram backed to him and her advice
and the telegram basically says everyone
else which i really means probably the
white house everyone else thinks you
should run for the senate i think you
should run for the ha for the house he
runs for the house there's another point
in his life where he's feuding with his
great financial supporter herman brown
really
really a a breaking field which would
have changed his career this is brown
and root yes of brown and road herman
brown of brown and root who had financed
lyndon's rise was prepared to find him
but here they had really clashed over
something
and she calls them both to
has them both as guests at longley it
involves a dam and a housing project and
she she looks at them
very beautiful everyone's a the most
beautiful woman and says
give herman the dam and let london have
the housing and all of a sudden that
compromise is reached so you couldn't
write
the life of lyndon johnson without
giving real space to alice clinton so i
suspect we're going to hear about brown
and root during the vietnam war years
yeah
are you still going to vietnam yeah
do you have a planned time to go there
let me get through with this book tour
all right
we've talked a lot about lyndon johnson
with you over the years i want to go
back and show you a montage
of many of the different appearances
including
a documentary we did on you at the
lyndon johnson library
my first i was a reporter on newsday and
what i realized was not that i wanted to
do biographies brian i never conceived
of
writing books just as the lives of
famous men i really had no interest in
that at all what i wanted to do was
explain how political power worked
because i was a reporter
and i was covering politics
and i felt that i wasn't really
explaining what i had gone into the
newspaper business to explain for 44
years whenever you paid a toll on any
bridge or tunnel within the boundaries
of the city of new york you were paying
it directly to robert moses because the
triboro bridge authority and other
authorities he controlled collected
those tolls and he had absolute power he
didn't have to go to a mayor a governor
a board of estimate or the state
legislature that was his money to spend
as he wanted but in this room really was
exercised some of the rawest use of
power when lyndon johnson was majority
leader he ran the senate as no one else
in the senate in this century has run it
and during the last two years he was
majority leader he appropriated this
office
well he came to a senate where the only
thing that mattered was seniority you
weren't even supposed to speak on the
floor the first year or two in his first
two years he became the assistant leader
of his party in four years he was the
leader of his party in six years he was
the majority leader and then he set out
to make the senate pay us the first
civil rights bill since reconstruction
and did it
first time i came here i came here
i was looking
for the papers and i
came around the corner like this
and this is what i saw
it's the only moment of my life
well maybe not the only moment but it's
a moment in my life when i felt like
quitting
i was really overwhelmed what you're
looking at here
are the papers of lyndon baines johnson
the 36th president of the united states
and this is the reading room right this
is an area that's closed to the public
you have to be an accredited researcher
to use it
and when you want to do research in
those boxes that we saw down there
the four floors of boxes you'll sit in
this room and you put in a request form
for the box of boxes that you want an
archivist goes down and brings them up
to you on your desk if you're here for a
while and you accumulate a few there's a
whole cart of boxes that you're using
and
sometimes you can actually go down if
you call for one that's in that first
row of boxes and you can see the gap the
hole in the box and the line of boxes
there which is the box that's up on your
desk um but that's what that's what
happens the the boxes are brought up
when you want to read them to this room
it is especially an honor for me because
for many years i have been watching ted
kennedy in the senate
in my last book i wanted to write about
the senate and its history and its power
and in order to get a feeling for the
institution itself
its moods and its customs
i would sit week after week in the
senate gallery and its committee rooms
trying to absorb how it worked and it
was while i was doing that that i came
slowly and almost by accident to the
realization of how much edward kennedy
has meant to the senate
and to america
if he's not giving them anything
he writes no
but sometimes he writes
no
out
and i asked john connolly what did no
out means and he said that meant
that this guy was never getting anything
from lyndon johnson he says you didn't
cross lyndon johnson
what was that no out
we were talking about that was when he
was head of the congr democratic
congressional campaign committee and was
deciding how much money to give
congressional candidate
you say in your book power
always reveals yes what does it reveal
well what what you wanted to do all
along like you know the cliche is lord
acton's statement all power corrupts
absolute power corrupts absolutely
i don't think that that's always true
i think what's always true is that power
reveals because when you have enough
power
to do whatever you want to do
then people see what you wanted to do
it's particularly true in the case of
lyndon johnson but it's also true and
you know power doesn't always corrupt
power can cleanse it cleanses for
example in the case of sam rayburn who
had to keep quiet as a representative
until he became
first a powerful committee chairman and
then
then you see
him moving the senate to
the house of representatives to
populist legislation you see it within
my first book the power broker and al
smith this great governor who had to be
the tammany henchman until he was
whatever 50 years old the most ruthless
tammany's ruthless henchmen in albany
then as soon as he gets the power as
soon as he's governor he goes to the the
tammany borses and says now we have to
pass social welfare legislation for our
people so power can cleanse
talking about four books and 3
267 pages
what
time in all these years since 1977 that
you've been writing about lyndon johnson
were you the maddest
well there have been a number of times
um and why
well
i would it's very um
you get really angry when you follow
some of johnson's methods you know some
of the things that he did
uh in the first volume when you learn
about lyndon johnson at congress and in
college i'm sorry when you learn about
lyndon johnson in college
you say this is really incredible
uh the things that he did
uh to get
campus power you know stolen elections
blackmailing a a woman student
um
sort of
you do get angry at him
you know it's disgusting
in the second volume you get when you
see
you know each one of my books is
supposed to be a an aspect of political
power so the second book is about a
stolen election i said
you know stolen elections are part of
american political life when you see him
stealing this election
and you see the negative campaigning he
uses you get angry at him then the third
volume is probably the angriest i ever
got because as you know there's a
section on leland olds a liberal new
dealer
a member of the federal power commission
johnson becomes senator and he's been
put in there by the natural oil and
natural gas put in there he's been
financed by the oil and natural gas
people his job is to destroy leland olds
and he destroys them and anyone who
watches through my book that's why i did
it in such detail
on
him destroy this man's reputation and
life so the rest of his life is just
ruined you just
it's horrible and when johnson comes
over to olds in in an interval of the
hearings in which johnson is testifying
as cheering and destroying his religion
saying you don't take this personally do
you leland it's only politics you know
you just
yes you get very angry at him okay when
were you the most angry at another
person that you were trying to get
information out of
angry at a person i was trying to get in
other words
there had to be a time when bob carroll
had a temper in this process
bob carroll as anyone will tell you
that's a lot of temper
um
well i have to really think a moment on
the johnson people you know some of them
wouldn't talk to me they all with the
exception of moyers and baker
came around and were helpful at the end
um
i i guess the answer to that is jack
valenti as a matter of fact i can answer
your question because valenti was always
attacking me he was writing off not just
reviews but op-ed pieces and all and he
had you know valenti was a great phrase
maker so he at one point he has this
phrase this young man who came to texas
with a poodle and a tennis racquet to
teach us politics you know
i thought his attacks were really unfair
i was sort of happy that he
came around at the end you know let's go
back to lyndon johnson
in this book and the different
circumstances that he found himself in
his vice president and how was he
treated by
john kennedy we could start with the bay
of pigs and then go to the cuban missile
crisis that's a very good question the
bay of pigs
you know you asked how
did the kennedy administration
treat lyndon johnson we were in all the
books before so many books before my not
all
i
he's portrayed you know he admires
lyndon johnson he gives to the ninja
he they made sure lyndon johnson didn't
even know about the bay of exit that
whole weekend he is sent by kennedy
to introduce
conrad adenauer the jerk the german
chancellor around texas he has to
introduce him to the legislature he
takes them to a country fair in
stonewall he's not even in washington
during the bay of pigs whether he
actually ever knew about it i think
probably i'd have to say probably i
think probably he never knew there was a
planned invasion and one thing after
another that the kennedy administration
does they don't tell them about when
kennedy introduces a civil rights bill
in 1963
for a while they won't bring him into
the picture at all
and finally
ted sorensen is told to call johnson you
know and get his advice
on the civil rights bill and johnson has
to say to him the first sentence is you
know i don't know what's in the bill the
only thing i know about it is what i
read in the new york times this is the
greatest legislator the greatest
parliamentarian
of certainly america in the 20th century
without anyone being close this was a
man who could get things through
congress that no one else could get
through congress and they haven't even
consulted him on the bill or told them
what's in it
the cuban missile crisis
is a more
is as a more involved um
story
but at the end of it
i mean
ted sorensen would tell me
and it's in the book you know be how
frightened
at the end of by the end of the cuban
missile crisis
they were really frightened the kennedys
of what might happen
if there was a similar crisis and lyndon
johnson was president
that's how hawkish
they felt
that he acted
[Music]
i remember sorensen sitting there
and one of these conversations i had
with him
he's telling about something johnson
said
and he said a chill went through the
room you know
so there in the cuban missile crisis
we see
both the kennedy brothers
in in the most moving
uh way
fighting to keep
this from escalating into war
um
just i mean to you know read the tapes
on the cuban missile crisis
there's there are moments there you know
president kennedy has been holding off
the hawks holding them off you know
saying give this
give them one more day but they have all
agreed that if the the missiles the q
ever shot down an american
reconnaissance plane immediately we
would attack and suddenly in one day in
the
messenger comes in and hands john mccomb
the cia director
a message and the message is an american
reconnaissance plane has been shot down
and from all you can hear this on the
taste room all around the table
people not just the hawks everyone says
we we said we'd attack we have to attack
now we no toy let's attack
jack kennedy says something like i'm not
right with this exact quote gentlemen
let's take a break and go for dinner and
we can talk about it later during the
dinner he goes down the hall with
his brother robert
and ted sorensen
to find another way of approaching
khrushchev so it's sort of um
i mean it's one of the great dramatic
moments i mean
president kennedy did some things which
are quite
remarkable as president i've criticized
not because legislative record isn't one
of them
but you really see when you when you
read these tapes or listen to these
tapes on the cuban missile crisis you
were already saying we were on the verge
of nuclear war and these two brothers
i i have i mean there's at one point
where a russian ship
breaks the blockade you know it goes
through the blockade
and is heading toward cuba again we've
said we'd attack
and robert kennedy says something like
can't we wait one more day you know and
and president kennedy says something
like i'm wrong with the exact quotes
here uh president kennedy says something
like yes we can wait one more day and i
wrote so peace had one more day
you talked about ted sorensen in another
hour you talked about how important a
source he was for you yes
what did ted sorensen think
just an award or two about linda johnson
in a word or two
contempt
we have a another audio tape you may
have heard this
arthur schlesinger interviewing lady not
lady bird but mrs kennedy jacqueline
onassis kennedy
that happened this tape would have been
made in march to june in 1964 talking
about ted sorensen she's already
suggested that she's irritated in an
earlier time that ted sorensen keeps
wanting to people to think he wrote the
speeches and wrote profiles and courage
let's listen it's hard to hear so listen
closely
i know one thing about the legislative
breakfast that larry o'brien told me
this is something interesting about ted
sanchez and
larry couldn't stand hits orange
until one night he was telling me
what well you know they were obviously
the irishman would be jealous of the
songs and
[Music]
but he said so many times larry would
have prepared an agenda for the
breakfast
and just before they were about to start
ted would ask to see it and take it
and he just changed one or two sentences
it says
and then initial it tcs and pass it all
around that way
and you'll see that heavy hand of ted
sarnson in more places
i mean he you know
wanted his imprint on so many things the
self-assertion yeah
i told you about the profiles and
courage thing and only doing it to larry
o'brien everyone
that's just so sneaky
was a little better in the white house
though wasn't he
oh yes but i mean i just got such a
petty thing to do
someone said he loved himself and
finally he loved one other person which
was jack and he also had such a
crush on jack i can remember when he
first started to try to speak like him
or dare to call him jack
and he'd sort of blush
and i think he wanted to be easy all the
ways jack was easy the sort of civilized
side of jack could be easy
dinners or girls like you and men um
because the end because he knew he
wasn't quite that way in the beginning
it almost went into a sort of a
resentment i mean it was very mixed up
in his own theory he had a big
inferiority complex so you can see
the things sort of all working back and
forth
but um
and i never saw him very much in the
white house
i guess you'd conclude that she didn't
like him
well i guess that's what i'd have to
conclude
from from this but i think it's very
unfair
because
one of the things that struck me about
ted sorensen
was how
important it was to him for me to
understand that he didn't write
profiles and courage that jack kennedy
wrote didn't he admit though a couple
years ago that he actually wrote it no
he has a very um
he never he
i don't believe that i don't believe
that that's correct uh he i think his
phrase
was something like
who is the author of the book
the man who writes it or the man whose
name is on it and takes responsibility
for it he meant that it's the second
person
the man who takes responsibility for it
who's the real author of the book i
wouldn't agree with him on that in
particular
but it was in talking to me
it was always very important to him
that i understand
that it was jack
president kennedy who was the author so
i i that's all i really can say about
well reading your books there's a lot of
back room nasty comments from everybody
i mean and if you listen to these tapes
of jacqueline kennedy uh there's a lot
of nasty comments about people she never
says anything negative about her husband
but meanwhile while she in that year's
was sticking up for her husband her
husband again on reports we've read had
women being moved around the country for
him
again what do we do what is the average
american supposed to take from all when
we learn all this you peel the
cover of the onion back and it's not
very attractive
well
for my you know
as i say for myself with lyndon johnson
most of the sex had no
meaning outside it
likewise with my first
subject robert moses
um but by the way my question really
isn't to the sex so much is it to the
trust that we have in leaders and the
lying that you report on and just the
whole nasty attitude behind the scenes
about individuals
well
um
you mean about the mistresses
well that's a very tough hit it's a very
tough business the staffs of robert
kennedy and jack kennedy
hated lyndon johnson
looked down on the texas people the
texas people say to me you could feel
one of them another secretary ashton
ganella i think it was said to me they
they made you feel every minute they
were in and you weren't you know
uh
they they sniped at each other they made
the kennedy people call lyndon johnson
you know
in fact
they call it's not just they call him
rufus cornpone they called him and lady
bird uncle cornbone and his little pork
chop you know mean horrible thing when
the rare occasions when lyndon johnson
would be invited out to one of the many
dinner parties that robert kennedy had
at hickory hill ethel would put him at
the losers table you know well he knew
he was at the losers table
um
another incident which is hard to it's
hard to believe and if you if is two of
the kennedy people are mid mid-level
kennedy people are having a conversation
at a cocktail party
and they notice a third person come up
in the way you do at a cocktail party
and you want to get in the conversation
but
it's lyndon johnson so they go on
ignoring him after a while he turns
around and walks away and one of them
says to the other i think we just
insulted the vice president of the
united states and the other one
basically says
i can't repeat it you'd have to bleep it
out
they didn't care what they did he was a
laughingstock to them but behind him
being a laughing stock was their fear of
him that they knew what he if they let
him off this tight leash what he might
do
we don't have but a minute or two left
what has been the best use in your
opinion just a personal thing of your
four books so far
uh by either educators or any any aspect
of any number of people in the country
well there's only one thing that's the
best use for me and that's to
teach kids about political power you
know i started doing these because i
felt that in a democracy
power really comes
from us
from the readers if you will
they vote
they have the power so the more they
understand about how the political
process really works
the better therefore our democracy would
have to be
so my books try to explain political
power and the best thing for me and it
happens i must say
an okay number of times in new york as
you're riding the subway and you see
kids reading
paperbacks of the four volumes and the
power broker nothing makes me feel
better than i mean heiner and my wife
sometimes says you know if you win an
award or something i have won some
awards
don't they make you happy you know well
they do of course they do but what makes
you happy is to see a kid reading your
book on the subway in the past you've
always dedicated your book to aina yes
uh you do it again however this time
it's chase carla chase is my son carl is
my daughter-in-law and the three jerry
shaina and jesse jesse jesse uh how old
are your grandkids
23 22 and 20. do they follow what you do
well
they read the books
one of them really
one one that's a bad question
[Laughter]
i would say
uh
possibly
one of them has read every word several
times
barry he's in he's going into politics
in politics he's a campaign consultant
and he's read every word you know
and i think the others have read
some of them
the title of the book is the years of
lyndon johnson the fourth book of robert
carroll's
five book series this one's called the
passage of power and we thank you very
much thank you
[Music]
for a dvd copy of this program call
[Music]
or to give us your 1-877-662-7726 about
this program visit us at q a dot org
q a programs are also available as
c-span podcasts
[Music]
next on c-span british prime minister's
question time
ladies thank you
for your attention and your
maximum presence here
attest to the fact that it's my distinct
pleasure
to be introducing one of the
foremost biographers in the united
states history
he is a
remarkable
and exemplary
historian of our recent past
robert a caro
is the winner of two pulitzer prizes
two national book critics circle awards
and many many other honors
following his first book
the power broker a biography of robert
moses
who was the man who conceived of the
multi-jurisdictional
public authority multi-state public
authority
and in that process
helped transform new york city
he has now brought his extraordinary eye
for
detail
to another power broker
former u.s president lyndon haynes
johnson
his latest book is the fourth in a truly
monumental
series
about johnson
it is
titled the passage of power
the years of lyndon johnson
it is one of
the most
exacting
and at the same time
vividly
recounted as a narrative story
believable about an individual
illustrative
of our complex political life
and
a model
of how history can be really written
when you do detailed research
and yet
still have that old classic magic of all
literature which is telling a good story
that draws you in ladies and gentlemen
one of the great
storytellers of america
robert a carrot
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
jim thank you that was such a wonderful
introduction in fact it was such a
wonderful introduction it reminds me of
what lyndon johnson used to say when he
got an especially nice introduction he
used to say that he wished his parents
were alive to hear it
because his father would have loved it
and his mother would have believed it
[Applause]
you know when winston churchill was
writing his great
biography of his ancestor lord walboro
someone asked him how he was coming
along
and he said i'm working on the fifth of
a projected four volumes
well i'm not comparing myself to winston
churchill but in regard to the lyndon
johnson biography we're sort of in the
same boat
i've been writing about lyndon johnson
so long that people sometimes ask me
don't you get bored
and the answer is that the very opposite
is true
for one reason i don't think of these
books as being about lyndon johnson just
as i didn't think of the power broker as
being about robert moses i never had the
slightest interest in writing a book
just to tell the life of a famous man
from the moment i first thought of doing
books i thought of biographies
i thought of biographies as a way of
examining the great forces that shaped
the times that they lived in and
particularly political power
why is political power so important
well we live in a democracy so
ultimately we have the power and the
votes that we cast at the ballot boxes
and therefore the more that we know
about how political power really works
not as it's taught in textbooks and high
schools and colleges but the raw naked
reality of political power the better
our votes should be and the better our
country should be
and lyndon johnson is the right man to
examine political power through he was
such a genius in the use of it in
bending congress in all washington to
his will the greatest genius in the use
of political power that america produced
in the second half of the 20th century
and it's endlessly fascinating to me at
least to watch him use it over and over
again in this book that i just published
the passage of power
to see him step into the presidency
where after president kennedy is
assassinated with no preparation at all
think of that no preparation at all and
today political scientists say that the
time between election day and november
and inauguration day is 11 weeks they're
saying that's too short a time for a
president to get ready to assume office
lyndon johnson had two hours and six
minutes basically the time for which he
was sworn in on the plane air force one
said let's get airborne and it landed in
washington he had to get off the plane
ready to be president of the united
states and to see him step in
with no preparation at all and at a time
when president kennedy's entire
legislative program civil rights and
indeed his other made every one of his
other major bills as well was stalled
stalled completely by the southern
committee chairman who controlled
congress as they had been controlling it
for a quarter of a century to see him
get that program up and running and pass
it ramming it through
to watch lyndon johnson do that in the
first weeks after kennedy's
assassination is a lesson in what a
president can do if he not only knows
all the levers to pull
but has the will
in lyndon johnson's case the savage
almost vicious drive
to do it to win
is to say over and over again as i'm
always saying to myself when i'm doing
the research wow
look what he's doing look what he's
doing here
and i try i don't say i succeeded but i
try to explain that in my books
and to me
to see him doing that is something
that's not only fascinating but
revelatory giving a true insight into
how power works in washington
and there's another reason that i don't
get tired of doing these books of lyndon
johnson
because you're always learning something
new
and that goes even if what you're
researching
is something that's been written about a
thousand
or
ten thousand times already
as isn't the case in the centerpiece of
this book
the assassination of president kennedy
during a motorcade in dallas
on november twenty second nineteen sixty
three lyndon johnson was in that
motorcade too you know the first car in
the first car president kennedy and
jackie were riding with john connelly
the governor of texas and his wife
nellie connolly once the sweetheart of
the university of texas still a very
beautiful woman the car behind them is a
very heavily armored secret service car
with agents standing on the run on the
running boards and with automatic rifles
down between the seats and then the
third car is lyndon johnson's car he's
riding in the back on the right side
lady birds in the center and the senator
from texas ralph yarborough is on the
left in the front
is a secret service man
named rufus yarborough
now johnson's car is in that motorcade
too but although thousands of books have
been written about the assassination
they concentrate on what happened to
jack kennedy
not one went into detail
in what i considered an adequate way not
one of them went into substantial detail
about what was happening to lyndon
johnson what was happening from his
point of view
the assassination had never been told
from johnson's point of view that
suddenly came to me when i was doing
this book and i said well we have to do
that
so how do you do that
first you interview the people who are
still alive
john connolly himself was very helpful
to me he had this great ranch down in
south texas with a stable of quarter
horses he used to wait come over to the
guest house where i would stay
very early in the morning 5 30 or 6
o'clock and we go and sit on the top
railing of a fence watching the mexican
vaqueros exercise the quarter horses and
he would tell me about really he
he answered almost every question that i
asked him about anything in johnson's
career but he took me through the
assassination in great detail
among the things that he said was you
know everybody thought when they heard
the shot that it was a motorcycle
backfire
or
that it was a balloon going off of a
firecracker but he said i was a hunter i
knew the instant i heard it that it was
the crack of a hunting rifle
talked to ralph yarborough i talked to
everyone who was with lyndon johnson in
the hospital
still alive who was in the hospital in
with lyndon johnson a congressman named
jack brooks
lyndon johnson's devoted secretary marie
famer
jack valenti kennedy secretary evelyn
lincoln
and i've learned there always seem to be
other sources
that have been overlooked written
sources
like and while i was doing this
suddenly i came across a fact you know
we that
it was to seek was a secret service
regulation that if you were a member of
the presidential or the vice
presidential detail and there was an
incident any incident involving the
president or vice president and the
assassination was in secret service
terms just an incident
if you were if there was an incident you
had to with the first available
opportunity type up a report with every
detail that you remembered and give it
to your chief of the secret service
i asked you know when i asked the secret
service what i never got a i never got a
reply but i was thinking in the johnson
library they have 44 million documents
and i went to the chief of archives
there and said
do does there exist in this library
those secret service reports and she
said yes
and there they were they suddenly
delivered to my desk there were 23
secret service men in that motorcade
and they also were
involved in dallas that day and they all
submitted reports and they're all bound
in a volume that's called
a just not a formal volume but a
cardboard gray binding
that's titled report of the united
states secret service on the
assassination of president kennedy
from these reports you find out quite a
lot
take the report of just one of them the
special agent in charge of the vice
presidential detail
group the
secret service agent i mentioned a
moment ago rufus yarborough
he was riding in the front seat of
johnson's car
so you have to picture this the
motorcade is going through this crowded
streets of dallas from every window in
the office building people are leaning
out every time jack kennedy waves they
surge again the crowd surges against the
police and the car has to go slower and
slower
when jackie smiles in waves they surge
even more enthusiastically to the car
suddenly the suddenly they're out of the
main
area and they turn into a sort of empty
area called dele plaza a
grassy plaza and there's as they do
there is a sharp cracking sound
as i said people thought it was a
firecracker backfire of a motorcycle but
john kindly knows what it is
your borough
didn't know in the instant
he hears the noise
and what happened then is in his report
there it is typed up
statement of rufus w youngblood
to chief concerning details of events
occurring in dallas texas
on november 22nd
and it's in his testimony also before
the warring commission
he hears this noise he doesn't know what
it is
but he leaps he looks up and in
kennedy's car which is two cars ahead he
sees what he calls in his report not
normal movements the president appears
to be tilting to the left now of course
we know now the poignant
tragic reason that kennedy was tilting
to the left because although he had been
hit by one shot he couldn't fall down
because he had as you know president
kennedy had this terribly bad back and
he wore a heavy corset and on days like
uh the dallas day where he knew he was
going to be a long hard day for
additional protection for his back he
would wrap around his legs and
and his waist an ace bandage and a
figure eight configuration to give him
extra support so when he's hit by the
first shot
he goes like this and is therefore
hit by the second shot
youngblood sees not normal movements the
president tilting and at the same moment
he sees an agent in the second car the
secret service car rising to his feet
and grabbing up his automatic rifle and
looking around he doesn't know for what
and we know what youngblood does next
i wrote it this way
whirling in his seat
young blood shouted ladybird said he
shouted in a voice i had never heard him
use before
get down get down
and grabbing johnson's right shoulder
youngblood yanked him roughly down
toward the floor in the center of the
car
as he almost leaped over the back of the
front seat and threw his body over the
vice president's body shouting again
get down get down
by the time only a matter of eight
seconds later that the next two show up
reports had cracked out
everyone knew what they were now
lyndon johnson was down on the floor in
the back seat of the car curled over on
his right side
the sudden large
to sudden loud show up sound the hand
suddenly grabbing his shoulder and
pulling him down
now he was on the floor his face on the
floor with the weight of a big man lying
on top of him pressing him down
lyndon johnson would say that he would
never forget
his knees and my back and his elbows in
my back and young blood is sitting on
sitting and half sitting in half lying
on top of him to protect him and
youngblood is wearing a c a shortwave
radio to keep in communication with the
other cars
and over this short so this shortwave
radio is crackling in almost
in johnson's ear with what they're
saying in the first two cars ahead
johnson hears he's hit he's hit
and he begins to hear the word
hospital
youngblood tells the driver of his car
close it up because he knows that his
maximum protection is going to be close
to that secret service car ahead of him
the
driver of johnson's car is a texas
highway patrolman named herschel jacks
and youngblood was to describe him as a
typical texan laconic and tough and calm
he puts the johnson core right behind
the bumper of the secret service car as
the three cars kennedy's secret service
and johnson roar up the expressway
squeal off a ramp and into the ramp of
parkland hospital now young blood as as
they're going young blood says to
johnson
when we get to that hospital don't stop
for anything don't look around don't
stop we're going to get you into some
place safe
the car stops and four agents sort of
pull
johnson out of the car
and run him off the emergency room
bay
he doesn't have a chance to look around
his car is right next to kennedy's car
if he had had a chance to look around he
would have seen the president lying on
jackie's lap but he didn't doesn't even
get a glimpse of it they run him through
the hospital looking through a pla for a
place they can protect up
corridors and down and finally they come
to something that it's called the
parkland hospital minor medicine section
and and there's a cubicle in the back
there are three cubicles the first two
are unoccupied and the third a patient
is being treated
he's hustled out and they put johnson
against the wall in the last cubicle
young blood is yeah and
lady bird is next to him and someone
brings a chair and she sits down
young blood is standing in front of them
never leaves their side
in the room between this room and the
outer room they're two secret service
agents and at the
doorway am i doing that
well
[Applause]
well i'll try to talk over can you all
hear me okay yeah thank you
and then the doorway is a fourth agent
and youngblood says to him you stay in
the doorway and don't let anyone pass
you unless you personally know his face
so johnson is standing there for
approximately 40 minutes
he doesn't know what has happened to
president kennedy he can't get any
information occasionally he sends
somebody out
a couple of his aides have come in to
try to get information and to see and
the all they come back and they say the
doctors say they're still working on the
president that's the only information
that he's giving them
johnson is standing there against the
back wall
and after 40 minutes a kennedy assistant
named kenny o'donnell who is not only
kennedy's appointment secretary but a
man who really loved him
and lady bird johnson wrote
that kenny o'donnell came through the
door and she wrote seeing the face of
kenny o'donnell who loved him we knew
no donald says to johnson simply he's
gone
a moment later another kennedy a comes
into the room and it goes up to johnson
and says mr president it's the first
time he's ever been called that what was
lyndon johnson like during those 40
minutes when he's standing there against
the back wall of the cubicle quite
striking
talk to the congressman rooks who came
in talked to jack valenti his aides who
who were there
the villain he wasn't really in the room
but cliff carter was they all use the
same word it's the same word that
youngblood used calm he was just
absolutely calm
and they remembered what lady bird was
always saying about johnson who of
course was given to almost hysterical
fits when he had a cold you would always
think he was dying of pneumonia
but lady bird said in a tough spot he's
a good man
and lady bird said that's watching his
face there in that 40 minutes
was like seeing the face of a graven
bronze statue
very tough face
his lips compressed you know almost a
snow
that we know this that lyndon johnson
look his eye is piercing but absolutely
calm and the minute that he's addressed
as mr president he starts to act like
one the secret service agents come in a
bunch of them they crowd around them and
no one knows that this isn't a
conspiracy you remember it was only a
year past the cuban missile crisis
it wasn't just the president who had
been hit by a shot it was also the
governor of texas if youngblood hadn't
thrown himself on top of lyndon johnson
they didn't know if a shot had would be
intended for him they didn't know if
this was a conspiracy an international
conspiracy or some other kind of
conspiracy they say we've got to get you
out of here immediately we're getting
you back to the plane and we're taking
off for washington because we can secure
you best in the white house johnson says
no
says i'm not leaving
until mrs kennedy leaves with me so we
can get her back to washington they say
well she won't leave without her
husband's body johnson says well then
we'll go to the plane and wait for her
and the body there
calm decisive as he as if he had thought
everything through on the moment
now that scene on the plane
when he gets to the plane also hadn't
been described from his point of view we
all know the photograph lyndon johnson
standing there with his hand up
jacqueline kennedy standing next to him
lady bird on the other side the judge
with the bible administering
administering the vote
it hadn't been told from johnson's point
of view and i wanted to do that so to do
that
i said i'm going to talk to everyone
who's alive who is still in that room
i think i i talked to marie famer who is
johnson's secretary if you look at that
iconic photograph in the back behind the
people you see the top of the young
woman's sort of curly black head that's
marie feyner's
head and what she's doing there she told
me is checking as johnson takes the oath
of office she's checking to make sure
that the words are right
i thought there was a reporter i didn't
who
did but he left a wonderful oral history
watching
johnson take over in that room
he said you know i had the kennedys of
course had contempt for johnson when he
was vice president they called him rufus
cornpone they had a nickname for lady
bird too they would they would say here
comes uncle corn pone and his little
pork chop so these reporters
sort of had a contempt for him also and
the reporters i'm talking about a man
named charmers roberts of the washington
post said you know i had only seen
lyndon johnson as colonel porn cornpone
i said it's going to be hard to think of
him as president johnson but watching
him take over there suddenly it wasn't
hard at all he's towering over the room
johnson was always the biggest man in
the room
um so i'm trying to talk to everyone who
is live there
and it's sticking in my mind i've
forgotten someone i can't imagine who i
forgot you know i keep going over the
faces and either they're dead or for
some reason and then it suddenly occurs
to me that who i forgot was the
photographer
now the photographer's name was a man
named his name was in cecil stouten and
i thought well he must be dead you know
by this time
but i had my wife on a look up in the
national telephone directory cecil
stouten and there was a cecil stone
living in washington 18 living excuse me
in florida he's 89 years old
and i call
and his wife answers the phone
and i said mrs stout my name is robert
carro i'm writing books about lyndon
johnson and she interesting she says
cecil has been waiting for you to call
and of course as those of you who have
read the book no he provided a lot of
other details very fascinating details
including the fact that the steadiness
of johnson's hands that one hand was on
the bible when he was there wasn't a
tremor that he was absolutely calm
then there's the flight back
what was lyndon johnson doing on the
flight back seemed incredible to me that
with all the books that had been written
they hadn't gone in real detail into
that it was quite a flight
in everybody's mind is was there a
conspiracy
at every air force base along the route
that air force one is going back to
washington the fighter planes are after
on the runways their engines are running
the pilots are belted into their seats
and on the radar screens in the in the
shacks radar shacks men are bent over
the radar screens watching to see if
there's any blip approaching air force
one in a thousand towns as air force run
roars across america
flags are being lowered to half mass
church bells are starting to chime new
york city the lights have been turned on
for the theater the marquis and times
square one by one the lights go off
traffic somebody hears it unstoppable
just stops his car cars behind him start
to beep and someone he doesn't move
someone comes out he asks him he tells
what happened and the news circulates
from car to car
so traffic comes to there's a push cart
peddler hot dog peddler
and he's sitting on a curb
on broadway and someone gets out and
says
is it true and he says yes he's dead on
fifth avenue
the shop windows
uh sales people come out in one store
after another take the mannequins out
put a photograph of president kennedy
there
on the church bells and st patrick's
cathedrals start to chime over the city
on the plane there are three
compartments in the first compartment
sits the press and staff and kennedy's
secretaries are sitting there sobbing in
the last compartment jacqueline kennedy
assist is sitting next to the coffin or
her husband
but in the center compartment where
lyndon johnson is sitting in the
president's chair there is an air of
great calmness we know what he's
planning because he's making a list on
the little notepads on air force one
that have the heading air force one and
he writes on one of them one staff two
cabinet three leadership has to have a
meeting with the staff has to have a
meeting with the cabinet immediately and
the congressional leadership we know
about incidents that occurred during
that flight
or just in one case just before it took
off when lyndon johnson calls robert
kennedy these are two men who have hated
each other all their lives
at the time
kennedy is having lunch he had a house
in mclean virginia
uh called hickory hill it's a big white
old
house then there's a long green lawn
that slopes down to a swimming pool and
kennedy is robert kennedy is sitting at
a table there with robert
who is then the
u.s attorney for new york and one of
more into his age and two things
happened sort of simultaneously i spoke
to morgan for he says all of a sudden he
saw the house was being repainted and
there was a guy up on the ladder
painting and all of a sudden he claps
the shortwave radio transistor radio to
call it then to his ear comes down the
ladder and starts to run towards us as
fast as he can and at that moment the
telephone rings on the table on the
other side of the swimming pool and
ethel kennedy gets up and answers it and
says to robert kennedy it's j edgar
hoover and it's hoover telling robert
kennedy that his brother had been hit
and was probably killed
so we know that john on this plane
johnson went into president kennedy's
bedroom and made a call to robert
kennedy
he asks him
for the details of being sworn in and
the exact wording of the oath he should
take as president
now you say
if you
is johnson taking revenge
for all the humiliations that robert
kennedy inflicted on him while he was
vice president well you say was there
some other motive
we don't know i i certainly don't know
but marie famer you know nick
robert kennedy patches in his deputy
nicholas katzenbach
to this call
and i swear he spoke to cancer and
katzenbach says you know any one of a
hundred officials could have given
johnson that information i could have
given him the information
he said he shouldn't have made that call
i asked marie famer
who was on an extension taking down the
the words of the oath
and she says i said what were their
voices like
and she said well
katzenbach's voice was like steel
robert kennedy's was when he started but
then it wasn't
then miss famous stopped and said to me
he shouldn't have been talking on that
call
not that lyndon johnson
ever
won at all against robert kennedy when
the plane lands at andrews air force
base he's made arrangements
you know when he was in the i should
have said one of the things that uh
the people in the in the cabin
uh said was how insistent johnson was
that jacqueline kennedy be standing
beside him while he took the oath
because he wanted a symbol of continuity
and she understood this too when she
doesn't come out johnson says to
o'donnell why don't you go get her and
no donald says do you want to do it and
she says for the sake of history i
should
johnson wants
the coffin to come off the back door of
air force one with himself and
jacqueline kennedy behind it and then
the kennedy a's and then his age so
he'll have this impression of continuity
but it's as the plane pulls up on air
force
at andrews air force base
the front door has a ramp go up to a two
when robert kennedy
runs up the front ramp pushes his way
the length of the plane pushes his way
past lyndon johnson without ever looking
at him and he goes down
with jackie behind the coffin we all
know that scene the coffin coming down
on the forklift with jackie and rabbit
behind it and they drive off
and the ramp is moved away so when
johnson comes to the back door of the
plane he has no place to go he has to
stand there waiting while the car
carrying kennedy's body
leave so there are a hundred facts about
that day
that we all thought we knew
but we didn't
and that could help in an attempt to
understand lyndon johnson
and of course
in this book i try also to talk about
the days right after this day
he has his first confrontation with
congress which has stopped kennedy so
completely
he says what's on the agenda there's
some minor bill it's like a uh export
import bill relating to a wheat deal
with russia and some conservative uh
republican senator from the midwest has
introduced an amendment that would limit
the president's power and the k and
kennedy the kennedy people are just
prepared to let it go through not
johnson
he says
i want that bill stopped i said he says
exact words are you i want that bill
murdered he doesn't want to just defeat
it he wants it defeated by enough to
show congress there's a new president
now and you can't treat him the same way
you were treating you can't treat me the
same way you were treating him he stays
on so he gets he calls in his vote
counters and they don't even know
he they tell them they have they have a
certain number of votes but johnson is
the greatest vote counter he counts the
votes and realizes they don't all night
he stays on the telephone making calls
to senators and the bill is murdered
johnson writes in his memoirs
at that moment
the power of the federal government
began flowing back to the white house
and it did
so one of the things that this book the
passage of power is about
really
is about how lyndon johnson
got power back in the white house
and what he does with that power once he
has it back
this book covers the first 47 days
of the passage of power
the passage of power from one president
to another
up to january 8 1964.
by the end of that time
those 47 days
the passage is over
he has turned jack kennedy's bills the
civil rights bill the tax cut bill
he at least started all of them on the
road to passage
and january 8th is also the date
of lyndon johnson's first state of the
union speech
the speech in which he makes the
presidency his own
with his announcement that america is
going to have
a war on poverty
contains lines that if we don't know
them and we don't they're not well
enough knowing in history or wonderful
said too many americans live on the
outskirts of hope
and that's who we have that's his quote
that's who we have to help
the more detail you learn
about how johnson did it
about what he did with congress
and what he did to congress
the more amazing the accomplishment
seems
he sees there's only one the civil
rights bill is dead he sees in an
instant there's only one lever that can
move it forward a parliamentary maneuver
and i wrote in the book if there was
only one lever lyndon johnson was going
to grab it
and i wrote if there was only one lever
he was going to push it he was going to
put all his weight behind it all of a
sudden the new york times writes
something changed on capitol hill
yesterday and the civil rights bill
starts to move
during this brief transition period
what i call the passage of power
lyndon johnson not only rescued his
predecessor's programs but launches this
one of his own
a war on poverty
a war a crusade
for a noble end
that would had it succeeded have
transformed america
that is not
the whole story of lyndon johnson's
presidency of course
there is another volume yet to come
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
vietnam is yet to come
the story of how the war on poverty
and the many programs of the great
society
the story of how the great dreams
are to be submerged in vietnam is yet to
come
but what i try to do in this volume
what i think we can see
with a rare clarity
in those 47 days by watching how lyndon
johnson took hold of presidential power
and so quickly began to use that power
for ends so monumental
what i think we can see is the immensity
of the potential that an american
president possesses to transform the
country he leads thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
i'll be happy to take
questions yes yes sir
in your books you talk a lot about the
two sides of lbj about the dark side yes
the light side yes for example when
president kennedy died he wrote such a
moving condolence letter to john and
caroline yes but yet he could be so
cruel to his staff and to lady bird yeah
could you comment on that a little bit
more
yes
well can you all hear the question okay
yeah well
this is a wonderfully well organized
festival you can actually all hear the
questions it's a rarity uh
johnson is that kind of a person it's
one of the real difficulties in writing
about him he's a person of such contrast
that you feel
his his what you call his cruelties
could be so cruel so monumental the way
he would back break the rules of
politics you know to steal the election
that got him to the senate in quite a a
remarkable
way not at all usual in texas but beyond
the usual bounds of politics that's
lyndon johnson
and the desire to help poor people
particularly poor people of color that
was lyndon johnson and it's part of his
whole life awesome
yes sir
what is your perspective on the writing
of the assassination by the father of
the former press secretary of uh
president george w bush did you ever get
to interview and question that author uh
bart mcclellan father of scott mcclellan
yeah i didn't i didn't uh interview him
uh well i can really say about lyndon
johnson's role in the assassination that
is that in all my years of working on
lyndon johnson's papers and you know
going through his diaries and lots
everything else and all the people who
were close to him i never found the
slightest hint that he had anything to
do with the assassination
yes sir yes mr carro um you know lbj is
well remembered as someone who
was
very adept at navigating the senate and
um
you know working with congress as
president to get some very difficult
things done right how well do you think
he would do as president today
getting things done with a very
very polarized environment
well that's it
that's a that's a terrific question
you know it's
it's hard to answer but part of the
answer is the following
when lyndon johnson became majority
leader of the senate in 1955
the senate was and had been
for
decades let's put it that way the same
mess it's hard to believe the same
dysfunctional
mess that it is today
uh
bills couldn't get past because the
power then that confronted the president
it wasn't a party division it wasn't
republicans against democrats it was an
intraparty division half of the
democrats in cong in the senate were
southern democrats who were just as
conservative as it can be imagined on
civil rights and everything else and
they i think in that year 1955 if i have
the number right of the 16 great
standing committees of the senate
the republicans were chairman of nine of
them and they the senior committee post
was stacked with them the subcommittees
were uh headed by them so they had
stopped every president you know no one
seems to realize this but in the 25
years after the supreme court packing
fight when the southern conservatives
realized that they and the midwestern
republicans were on the same side and
they could control congress no president
not franklin roosevelt not truman
ever got a major domestic bill through
congress johnson comes in in 1955 and in
an instant
it's changed and the senate becomes the
center of governmental energy and
ingenuity and creativity it's working
like the founding fathers wanted it to
he's majority leader for six years
at the end of six years he leaves
instantly the senate is back
in the same mess the nature of political
genius is to find a way
where no way appears obvious i don't
have any no idea what president johnson
would do with this congress hopefully i
could research it and find it out and
describe it but someone will come along
to do it again
yes sir yes um one of the major events
that occurred during the time period
covered in this book was the u.s role
and the overthrow of
overthrow of diem yes and uh johnson is
on record in the cabinet meetings
opposing it um can you elaborate a
little bit on what particularly is drove
his stance and why he saw what what
particularly was it on that and why he
believed
um the way he did on that point i mean
ironically was one of the things he did
agree with ken robert kennedy on can i
take a pass on that one question and the
reason is it's right at the beginning of
the book i'm writing now and
no no i don't mean it and it's a very
con the answer is so complicated and i i
don't have a summation of it in my mind
right now oh um okay can i go bend back
and refer to your book that you're
talking about now then um
you alluded to when you stated that the
united states was running a murder inc
um under the kennedy administration no
no lyndon johnson johnson said that to
robert he knew he would get back to
robert kennedy he alluded to diem and um
trujillo i believe no just the
characters just castro yeah okay yeah um
okay well johnson you know the the
kennedy johnson
i don't want to be put in a position you
know these uh uh of
johnson did say that in his retirement
he said to the reporter you know the
kennedys were running a damned murder
incorporated down there in the caribbean
um exactly what he
what
um
documentation he had for that we don't
know i don't know oh just um there was a
portrait saying we had a hand and
killing him and now it's happening here
that was that was the quote in the book
oh okay i was in the end thanks
yes we have time for only one more
question thank you okay
thank you for your spellbinding um
reporting about lyndon johnson
[Applause]
[Music]
could you elaborate a little bit about
his
stance on civil rights before he was
president and how he
passed this legislative landmark
legislation and what the differences
were in his outlook on that at issue
sure yeah
you know elaborate on lyndon johnson's
stance on civil rights and and how he
got president kennedy's civil rights you
know his stance on civil rights i'm glad
you asked me that because people are
always asking me how sincere he was well
i always felt lyndon johnson always
wanted to help poor people of color and
i'll tell you
why i think i know that when johnson was
in college between his sophomore and
junior years he was so poor he had to
drop out of college to teach for a year
and he toured down in a little town in
south texas called catulla and he taught
in what was called the mexican school it
was really for the mexican the children
of mexican migrant workers
and johnson i wrote in that book if
no teacher had ever cared if these kids
learned or not
this teacher cared he
sort of was so important they learn
english you know and he would spank the
boys and tongue layers the girls if he
heard a word of spanish he would go
among the migrant workers shacks you
know
to get them so he could they would drive
their kids to baseball games so they
could have a debating team in a baseball
team like the white kid
but the thing that got me you could say
if you really want that's just an
example of lyndon johnson always trying
to do the best job he could in whatever
job he had and that's that is a
characteristic of johnson but i feel i
know
he really wanted to help because he
didn't
teach only the kids
he taught the janitor the janitor's name
was tomas coronado and johnson insisted
that he learned english he bought him a
textbook and every day before and after
school he and coronado would sit on the
steps of the school and coronado says
johnson would pronounce i would repeat
johnson would spell i would repeat i
think lyndon johnson
always cared about civil rights i can't
the second part of your question
how did he get kennedy's bill you know
it's it takes a lot of pages in this
book
to talk about all the things that he
does but the thing he does on the
instant on the instant i mean this bill
appears to be totally dead totally dead
he says didn't someone file a discharge
petition now discharge petition had been
filed to take it away this bill
was in um
a committee that was never going to let
it out it wasn't even in the senate it
was still in the house it was in the
house rules committee which was chaired
by judge howard w smith of virginia who
wouldn't even give a date when he would
have a hearing the bill was going
nowhere someone's johnson said
someone johnson remembers that someone
filed a discharge petition to take it
away from that committee now that's that
was very discharged petitions were
almost never past them because it was a
violation of the house rules and no
president had ever really gotten behind
one before johnson calls the
representative who introduces it and the
representative richard bowling of
missouri has been told by the leaders
drop this thing and they listen to
johnson in this telephone call is to see
a genius in human nature because the
first half of the call is johnson saying
of course we can't violate the house
presidents you know
then he says so what other ways do we
have
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you all very much
[Applause]
[Music]
yep
and this is book tv's live coverage of
the 12th annual national book festival
you yep
[Applause]
and this is book tv's live coverage of
the 12th annual national book festival
you've been listening to lbj biographer
robert carrow talk about the fourth
installment of his lbj
bio this is the passage of power now mr
caro will be working his way over to our
set next to the history and biography
tent to take your calls we're gonna put
the numbers up on the screen 202 is the
area code if you'd like to dial in and
you have a question or reaction
to what mr carrow had to say
585-3885 for those of you in the east
and central time zones
585-3886 for those of you in the
mountain and pacific time zones mr
carroll will be over here just as soon
as we can wrangle him from this big
crowd it was a as you could see a
standing room only crowd in the history
and biography tent and as soon as we can
wrangle him over here we'll get him over
we're located right next to the history
and biography tent
so we'll begin taking those calls now
next up in the history and biography
tent in just a little while you're gonna
hear from elizabeth dowling taylor a
slave in the white house paul jenning
and the madisons paul jennings was a
slave of
james and dolly madison and she'll be
talking about her book and then pulitzer
prize winner john lewis gattis we'll be
talking about his book george f kennon
and american life uh focused on the cold
war so that's what's coming up here uh
in in the history and biography tent for
the next couple of hours
we here will be doing a call in with mr
carrow in just a few minutes and then
tom friedman and michael mandelbaum will
be joining us here for a call-in uh so
you can talk to them their best seller
that used to be us and that will be
after mr caro so that's what's coming up
here on book tv on c-span too but
if you are interested in other things
you can go to booktv.org
we are webcasting live the contemporary
life pavilion uh tent from the national
book festival whole different set of
authors you can watch
on booktv.org
the full schedule is available at
booktv.org
so you can go there and you can see
exactly
what we're broadcasting there linda
greenhouse should be starting she's got
a new book on the supreme court of
course she was a long time new york
times
reporter on the supreme court she should
be talking right now at booktv.org again
two separate feeds the webcast on
booktv.org and our live broadcast here
on
cspan2
now we've put up the numbers so you if
you had any reaction to what mr carroll
had to say in his presentation and i
want to begin taking a couple calls and
if you have a question while we're
getting mr carroll ready we'll write
that down and we'll get that question
for him we want to begin with a call
from mark
in howell new jersey mark you are on
book tv what's your uh comment or
question for mr carroll uh
yes mike uh
my question for of my comment ms
mccarroll is one thing first and that is
uh i read
three previous books about lyndon
johnson i found it very entertaining and
i'm looking forward to the reports
but the uh but the question i want to
ask is uh
uh he covered johnson's reaction to him
being president and all after the
assassination of kennedy
what was the reaction of uh
the administration workers uh to johnson
after uh kennedy got shot
and the people's
reaction to johnson after kennedy got
shot
okay mark thanks so much
i see mr carroll has joined us here mr
carroll thank you for being on book tv
we appreciate it and that was mark in
new jersey right and he wanted to know
what the reaction of the jfk
administration officials were when lbj
came into power well that's a good
question
many of them while he was vice president
had treated johnson really badly he was
cut out of power completely he was
humiliated by the kennedys time and
again they would reorganize uh a
committee that he was chairman of
without even telling him he was
organized and as i said they referred to
him as rufus cornpone they they thought
he was just a big
loud uh politician
uh they also were
those of them who were honest and would
talk to me honest about it more than a
little afraid of him because they had
seen him in the senate when he ruled the
senate and could really get
they knew where the power he was and he
they were afraid if he got any
i
they wouldn't be able to keep him on a
leash but johnson realizes that if his
presidency is going to be successful he
has to get them on his side he and he
does it he says to them i need you more
than he needed you
now uh mr carroll we heard in your talk
you said that this book the power of
passage
covers 47 days only no uh five years oh
it does cover five years
okay it begins in 1958
and it goes through
it goes through kennedy's uh and
johnson's fight for the nomination in
1960. then it goes into how robert
kennedy tried to remove johnson from the
ticket then it has johnson's vice
presidency the 47 days you return to it
it then covers the first 47 days of
johnson's presidency that's what i call
the passage of power between kennedy's
assassination on november 22nd 1963 and
johnson's first state of the union on
january 8 1964. well mr carroll we had
uh
tomorrow david marinus who's another
presidential biographer yes we'll be
talking about his book barack obama the
story yes well book tv we asked mr
marinus if he had a question for you oh
okay and he had two and i want to read
those to you okay and this is from david
marines okay you seem to have a
remarkable capacity to maintain your
excitement and curiosity
about a single subject over a long
period of time first question
have you found that your excitement and
curiosity about lbj has actually
increased rather than diminished over
the years yeah it's a terrific question
the answer is yes because you know as
i've said
i regard these books as be as not being
about lyndon johnson alone but about
being about political power and how it
works in america i think it's important
that we understand how political power
really works the realities of it to
watch johnson use political power is to
see the full potentialities of how it
can be used and uh for someone like me
who's interested in political power you
say boy that's fascinating i'm always
saying wow look what he's doing now
and the second question from mr marines
have you ever been tempted to break off
and do another book in between
and if so what subject would that be
well i haven't been tempted to do that i
am writing you know
but i'm i'm
where i've been taking notes all along
on what it's like to do these books the
power broker on robert moses when and
the lyndon because moses would do
anything that he could to stop my book
so there was a story i felt
in the doing of that book and there's a
story in the doing of the johnson book
so i hope after i finish this book to
write a study a really a story of
hunting for power
robert carro is our guest and the next
call for him comes from right here in dc
tyrone good morning to you uh good
morning uh mr carl i've yesterday
enjoyed uh
your books over a
long period of time and uh
it was great to your presentation i did
have one question in particular uh in
trying to finish up uh your first
original book you were trying to find
one specific
uh secret server agent to
clarify specifically what happened after
uh mr kennedy uh
was assassinated and
some of the
uh
other offerings that were done by other
offer authors
that suggested
uh
the secret service had not acted
properly and in a timely manner and
writing down all their notes
subsequently some of their notes were
not accurately
uh portrayed in terms of how they were
handled by the white house at that time
well
uh
my your answer to that is i don't agree
with them
around lyndon johnson and because i was
trying to tell you mr caro if you could
your mic came off for a second if you
could just you're fine if you could just
start your answer again right well i
concentrated on uh
the agents around lyndon johnson because
i was trying to tell the story of the
assassination
from lyndon johnson's point of view
the agents around him i thought acted
magnificently particularly rufus
youngblood who is the agent you know
when the first shot rings out
young blood is sitting in the front seat
of the johnson car
he realized he whirls around he sees
president kennedy start to tilt to the
left he sees in the car in front of him
a secret service agent rising up with a
rifle in his hand and looking around
and he leap he grabs johnson's right
shoulder throws him down on the floor
sort of jumps over the back seat the
front of the back the back of the front
seat and throws himself on johnson's
back johnson says i'll never forget his
knees and my back and his
uh elbows in my back and protects him
with his own body on the way to parkland
and really doesn't leave johnson's side
much for the next week
reynaldo laredo texas you're on book tv
on c-span 2 with robert carroll
yes good morning uh
good morning excellent on november the
21st 1963
the day before the murder of jfk
there's a meeting in washington house
with lyndon b johnson richard nixon
john j mccoy of the uh warren commission
asia hunt and at that meeting
uh lbj tells madeleine brown
after tomorrow those goddamn candidates
will never embarrass me again
that's no threat that's a promise that's
the night before the murder
yes let's get an answer
actually lyndon johnson was never at the
meeting that you're talking about and
all the time that i was working have
been working on lyndon johnson going
through
any kind of his papers his diaries his
logs letters memorandum talking to
everybody who knew him
i have never found a single hint that
lyndon johnson had anything to do with
the assassination
mr caro do you find yourself answering
conspiracy questions yes regularly yes
um
and
my only answer is the answer that i only
gave i would pursue anything
that i found
but i found absolutely nothing
now a viewer here in the audience before
you came over asked a question he wanted
to know about ballot box 13.
what is that and
is that what kind of question is that
right ballot box 13 is the ballot box
with which lyndon johnson stole the
election that got him to the senate
six days
he's running for the senate in 1948
six days after the election he is still
behind when suddenly a ballot box from
precinct 13 in alice texas that's ballot
box 13 is found in the desert
it contains a number of votes actually
if i have this right it's been years
since i wrote 202 votes and they're
interesting votes because they're all
written in the same handwriting
and they're all written in the same with
the same pen
and then you had a sign a register book
in texas when you voted and these 202
people voted in alphabetical order
though those two vote 202 votes with the
crucial votes with johnson emerged as
the winner by 87 votes and that's how he
got to
uh the senate
i remember one of his aides warren
woodward said to me if it wasn't for
that box we wouldn't have had the great
society we wouldn't have had vietnam
american history might have been
different you know people are always
saying that they were always stealing
lexus in texas which is true
but johnson really bent those rules he
pushed the envelope further than ever
before to get to the to get to the
center when i started these books peter
i i you know everyone said we'll never
really know if lyndon johnson uh stole
that election that was in every book i
said i'm never writing about about
lyndon johnson's life unless i've done
everything that i could to find out
whether in fact he did steal the
election and i did manage to find the
very election judge the guy who ran
precinct 13 box the ballot box 13. his
name was louis salas he was a mexican
sort of enforcer for the border county
boss who ran the elections down there a
man named george bohr and he told me the
story and
then everything fell together and you
could see exactly what happened and the
gentleman who asked that question is
standing right there in the berets good
oh good question next call comes from
glenn in pasadena california hi glenn
good morning
yes you know what
i
i
i was with jaime escalante in a mexican
school it was the worst school in the
united states and i wondered if
if the author here
knew that that he gave for 18 years a
million dollars to this poor school the
high school in in in los angeles
and 250 000 to each of the feeder
schools for 18 years that is a ben bend
of the of the rules i think did you know
that
i know i never heard that before
glenn you're saying lbj gave a million
dollars a year to this school
well it was it was through the
government i presume but but but because
of him he was he was the one who who
gave a million dollars for 18 years and
250 000 to each of the feeder schools
and he gave them instructions you can't
do anything you can't
change anything just let the teachers do
it and there was you know it was the
best it became the best school in the
united states because like over 40
children every single year would pass
the college calculus test and the girl
from my classroom got her doctoral
degree in one of the best schools from
the worst school
is that a new story that's fascinating
and you know as i do this last volume on
his presidency i'm going to take a look
into that thanks for telling me about it
and barbara in austin texas home of the
lbj library hi barbara hi i hope you can
hear me i think my phone is acting up we
can hear you fine it is such an honor to
speak to this great historian i really
admire mr carroll and i think he he is
going down in history as one of the
great historians um and i want to thank
you for giving us so many details today
that we never knew before
so i have a question about the johnson
daughters i'm wondering how they learned
that their father was going to be
president and that kennedy had died and
how old were they at the time and where
were they did you look into that
well yes uh lynn
linda bird was at the university of
texas and as i recall i may have this
wrong she was uh
secret service agents notif came up and
notified her
uh of what happened and i think she went
with them to the home of the connelly
john connolly's children conley was the
governor of texas
and he had been wounded no one knew how
seriously at the time and she went to
comfort them
lucy byrd was at high school in
washington and if i have this right
she would she was taken out of class and
brought back to the johnson home in
washington
next call for robert carro cece in
portland oregon hi cece
hi mr carol i enjoyed your talk um one
of the conversations in your talk was
about
the southern democrats and i wondered if
you could elaborate on their movement
to the republican party after
the passage of the civil rights all of
us have heard about johnson's quote and
i'm paraphrasing i think i've just lost
the south you know permanently
um the democratic party has and so i was
wondering then if you could talk about
his if he as a political tactician knew
that through the passage of the civil
rights
bills that
that the south would be away from would
be lost from the democratic party
permanently or
you know prior to um it actually
happening and when he was trying to get
the bill passed he realized that
that that vote was going to be lost at
that time do you think
yes
you have the quote almost right he he
didn't say i think we've gone
south to the republican party he says
we've just handed the south to the
republican party for the next 40 years
johnson always you know had this desire
to help poor people people of color when
he becomes president i talked in my talk
about how he had that even when he was
teaching
uh mexican children
while he was taking time off from
college when he was like 20 years old
and when he becomes president you know
the first night
that he's president
uh
or in fact i have that wrong the second
night
they're writing his first his speech to
congress uh we
we shall continue speech after kennedy's
assassination and they're writing it
four or five of his advisors are writing
it around the kitchen table in his home
in washington and they're all advising
him not to make civil rights a key issue
because you can't win the republic the
democrats in congress are too strong
it's a lost cause it may be a noble
cause but it's a lost cause don't spend
your political capital on this cause and
lyndon johnson looks at them and says
well what the hell is a presidency for
then and he starts immediately in that
speech to say our number one priority is
civil rights
and to watch him push that bill through
of course is to see political genius in
action sometimes you wonder if we would
have a civil rights bill today if lyndon
johnson hadn't been president then
you know if i can just add one thing to
it
other people wonder how sincere he is
one of them was one of kennedy's a's and
speechwriter for kennedy who later
became a speechwriter for johnson named
richard goodwin very brilliant man
and
goodwin raises
some questions similar to yours with
johnson and johnson says you know
years ago when i was teaching those kids
i swore that if i ever had the power to
help him i was going to use it he says
now i have the power and i'll tell you a
secret i mean to use it the passage of
power is the name of mr carroll's most
recent volume on lbj and as robert
carroll writes in this book
uh about his publisher
sonny mayda has never asked him when his
next volume will be due but we will ask
him that question here on book tv when
is the next volume well peter i could
give you an answer
three or four years but why would you
believe me
next call for robert carro lewis in
sedona arizona hi lewis hi
hi uh mr caro yes i'm an 89-year-old
retired clinical psychologist and
psychoanalyst
given your study of president johnson
you have learned a great deal about the
way in which certain techniques
used by the president could influence
congress
if president obama called you to the uh
white house and sat with you
and asked you
given uh given my i'll make believe i'm
president obama make
given my different personality from
president johnson's uh what do you think
i would have to do
in order to
affect congress with some of the same uh
powers that president johnson did
well it's a good question uh
let me say uh first that i i wouldn't
really answer it because what i learned
in doing these books is you don't really
know what's happening behind the scenes
unless you do the research on it i
haven't done the research on you know
this period the second thing you know i
do i would like to say
i think president obama has
some
achievements with congress that he's not
given enough credit for i think when
history looks back it says that 30 plus
million people raided to the
health insurance rolls through his
health insurance bill that's going to be
quite a change uh quite a you know uh
martin luther king said the moral arc of
the universe spends slowly but it bends
towards justice i think that was a
bending towards justice there are things
wrong with the health care bill but you
know what johnson would have said he
said he said it about the civil rights
bill which was also a very flawed bill
he said the important thing is to pass
it once you pass it it's easier to go
back and fix it
next call marion in augusta georgia
good morning to you good morning and
thank you mr cara for your distinguished
work for us all thank you yes i wonder
if you came across things in your
research that suggested
president johnson experienced some moral
compunction
about his behavior at some point
it's very striking that he's so on the
side of the angels with civil rights and
other
important issues
but so unscrupled in in accomplishing
those
wonderful goals thank you
well that's you know that's another
really terrific question you're talking
about ends and means the ends are noble
a civil rights bill for example
medicare
uh you know
lyndon johnson said it's the job of
government to take care of the bent
and the ill the bent mint the stooped
the old the agent
his methods are ruthless
cruel sometimes
really painful to write about so i write
in my books that the life of lyndon
johnson the things he accomplished
the means he used to accomplish them are
really an examination of the
relationship between ends and means is
not a simple answer to it
and we are talking here with robert caro
at the national book festival
in april his the years of lyndon johnson
the passage of power came out the fourth
in his series on lbj and the next call
for him comes from don in new haven
connecticut don you're on book tv
thanks uh hi mr carol hello to talk to
you
um uh quick question uh would we have
medicare and medicaid today if it was
not for uh president johnson
well you know i i'm can i say on that
particular question that's a that's
really a major
um
thing i examine in the book i'm writing
now and i haven't done i haven't
finished
uh and i haven't even finished my
thinking completely on it so i i'm not
going to go into too much detail i'd
just say to watch him
ram medicare and medicaid through
congress through a congress that didn't
want it i mean uh
really
is to watch as i said before political
genius in action and um you say
he accomplished things and you really
wonder could any president have
accomplished them uh after him
and if you need more of robert caro mr
carro did a two-hour q a on c-span back
in april and may of this year you can go
to c-span.org you can go to the search
function type in his name and you can
watch both hours from q a now the last
call for robert carro comes from
margaret in orange county california
margaret please go ahead
margaret we're listening
and i think margaret is all gone so let
me say two hours of robert carroll is
more than enough
robert carro has been our guest here at
book tv at the national book festival
here again is the passage of power the
years of lyndon johnson and once again
mr carro what's the time frame that this
volume
covers it starts in 1958 when johnson
starts to run for the presidency and it
ends on january 8
1964. with his first state of the union
speech for about five years so we very
much appreciate your time here at book
tv now there's a full day of event
coverage at the history and biography
tent coming up next the next event that
we're going to show you live is
elizabeth dowling taylor a slave in the
white house paul jennings and the
madisons about a slave that was owned by
james and dolly madison that will be
coming up in a little while following
that is pulitzer prize winner john lewis
gaddis talking about his biography of
george cannon and those are the two
events the next two events in the
history and biography tent reminder if
none of this is catching your fancy you
can go over to booktv.org and watch our
live webcast from the contemporary life
pavilion tent here at the national book
fest so you got two options this year to
watch us at the national book festival
booktv.org the entire schedule for both
is available there and our webcasts are
available there but coming up next here
on book tv on c-span 2
tom friedman and michael mandelbaum
we'll be taking your calls about that
used to be us their national bestseller
book tv covered these two authors a
little earlier uh
probably in this book this just came out
in paperback so we covered them about a
year ago
when their hardback came out and we want
to show you just a little bit of that as
we get them here on our set at the
national book festival
whenever people hear the title of our
book
that used to be us
american history tv continues on c-span
3 and we want to welcome from new york
historian and author robert carro among
his books the years of lyndon johnson
the passage of power
and november 22 1963 dallas thanks very
much for being with us
pleasure to be back here
i want to begin with the headline that
lyndon johnson woke up to on the morning
of november 22 1963 from the dallas news
yarborough snubbing lbj
set up that headline what was going on
in texas
well that headline is really a symbol of
the position lyndon johnson was in
on the morning of november 22nd
he had been humiliated and powerless
during the three years of his vice
presidency kennedy had brought him to
texas one of one of the aims was to
patch up the division between the
yarboro wing the liberal wing and the
conservative wing in texas johnson
couldn't even get senator ralph
yarborough to ride with him in a car the
day before so in a motorcade he and lady
bird had had to sit conspicuously alone
in the back seat of this car and all the
reporters knew why he was alone that
yarborough wouldn't even run ride with
him there were other things going on
with regard to lyndon johnson including
an investigation here in washington d.c
what was happening
well you know on that very morning two
things were going on that would have
affected lyndon johnson's career
and pot and possibly wrecked it
there was a huge investigation about his
assistant in the senate bobby baker it
had been going on for months and it had
been coming closer and closer to lyndon
johnson but the link between baker was
still the bobby baker scandal it was on
the front on the cover of all the
magazines but john's it involved call
girls payoffs
and
campaign contributions
and kickbacks but johnson hadn't been
linked to it but that very morning in
fact as the motorcade was going through
dallas
a witness named don b reynolds a
maryland insurance broker
was being
interviewed by investigators of the
senate rules committee in the senate
office building and he was actually
pushing across the table to them checks
and invoices that would have tied
johnson to the scandal for the first
time it was while he was doing this that
the shots rang out in dallas
we're looking at uh footage of the last
two days film of president kennedy as he
toured through dallas but explain
this feud who was it with and why was it
so important for john f kennedy to
travel along with his vice president and
the sitting governor across the state
well you know texas was key
to democrats chances in presidential
elections
kennedy had calculated
that he couldn't that when he he
selected johnson as vice president
as his vice presidential uh running mate
because he needed tech the votes of
texas he also needed money from texas
texas was a source of huge campaign
contributions for the democratic party
and he needed a united party in texas
and johnson of course was his vice
president
and kennedy was becoming
uh increasingly disenchanted with the
fact that johnson although he was from
texas
wasn't able to unite the party down
there
robert carro there's also another factor
in fact if i can tell you you know
the governor john connolly had once been
lyndon johnson's assistant he was
johnson's protege
but in be in planning the trip to texas
kennedy summoned john connelly to
washington and they met the two of them
johnson wasn't even there the trip was
planned without him you know i spoke to
john connelly about this
johnson learns while conor lee's there
that he's meeting with kennedy and
hasn't been invited he had previously
invited conley to have dinner at his
house with him in lady bird so connolly
shows up and johnson meets him at the
door and connolly told me johnson said
to him i guess you think i don't care
about texas anymore
and i asked conley what was johnson's
attitude
and he said irritated
and i remember saying irritated and
kindly said well
hurt
hurt would be a better word
ah but it's very significant in
examining lyndon johnson's career
that in planning the trip to texas he
met with connolly without johnson even
being present
well there was another headline i was
going to ask you about richard nixon
predicting
that that jack kennedy was going to drop
lyndon johnson in 1964. how serious was
that threat
well
uh we don't we don't know what was in
kennedy's uh
mind nobody really knows that it is a
fact that he said to his long-time
secretary evelyn lincoln to whom he
talked very frankly she had worked for
him for a long time
that
it i i forget his exact quote
that it would be necessary to have
someone else on the ticket someone more
in tune with his own aims for his second
term but in public kennedy repeatedly
over and over again said of course
lyndon johnson will be on the ticket of
course you have to remember that before
kennedy pick johnson as his nominee he
repeatedly assured people that johnson
would not be on the ticket and the
relationship between robert f kennedy
and lyndon johnson during the two and a
half years that he was attorney general
what was it like well you know
you have to say as a historian
you hate to use loaded words like hate
but hate is not too strong a word to
describe the relationship between robert
kennedy and lyndon johnson those two men
hated each other and during the
time of lyndon johnson's vice presidency
bobby kennedy who had the power because
his brother was president
took every opportunity to humiliate
johnson he once had a party out of his
home in hickory hill
a birthday party i think it was and as a
present he was given a voodoo doll and
to stick of lyndon johnson and they
stuck pins in it to the merriment of
everybody who was there you know johnson
couldn't even get a plane to take him
somewhere without robert kennedy or one
of roberts kennedy's aides signing off
on it had to have every speech cleared
by the white house
the kennedy people even had a nickname
for lyndon johnson rufus cornpone they
called them rufus cornpone or uncle
cornpone
they had a nickname even for him
and ladybird they used to call him uh
uncle cornpone and his little
pork chop they wouldn't many of them
wouldn't call him mr vice president they
would call him lyndon which humiliated
him
and yet was his selection as vice
president
was his election as vice president key
to kennedy's victory in 1960
oh absolutely and uh the kennedy
people knew that you know in
people forget
dwight eisenhower in the last two
presidential elections before 1960 had
carried texas by huge margins
and
kennedy was in trouble in texas also
because of his civil rights stands
johnson
carried texas for kennedy not by very
much
narrowly
if johnson hadn't been on the tickets
you really feel texas would not have
gone for kennedy but johnson also
brought back into the democratic party
five southern states that had been for
dwight eisenhower in 56 kennedy had to
have those states
our phone lines are open and we are
dividing the phone lines regionally
202-585-3880 for those of you who live
in the eastern or central time zones and
for those of you in the mountain of
pacific time zones the number to call us
202-585-3881
you can also send us uh
an email or you can join us on facebook
at facebook.com slash american history
history tv i should say and you can also
join us online the hashtag c-span chat
let's go to jeff joining us from the
bronx in new york go ahead jeff
uh mr cairo it's an honor to speak with
you
in the latest show in the latest volume
of your magnificent biography of lyndon
johnson
you write that only minutes after the
assassination of president kennedy lbj
sees fit
to learn the wording of the
constitutional oath of office he's going
to take
in a little while by personally
telephoning and inquiring of the
nation's attorney general bobby kennedy
who's still
shocking and distraught and my question
to you and this is of course a question
that any first year law student
could have answered not to mention
thousands of justice department
employees my question
is there a charitable or benign
explanation for that phone call on
lyndon johnson's part
well that's a terrific question it's not
easy to answer it very quickly
the answer to you could he have learned
the oath without calling robert kennedy
nicholas katzenbach who was the deputy
attorney general
said he could have called any one of a
hundred federal
officials it's in the law books is in
it's in the constitution he didn't have
to call robert kennedy frankly calling
him so soon after his brother's death it
was just a matter of minutes was
appalling you know johnson calls robert
kennedy whom he hated
uh from
air force one
and i talked to
lyndon johnson's secretary marie famer
johnson had put her on an extension to
take down the wording of the oath when
she got it robert kennedy patched in
nicholas katzenbach in washington to
give the oath and i asked marie feymere
to describe the call and she said
katzenbach's voice was like steel
when he began
robert kennedy's wasn't
i kept thinking he shouldn't be doing
this
uh you say well there could be there
were reasons that johnson called the
attorney general he needed a legal
opinion on whether he should be sworn in
immediately why not get it from the
nation's highest legal officer the
attorney general
uh
but you also say um
what were the human motives involved of
course
all of us can only speculate on that
carl is joining us next from elizabeth
new jersey with historian robert carrow
good morning good afternoon yes cole hi
carl thank you thank you i i have two
questions mr carol
how
a responsible historian and biographer
would handle two issues
and i do put you in that category very
highly if a president is clinically
bipolar or an older parlance manic
depressive should that be ignored or
glossed over and two
regarding a significant question about
lee harvey oswald
whether he acted alone or in concert
with someone else
if on the day after the assassination
jager hoover calls the new president
and says
we have very uh
disturbing evidence
both photographic and
audio audiotape that someone has
impersonated oswalt
soviet embassy in mexico city eight
weeks before the assassination should
that be told or hidden from you
on page 392. do you intentionally
mischaracterize that thank you
well i'm sure i don't mischaracterize
whatever it is you're talking about
i don't know what you're talking about
the conspiracy theorists of ge of whom i
guess you're one
uh
have a lot of theories about this i'm
going to leave the conspiracy debate
to the conspiracy
theorists uh and the answer to your
first question about bipolar a manic
depressive or however you put that
i'm not a psycho historian
but i haven't seen any evidence
that lyndon johnson was either one of
these two things
and we should point out if you are
interested in this issue as well we'll
further delve into the warren commission
this friday the day after thanksgiving
here on c-span 3's american history tv
beginning at 10 o'clock eastern time 10
o'clock friday morning we'll also take a
look at the various conspiracy theories
in a set of programming on friday
afternoon check out the schedule at
cspan.org robert carroll let's go back
to the moments before the shots were
fired in dealey plaza in texas what was
happening inside lyndon johnson's car
the moments before the well he was
riding you know
the the first car in the procession is
john and jackie kennedy in front of them
john connolly and nelly connolly his
wife and the second car is it's called
the queen mary it's so heavy because
it's so heavy because it's so heavily
armored
there are four secret service agents on
the running boards and inside are more
secret service agents with their
automatic rifles concealed on the floor
then there's a 75 foot gap which the
secret service insisted on and then
there's johnson's car it's a convertible
he's riding in the back seat on the
right side lady birds in the center and
now ralph yarborough
who wouldn't ride with him the day
before was riding with him in dallas
because kennedy had really said to
yarborough if you value my friendship
you will ride with him and your borough
had agreed and he kennedy said to
another aide ken o'donnell
he's going to ride with lyndon if you
have to throw him into the car
and in front of the three in the right
hand seat next to the driver is a secret
service man a tor lanky georgian named
rufus youngblood
and of course it seems so
different by today's standards but the
motorcade route was published in the
dallas news paper and an open-air car
something that we would never see today
why was that back then
well
we hadn't had a president assassinated
that's that's really the best answer to
it
things were done that day the
publication the detailed publication of
the route
the open air limousine of course
president kennedy wanted the top off
because he loved you know the contact
the facial contact if you will with the
crowds and you see it you know what you
see
the effect of him
as they're riding of this through
as they're riding through dallas the
first couple of miles they're going
through a light industrial area so the
car
they're not many people on the sidewalks
but then it turns into the dallas main
street and all of a sudden from every
window in the office buildings and the
department stores are filled with people
cheering the sidewalks are packed from
the curb back to the building line with
people every time jack waves the crowd
presses against the policemen and
presses it presses them back every time
jackie waves the crowd presses even
harder
the opening for the motorcade gets
smaller
the motorcade has to slow down from 20
miles an hour to 15 miles to 10 to five
before it suddenly turns a corner into
this open grassy space which is deeley
plaza
kennedy and jackie's rapport with the
crowd you know nellie connelly the last
thing we know that was said in that car
in that first car is nellie connolly as
the crowds just adoring the kennedys
nellie connolly turns to jack kennedy
and says mr president you can't say that
dallas doesn't love you and mrs connolly
said he gave me the big a big smile back
so the shots were fired do you know the
distance between dealey plaza and
parkland hospital
and what lyndon johnson was doing once
he arrived at the hospital
the exact distance between i don't know
what happens is
when the first shot
is fired uh
young blood turns around and lady bird
says in a diary in a voice i have never
heard him use before
yells get down get down he grabs lyndon
johnson's right shoulder throws him down
on the floor of the back seat jumps over
the front seat and lays on top of
johnson
to protect johnson's body with his own
and uh
you know
youngblood is wearing a a radio the
secret service radio shortwave radio to
which they communicate with each other
and
because he's lying on top of johnson
the radio is right in johnson's ear and
johnson was to recall that he hears
these phrases out of the static he's hit
he's hit let's get out of here then he
hears the word hospital and these three
cars squeal up in the expressway i ramp
onto the expressway
travel along the expressway at this
tremendous rate of speed and then squeal
off at lady bird was to say i didn't
think we were going to make that turn
and into the emergency bay at parkland
hospital
and from there what happened next well
youngblood has said to johnson when we
get there don't stop don't look around
don't look at anything we got to get you
into a secure room who knew it wasn't a
conspiracy you know not only the
president had been shot but governor
connell the governor of texas had been
shot who knew if young blood was in law
at that moment if young blood wasn't
lying on top of lyndon johnson would
there have been a bullet for lyndon
johnson so when they the his car pulls
into that emergency bay and kennedy's
car is right
next to it kennedy's still in it
force but johnson doesn't have a chance
to look at it four secret service agents
yank johnson out of the car and run him
through the hospital as they're running
him there's another secret service agent
with an with an automatic rifle is
following them and they go down one
corridor around another around another
turn until they finally find it's called
the parkland minor medical section a a
room which has been divided into three
cubicles by white muslin hanging
curtains they put johnson against the
far wall youngblood stands in front of
him in the middle one of the three
cubicles he stations two secret service
agents and at the door he puts another
agent and his instructions to this agent
do not let anyone pass unless you
personally know his face and johnson is
standing there for a number of minutes
we really don't
know the number of minutes um
about 40 minutes unable to get any
information about kennedy not knowing
what is going on
i'm going to come back to that moment in
just a moment in a moment it will also
remind her to facebook.com
c-span history or join us at c-span chat
with your tweets and let's go to susan
joining us from boston good afternoon
yeah yes
hi mr caro i just want to tell you what
an honor it is to speak with you i'm i
was a history major
and you're just one of my heroes and i i
am from the kennedy era i'm carolyn
kennedy's exact age
and i'm from the state of maryland
where the schreiber family was just
adored they were extraordinary landed
gentry catholics and sergeant shriver
was such a pure
devout
extraordinary man and and in fact among
our circle
we go back to the 18th century maryland
and we are roman catholic but
we felt sergeant was actually slumming
it when he married into the
family
um you know they were viewed as very
crafts and um you know joseph kennedy
had these
um you know with the bootlegging and
other
skeletons in his closets and his
horrible womanizing and all that that
was well known in maryland circles
um
but
i and i didn't grow up in a pro kennedy
household but i grew to love the family
one for exposing the the nation and the
world to the excellence of a
of a catholic background you know the
focus on education and
you know in most cases you know god
fearing great people and um
extraordinary contribution to american
life and culture and politics so that
aside
i would love to have
if you have any insights on how sergeant
shriver
was viewed by the kennedy family
and also how he coped with
the notorious
understanding of jfk's infidelities and
you know bad bad side and the other
thing i would say is um
i also have i grew i grew up during the
war years and i knew you know i knew the
anger and the resentment of the vietnam
conflict and all that but i i just
adored lbj i loved lady bird um and you
know their family and and one of my
great goals is to go to the lbj ranch
and really immerse myself in
um you know his presidential history in
a direct way susan thank you very much
we'll get a response appreciate it
well um
sergeant shriver uh was viewed as a very
you know the
key thing about him he was viewed as
such an able public servant able
administrator that of course he was an
administrator for for the kennedys
uh the head of the peace corps but
lyndon johnson takes the same man
sergeant shriver and puts him in charge
of what is an a cherished program of
lyndon johnson's the war on poverty
so um
can i take a pass on the rest of that
question because it's in the next book
and i haven't written that section yet
and it won't come out and as well if i
talk it out here but i think i i the the
key thing and answer to your question is
that he was so respected
as a as a public servant and
administrator by both johnson and the
kennedys
robert carra was joining us from new
york and all weekend here on c-span 3's
american history tv we are of course
looking back at the 50th anniversary of
the assassination of president john f
kennedy and the swearing-in of our 36th
president lyndon johnson this is a tweet
that we got robert carroll from steve
duvall who wanted to follow up on the
earlier question we had about rfk his
question what were the origins of rfk's
hatred of lbj
yeah that's a good that's a terrific
question let me tell you about the first
time that they met
and what the people who witnessed it
said the first time that they actually
met was in 1953 lyndon johnson was the
mighty majority leader the man who made
the send the most powerful democrat in
the united states
robert kennedy was a young he had just
joined the
mccarthy committee as the assistant
council uh
the following
incident occurred the senate cafeteria
is on the second floor of the senate
office building uh
every there's a big round table by the
cashier every morning senator joe
mccarthy sits there with
four or five of his staff aides
one morning lyndon johnson walks and
accompanied by two assistants george
reedy his speech writer his excuse me
george reedy his press secretary and
horace busby his chief speechwriter
and senator joe mccarthy jumps up as
everybody did with johnson
congratulations on what you did
yesterday mr leader don't know how we
would have won that without you mr
leader great job yesterday mr leader
and his staff jumps up to shake hands
with johnson all except one member of
the staff it's robert kennedy this
slender young kid he won't get up well
johnson sees this in an instant
in a personal such an interpersonal
situation no one is ever going to get
the best of lyndon johnson he knows just
what to do he sort of walks around like
this so that when he gets to robert
kennedy unless kennedy is going to be
deliberately snub him he has to get up
and he's forced to get up and shake his
hand too i asked reedy and busby
johnson's two aides
what was going on there and
they both said sort of the same thing
i'll tell you ready's words he said
did you ever see two strange dogs who
come into a room and all of a sudden the
hair rises on the back of their neck and
there's this low growl
these were two people
who just had a antipathy towards each
other from the first time they saw each
other they couldn't look at each other
uh
that was the depth of the feeling there
of course there are other reasons that
you you can induce to that but it's this
personal uh they couldn't even look at
each other that's a crucial thing you
know after at the democratic ninth
convention in 1960 after jack kennedy
offers lyndon johnson his vice vice
presidential nomination on his ticket
three times in that day robert kennedy
goes down the stairs in the biltmore
hotel from the kennedy suite which is
93-33
down the back stairs to johnson's suite
which is 73-33 to try to get lyndon
johnson to withdraw from the ticket
johnson never forgot that day it was a
day of utter humiliation for him and
whatever his feelings were for robert
kennedy before this hatred was really uh
deepened so let's go back to the early
afternoon hours of november 22nd 1963.
president kennedy has been declared dead
he was delivered the last rites by two
priests
what does lyndon johnson do next
johnson is standing in this cubicle at
the other end of parkland hospital from
where the doctors are working on jack
kennedy
twice he's
sent someone out to try to find out
kennedy's condition both times the man
comes back and says all the doc all i
can learn is that the doctors are still
working on the president
then after about 40 minutes as i say i
don't have the exact number of minutes
lady bird was to write in her diary well
kenny o'donnell was an aide very close
to jack kennedy he was his appointment
secretary
and he had been campaigning with kennedy
for 20 years or so
and late he walks through the door into
the cubicle where lyndon johnson is and
lady bird
says seeing the stricken face of kenny
o'donnell who loved him we knew
a moment later another kennedy a comes
running through the door
runs up to lyndon johnson for orders and
begins by saying mr president that's
really the first that lyndon johnson
knows that he is president in that
moment the secret service
youngblood and the others surround them
and say we got to get you back to the
plane right away and take off and fly
back to washington the safest place for
you is in the white house we can keep
you safe there again no one knew if it
was a conspiracy or not
johnson instantly and decisively says no
i'm not leaving the hospital without mrs
kennedy's
without mrs kennedy they say but she
won't leave without her husband's body
johnson said that's all right then we'll
go to the plane and i'll wait for her
and the body there but i'm not leaving
dallas without her and he orders young
blood to get them back to the plane he
says
he's giving orders in different cars
than they arrived in by a different
route than they've arrived in don't turn
the sirens on on the police cars and
they hurry out of the hospital uh
youngblood gordon johnson johnson homer
thornberry other secret service agents
lady bird says that was one of the
swiftest walks i ever took getting and
they drive without sirens turned off to
love feel and run up youngblood says we
almost ran up the steps to air force one
where he felt he could keep johnson at
least relatively safe and of course that
iconic photograph of lyndon johnson
being sworn in here's just a portion of
that process as our 36th president took
the oath of office
at 238 in the forward cabin of air force
one a necessary ceremony
the constitution of the united states
from the afternoon of november 22 1963
and lauren is joining us from richmond
virginia with author and historian
robert carro good afternoon
mr carol
excuse me um
there were three other assassinations
there's lincoln elected 1860
garfield 1880 and mckinley 1900
and uh
i was just wondering uh why did uh
wait why did um johnson run for vice
president if he didn't
like kennedy
and do you think johnson could deal with
the republicans today
we'll get a response
well i i i forgot the first hair for
that why did johnson yes why did johnson
run with kennedy if he didn't like how
you know politics isn't always a
matter of doing
something with someone you like we we
actually know one johnson
would say
actually not a few times in his life
that if you were from texas if you were
from a southern state the vice
presidency was the only route by which
you were going to get to be president uh
he didn't necessarily mean by an
assassination he didn't mean even by the
death of a president he just meant that
a vice president uh
ceases to be a local southern figure and
becomes a national figure but he also
was aware that seven times in american
history i pray
a vice president had succeeded to the
presidency
um
so he he was calculating uh those things
and that's
a reason
that he
took it
he didn't anticipate
that the kennedys would cut him out of
power so completely he underestimated
jack kennedy he didn't realize how tough
he was he probably didn't realize what
was going to happen to him as vice
president how powerless he was going to
become
i'm sorry i forgot your second the
second half of your question well
i'm going to come back to that second
part but i want to read this tweet from
glenn because i know the the johnson
tapes have been a source for you and
many of the historians we've been airing
them on c-span and c-span radio and this
is from glenn who says when did lbj
first become aware of the white house
taping system
um
that's a good question to which i'm
afraid i don't know the answer
one of his first acts was to create the
warren commission why yes
he real well he realizes that
that there's a real danger
of people of
of
let me start over we're we're only 13
months past the cuban missile crisis
um
nuclear confrontation the verge of
nuclear war with russia over cuba
who knew in those first days there are
these headlines oswald visits soviet
embassy in mexico city
oswald has ties to anti-castro group
who knew
if this was part of a conspiracy in
which russia or cuba is involved johnson
realizes it's very important that this
uh
that that rumors not be not so he's
worried about what will happen
if a a belief becomes widespread that
russia was behind us
he's worried about nuclear war he
realizes he has to have a commission
headed by someone as respected as earl
warren to do an investigation that's not
to say
that the warren commission did a good
job in its investigation it didn't
although a house select committee that
investigated again in 1975 did do a
thorough job and reached basically
the bottom line the the same conclusions
but johnson realizes he has to set he
has to
set the mall he has to have this and has
to have the american people believe that
an investigation is being carried out by
a very respected commission
and the other part of the caller's
question by the way was how lbj would
deal with the republicans today do you
want to quickly discuss that
well john yes you know today yes you
know johnson was a political genius
um
political genius is knowing how and part
of it is to solve things that other
people can't solve we say today that
there's never been a situation quite
like the tea party opposition in
congress
but
people forget
johnson was facing
a congress that was also again it wasn't
divided by parties it was divided the h
his party
the southern democrats in the senate and
the house
particularly in the senate controlled
the key committees every key committee i
think of the 16
if this is the right number the right
year of the 16 great standing committees
in the senate i think
southerners if i have the year right
were chairman of nine of them and they
could they had stacked the other one so
they basically had control of most of
those also they were the powers in
congress and they were unalterably
opposed to civil rights and they were
united with the midwestern republican
conservatives and they had really
stopped
uh president after president from
getting civil rights or any meaningful
uh social welfare legislation through
for a quarter of a century so johnson
the senate was stuck johnson becomes
senate uh
senator
senator becomes president and instantly
uh he finds a way
to get around the southerners you know
richard russell the leader of the
southern bloc said you know we could
have beaten
jack kennedy on civil rights we could
never beat lyndon
and
i think that you have to say that a
political genius
finds a way around obstacles i don't
know what lyndon johnson would do with
the republicans today i certainly would
be fascinated to watch him
our guest is robert carro his book the
years of lyndon johnson passage of power
also dallas november 22nd 1963.
phyllis is joining us from rochester
michigan
good
from afternoon of michigan tell us if
you can turn the volume down we're
getting a little bit of feedback go
ahead with your questions okay
actually my question was answered
because i was gonna ask
um
if uh
the speaker could elaborate more on why
the
kennedys did not like lbj
well phyllis let me take that point and
take it one step further what was the
personal relationship robert carro
between john kennedy and lyndon johnson
well the personal relationship
before
he becomes vice president
johnson doesn't have respect for kennedy
at all johnson you know considered
himself and was in most instances a
reader of men a great reader of men but
he read jack kennedy wrong you know what
he says about him
when kennedy was a senator and he was a
majority leader he says jack kennedy was
pathetic as a senator he didn't even
know how to address the chair meaning he
didn't know the rules
uh he believed that he was in such poor
health that he was likely to die soon he
used to call him sickly that's a word
johnson would use he's sickly sickly
sickly he used to say to reporters do
you ever see his ankles they're only
this big around uh he's yellow he's
young his skin was yellow he's malaria
ridden he's sickly
uh
after as soon as kennedy becomes
president
johnson realizes how tough kennedy can
be he doesn't realize that kennedy
although he's been ill a lot of his life
is now much better because court the
disease he had addison's disease they
discovered cortisone as a miracle drug
for addison's disease and kennedy starts
to get more energy to fill out to become
the confident jack kennedy we know so
johnson underestimates kennedy
terribly
um
as for kennedy's feelings about johnson
you know they one reason for thinking
it's a very complicated question but one
reason for thinking that they kept
johnson under such tight reign when he
was vice president is they had seen
johnson in his days of power how he
dominated washington how he ran the
senator made the senate work how he
introduced legislation wrote legislation
got bills passed they may have been
afraid
that if they gave johnson a little
running room he would really uh become
uh too dominant the figure in washington
david is next from maple valley
washington good afternoon
hi
hello
yes sir
yes sir
i'm always always curious about the the
process of uh
coming through the motorcade
uh before they hit daley plaza
and
they always took that hard right turn
just before they had to make that
sweeping left slow down on elm
why didn't they just on the motorcade
come just straight straight to the
underpass right to the
freeway to get over to the trademark
without having to go around
and the other one was
before besides having the information of
the motorcade route published
i don't know when it was that it was
published but
somebody got oswell that job in that
book depository
and
he had so much information that the fbi
and people knew about him it's odd that
the very last point on that motorcade
they just didn't take the straight path
right to the
freeway we'll get a response
well i don't know why they took the
route they took instead of another uh
route
um
that's about the only uh
way i can answer that question so let's
move forward to the the afternoon and
evening hours as president johnson comes
back to to washington
does he go to the white house obviously
mrs kennedy is still living there what
are the first steps he takes the weekend
that led up to president kennedy's
funeral which was 50 years ago tomorrow
well the first steps he takes if i can
just go back a second uh and not on the
when he gets to the white house but
actually on the plane going back to
washington you know we know uh it's
really
impressive
indeed uh
revelatory of johnson's political genius
to see what he does
with so little preparation you know
today
there's 11 weeks between election day
and inauguration day and political
scientists say
those 11 weeks are not enough time to
prepare yourself for the modern
presidency but johnson's preparation
time was two hours and six minutes he
takes the oath of office and ifos one
the plane then his next words are let's
get airborne the plane takes off and in
two hours and six minutes it lands in
washington and he has to be prepared to
take over the presidency of the united
states
and what does he do on the plane well we
know some of the things he plans on the
plane because he jot there's a list
the notepads on air force one are headed
aboard air force one and one of them
johnson writes one staff two cabinet
three leadership he means he wants to
meet as soon as he gets back to
washington with kennedy's top staff with
the cabinet and with the congressional
leadership he's told on the plane that
not only
that six members of the cabinet
including the secretary of state dean
rusk and
the secretary of the treasury douglas
dillon and the press secretary pierre
salinger aren't even in washington
they're all on one plane together
halfway across the pacific going to an
economic conference in japan the gov the
government's in an unusually vulnerable
position johnson says turn that plane
around and worry and the plane in the
middle of the pacific makes a u-turn and
starts heading back to washington uh
johnson knows the importance of
reassuring the american people of
showing them continuity and stability
that a president is dead but the
government goes on and you see
what he's doing in the orders that
crackle over the radio from air force
one to washington the secret service in
washington says when air force one lands
take it to the
the most remote part of andrews air
force base it'll be surrounded by guards
johnson
gets this information and he sends
an aid
up to the cockpit and the aide
talks back to the washington says no the
plane is to go to its normal position
the press is to be put in its normal
position everything is to be normal to
give the people the the understanding
that he has continuity it's terribly
impressive to see him uh
do that as soon as he gets back to
washington in the answer to your
question he does other he he acts with a
such a decisiveness he tells the kennedy
the key kennedy people
mcnamara uh secretary of defense robert
mcnamara
uh assistant secretary of state george
ball etc mcgeorge bundy the national
security adviser
you have to stay on
we have to show people that the
government's continuing
jack kennedy needs you needed you i need
you even more and he gets all the
kennedy people including kennedy people
who despised him who looked down on him
uh who had been ridiculing him he gets
them all to stay on
and uh he does it all
with such rapidity that it's amazing to
see robert carro his latest book on
lyndon johnson passage to power and of
course dallas november 22nd
1963 joining us from new york as we take
a look back at the events as they
unfolded 50 years ago thanks very much
for being with us here on c-span 3.
pleasure as always
and we'll continue with our look author
and historian timothy nathalie will be
joining us to give us his perspective on
the kennedy legacy his two years and 10
months in the white house but more from
50 years ago and refl